hey guys welcome to this full stack
development video
this full course video will cover
various technologies used in application
development
the video will go in depth for each tool
and framework in the roadmap to become a
successful full stack developer
but before we begin if you haven't
subscribed to our channel already make
sure to hit the subscribe button and the
bell icon to never miss an update so
here's what we'll be covering in this
session
first we look at a simple introduction
to what exactly full stack development
is
then we learn the most popularly used
version control system that is git which
helps you manage your project files
next we'll look at a tutorial on the
commonly used front-end framework that
is angular
moving on we'll understand back-end
development and learn about node.js
talking about database management
systems we'll look at tutorials on
mongodb and mysql now after this we look
at an angular tutorial on how to build
an admin dashboard moving further ahead
we'll have a section covering maven and
jenkins
finally coming to testing tools we learn
the working of selenium and lastly we'll
conclude the session by understanding
the popularly used continuous
integration and continuous development
tool docker i hope you're excited for
this video so let's jump right in so now
what exactly is front end every time you
open a website it has several ui
components
and once you click on a particular icon
say sign in in this case you get
navigated to the sign in or the login
page right so what happens is that all
of these items facilitate navigation and
utility
these are collectively called as the
front end
so the front end is the visible part of
the website or the web application which
is responsible for user experience
the user directly interacts with the
front-end portion of the website or the
web application
so now let's have a look at some of the
front-end languages
so i'm sure you've heard of html css and
javascript so these are collectively
called the frontend languages when it
comes to html it defines the structure
of websites and formats the web pages
it also defines text documentation so
let's look at a simple example so here
i've made use of the h1 tag which is the
heading tag in html and have displayed
the message hello welcome
so correspondingly my website displays
the same message
so html is responsible or defines what
is being shown on the website
next up is css now css is a style sheet
that allows you to alter and style
different web components beat size
font spacing etc it makes the content on
the website look more decorative correct
so now if you have a look at the code
here i've added some styling i've
changed the font style to italic i've
made the text bold and i've changed the
color to red and again correspondingly
all the changes are seen on the website
moving on we have javascript now
javascript is a very powerful
client-side scripting language and it is
mainly used for enhancing the
interaction of a user with the web page
so again if you have a look at the code
here i've created a form wherein the
user can enter their name and i've also
displayed the message please enter your
name as a result an input box is made
available where the user can type in
their name
now this is facilitated by javascript so
as i mentioned earlier it is used to
make web pages interactive and bring the
web applications to life so next let's
have a look at some front-end frameworks
and libraries now most of these are
javascript frameworks and libraries
first we have react
then there's angular there's view
there's jquery and then there's
bootstrap
now all of these help develop the front
end of the application however when it
comes to react angular in view it's not
necessary that you must know everything
to create a website one of them will be
sufficient however the usage of react is
on the rise and most of the developers
prefer using react jquery and bootstrap
are also powerful
frameworks that can be used to create
interactive web pages now that you know
what front-end development is you must
be wondering how the data is being
fetched and how this data is being
presented in front of you on your screen
correct now this is all facilitated by
the back end of the application
so let's understand what back-end
development is
now back end basically refers to the
server-side development of the
application
it is responsible for managing all the
database with the help of queries and
apis so every time the user makes a
request it queries the database and
retrieves the data from the database and
presents it to the user
and lastly it ensures data consistency
so now let's have a look at some
back-end languages and frameworks
firstly we have node node and express js
are packages provided by javascript
then there's python which is a very
popularly used language
python frameworks like django and flask
are
popularly used to create the backend of
applications
then there's java and java provides
spring and java server faces which are
also used for back-end development
then there's
c-sharp which provides frameworks like
asp.net core and asp.net mvc and other
popularly used backend languages are php
there's perl and ruby
database is the collection of
interrelated data which helps in
efficient retrieval insertion and
deletion of data from database and
organizes the data in the form of tables
views schemas reports
now some of the commonly used database
management systems are mysql there's
postgresql there's microsoft sql server
there's oracle database and then there's
mongodb today i'm going to cover a few
essential git commands and walk you
through a demonstration for most of it i
begin by installing a git bash or the
git client and configuring it for its
first time usage once i'm done with
configuring the git client i'm going to
spin up few repositories locally and
work on these repositories using git
commands once i'm happy with my local
changes i'm going to commit few of them
and then push these changes to a git
server of my choice for today's
demonstration i plan to use github.com
which is a cloud hosted free service and
it provides free account registrations
for anyone eventually i will cover few
topics regarding git branching and
merging because these two in my opinion
are the killer features of the git
distributed version control tool kit is
one of the most popular distributed
version control tools of recent times
and like any other distributed version
control tool it allows us to perform
various version control tasks without
really needing a network connection
before i jump into my demonstration let
me spend some time explaining to you the
git client server working model what
does it take for a couple of users to
collaborate and start working with git
the bare minimal thing that any user
would need in order to start working
with kit is something called as git bash
or the git client this comes as an
installer for all popular operating
systems like windows all flavors of
windows linux mac os and other operating
systems so once you install git bash you
get a command line utility using which
you can fire up your git commands and
ensure that you can bring up
repositories you can work with these
repositories by adding files to it
committing changes to it and all those
git commands would work perfectly well
so you can bring up a small repository
and you can work with your repository
using this git bash but what does it
take for you to share this repository
with another user who has also got git
bash installed on his system this is
where you would need something called as
a gig server
so for user one or one user to share his
repository with another user he would
need to collaborate using something
called as a git server so in the present
market there are a bunch of git servers
which are popularly available some of
them are free some of them come with
cost because they are licensed a bunch
of these servers that i can think of are
github which is one of the most popular
kit servers that is around in the market
for a long time now it comes with two
variants one is the cloud hosted one
which is the github.com and then the
other one is an enterprise server which
comes as a black box that can be
installed into your data centers so
typically organizations who don't want
their source code to be put up on the
cloud but go for this github enterprise
servers wherein they buy these servers
and these servers are hosted on their
data centers other popular variant of
the git server is bitbucket this is from
the famous atlassian products and it
integrates very well with all other
atlassian products like jira in recent
times there's one other variant of the
git server called gitlab which is
getting very very popular these days
because gitlab not just provides a git
server it also provides something called
as a runner this is a part of the
continuous integration strategy where as
soon as you have a source code check-in
that is going in you have this runner
that kicks up and builds your particular
project so all these are bundled
together in a git lab and git lab also
provides you with a community edition
which is almost free of cost having said
that there are a bunch of these tools
available for my demonstration what i'm
going to do is i've already registered
myself on the github.com by providing my
username and my password and i'm going
to use a free account so whatever
repositories that i'm going to put up on
this server is all public by default so
i want to register myself by using my
username or my email id and my password
so this set of authentication is also
referred to as https authentication
so in order for me to share my
repository with say user 2 the first
thing that i got to do was have an
access to a git server where both user 1
and user 2 are set up so once i have
that i can push my repository onto this
server and provide right kind of access
so that user 2 or the other developer
who wishes to collaborate with me on
this repository can use his credentials
as long as he's registered properly on
the git server he can use his
credentials and pull down this
repository and work with this repository
so this is the https way of
authenticating and sharing repositories
another popular way of sharing
repositories or working with each other
is called as ssh authentication as many
of you would know ssh means nothing but
creation of a private and a public key a
bunch of keys public and private are
created on the client machine while i
create a keys i will be asked for a
passphrase i need to type in a
passphrase and remember my passphrase
and then i take this public key and kind
of post it onto my account within my git
server so that whenever i'm going to
connect next time using my command
prompt or any of the tools it's going to
challenge me for my passphrase as long
as i remember my phrase correctly i can
authenticate myself and get into the
server so both https and ssh are popular
ways of communicating with the git
server having said this let me just get
started by installing the git bash on my
local system and then fire up some of
these git commands and build up some
repositories make some changes in my
repository commit these changes and
later use my github credential to
connect to my github server and push my
repositories out there
let me now go ahead and find my git bash
for my windows so that i can go ahead
and install it so i just type in get
client for windows open up a browser and
type in for this the first one that i
find as a gui tool i don't need this gui
client i need this one
so this is the git client or the git
bash that i was referring to it's about
40 megs and let me just download this
pause this video for some time so that
the download happens and come back to
you once i have the download the
download seems to be complete when i'm
recording this video the version that i
have the latest version that is there is
2.19.0
and this is a 64-bit version for windows
so i've got that downloaded let me go
ahead and find it and install this exe
all right i go ahead choosing all the
default options i want it to be
installed in c colon program files under
the git folder
everything looks good for me i'm not
going to make any changes here
get bash from windows yes i may want to
use git from windows command prompt that
sounds good for me open ssh that's fine
looks good looks good
now i don't want any of these new
features
so what i'm doing is installing the git
bash or the git client so that i can
start using my git commands
the version that i'm using is 2.19.0
which as i record this video this
happens to be the latest version
all right so looks good i don't want to
see the release notes i'll say again
launch git bash
so what i get is this window so this is
the git command prompt so let me check
if everything is looking good say get
version it sounds good
say get
help all right a lot of git help
commands
everything looks good so i ended up
installing the git bash i can go ahead
with all other commands
now that i have git bash installed on my
system let me open up a git bash prompt
and start using it but before i do
anything i just need to configure it for
the first time stating what would be the
user name and the email id with which i
want the git bash to be configured with
the command to do that is get config
hyphen iphone global which means that
this setting that i'm going to set would
be a global setting user dot name and
this the name of the user would need to
be specified within a double code in my
case i am using the simply learn account
which is the official account and this
is the particular user name of this
account the other setting is nothing but
git config hyphen f1 global this is also
global setting
and this would be the email id
the email id need not contain a double
quote
so in my case this is the email id that
i would be setting up git to work with
all right let me check if the
configurations were set correctly or not
all right if you see this the username
and the email id has been picked up the
way i wanted it to be picked up looks
good so far all right so what do we do
next by default whenever you open up the
git prompt you're placed into your home
directory let me create a folder here
which would be a repository folder from
where i'm going to create all my
multiple git repositories so i will
create a folder called let's say git
underscore demo
all right
there's already a folder called git demo
so let me just delete that in the first
place and let me create this git demo
again
all right let me navigate to this
particular folder
so this is the folder let me open up
that folder using a command prompt
this is my git demo
so this would be a folder so i would use
this folder as a base folder for
creating all other repositories as a
part of this demo so let me create my
first repository a repository is nothing
but a folder so let me create my first
folder called first
repo
and let me
get into this repo all right as of now
this is just an empty folder
if at all i navigate to this you could
see that this folder is empty there's
nothing much in this folder at all at
this moment
okay so let me create a repository out
of this how do i create a repository of
this it's pretty simple i just run and
get init command
when i say git init it means it's going
to initialize a repository as of now
the folder contained nothing on it was
an empty repository so it initialize an
empty repository in this particular
folder if at all i look at my content
you'd see that there's a hidden folder
this would be a hidden folder since i've
configured my explorer to view all
hidden folders i see it otherwise you
wouldn't see it so a folder by name dot
get is created within this first repo
and this was created because we ran the
command git init
if i get into this folder i see a bunch
of directories and other configurations
if you see there's something called as a
hooks directory
a couple of configuration files that are
here in this directory all these relate
to one or the other type of a client
hook that can be enabled and there's
info there's objects
there's references a bunch of stuff that
is there
so what is this folder this is a magical
git folder and this is created whenever
a repository is initialized so by
default if at all you get into any git
folder or any git repository you would
see this dot get folder a word of
caution do not get into this folder and
try to modify anything because if you
fiddle around with this and corrupt this
particular folder your whole repository
will go for a toss so let me come out of
this and let me show you another thing
now if you notice here when i was in the
folder the repository did not have
anything after this now when i say git
in it there is something called as a
master that shows up so typically what
happens is whenever a git repository is
created for the first time
it creates a default branch the name of
the branch is called master and that is
why you would see master within braces
this doesn't mean anything else other
than we have a repository out in this
particular folder and by default there
is a branch called master and we are
currently on that branch if at all i
create multiple branches in this folder
whenever i navigate to different
branches the branch name within this
brackets would change all right so far
so good so we created a folder we made
it a git repository by initializing that
with the get in it and then i'm not put
anything yet in the repository so let me
try to do that let me create a few files
within this particular repository
so i use a touch command
touch is a linux command it kind of
creates this particular folder if not
you're not comfortable with the file
creation by this way you can always use
a file explorer and create some files in
this so i create a file called
touchmaster.txt i'll open up in the
notepad
okay so this is my first file that's
what i'm going to write inside this
i save this and i come out of this all
right now let me do a git status command
so what does this
tell you there's no commit set you're on
the master branch there is an untracked
file and this shows up in red it also
gives you all the commands that is
supposed to be run so if at all you want
to add this file you would say git add
and the name of the file and then you're
going to commit it
so what happened is that when the
repository was initialized it was an
empty repository now that a git notices
that there is a new file in this
repository called master.txt if at all
you want you want us to let git know
that you want to track this file we need
to add this to the repository so the
command to add that is called git add i
can specify either the name of the file
or i can give a while character saying
git add dot now if i run the git status
command again
it says there's no commits yet
added a file and the file which was
earlier in red now shows up in green and
it says it's a new file master dot text
all right it also gives you something
called git remove command if at all you
want to unstage or undo your changes so
what has happened is the file which was
earlier untracked has been added into
the git index or it is ready for staging
or it's in a staged state now i can go
ahead and commit this file if at all
that's what i want to do so let me do
that
i'll do a kit commit minus m and i give
a message that i want i would say this
is my
first get
commit
all right i run the git status command
again
and see it says on the branch master
nothing to commit it's all nice and
clean so typically what happened was i
created an empty directory made it into
a git folder by doing a git init i put a
file into it i made some changes to the
file i added that file into the
repository and i committed to the
repository if it error i run the git log
command
it says this was the commit id or the
commit
number or the commit hashtag and this is
the author if you notice this is the
email id and the username that we set
earlier this was done on this date and
this is the
commit message that is there all of it
looks so good let me do one more commit
into this repository so i will touch
master one dot text i'll put in another
file
i'll open up this particular file
write something into this
all right i save this change
let me also open up the older
file make some more change into this
all right so what i did i modified the
older file that existed i also added a
new file to my repository now if i run
the git status command
it says modified this file which is
showing in red and it says you have one
more file which is an untracked file
all right now let me add both these
files because these are the changes that
i want to
incorporate i would say git add dot i
run the git status command again
and it says now this is a modified file
this is a new file looks good to me let
me go ahead and commit this so git
commit with the message that says this
is my second commit
all right
if i do a git log now it shows both the
comments the first comment is the one
that that shows up at the bottom and the
topmost one is the latest comment that
is there so far so good if at all you
notice
i'm doing all these git commands without
really connecting it to any git server i
don't need any network connection for
doing any of these things i can keep on
doing more and more git commands and run
git commands the way i want to
without really having any connections to
the kit server
now that i have my changes the way i
wanted and i've checked in all the code
changes into my local repository i may
want to share my repository with
somebody else
and work in a collaborative way so the
way to do that is as i mentioned earlier
to host this repository or to push this
repository onto a kit server i already
have a github account wherein i've
registered myself using my username and
password so i log into my github account
using my username and credentials and
let me go ahead and create a new
repository
my repository is already there on the
local system so what i essentially need
is just a placeholder for my repository
so that i can link them together and
push the content from my local
repository to the server
if you notice the name of my repository
is this first repo
so let me copy this i would create a
folder structure or a repository
structure on the server with the same
name
so that
when i pushed my repository from my
local box it will go ahead and get
created in the server
so the repository name should be the
same as what i created on my local box
description i would say this is my first
git
hub
repository
on the server
this is just an optional description
that will show up
and if you notice i can't have any
private repositories so whatever
repositories that i'm going to create
here would be a public repository so i
choose public and i don't want to
initialize this with a readme file or
anything of that because i already have
a repository with some content with some
code checked in all that i need is a
placeholder for my repository on the
server
so with this option with just the name
and with an optional description and the
repository being public i go ahead and
click on the create repository button
so if you notice it gives me a bunch of
commands that i would need to run in
order to create a repository and pushed
onto the server
and also important point it shows me two
urls one is the https url and the other
one is the ssh url as of now we do not
have any ssh keys that is set up so let
me use this https url to connect my
local repository with the repository on
the server
so i've done all these things i already
have the repository set up all that i
need is a placeholder for me to connect
my local repository with the server url
so this would be the command that i need
to copy
which essentially links or adds an
origin with the url of the git server i
just copy this command
and run it here
get remote add the name of the remote is
called origin and it points to an https
url which is nothing but the placeholder
that i've created on the server
all right so let me check if it's added
correctly
okay the url looks good i'm all set i've
got two comments in my repository i'm
done with all the changes so let me try
to push my repository onto the server
the command for doing it for the first
time is get push hyphen u this is for
linking the upstream
origin
master
so git push hyphen u upstream linking
origin master link the master
branch of my local repository with the
master branch on the server repository
and where is it going to push it is
going to push by default to an origin
and the origin points to this url
all right let me try doing this
so it essentially opens up an url asking
me the credentials with which i need to
log into my github server
so let me just
copy and paste
the username
and the password with which i have
registered
i would say login
okay success
so i'm able to create a repository on
the server and the content seems to be
pushed and it created a new branch
called master it has linked the master
branch from the local repository with
the master branch on the server
so let me go back to my server and
refresh this page
and see if all my commits have come in
master master one dot text if at all i
see the commits there seem to be two
comments this is my first comment this
is my second comment and if at all you
notice each of this commit comes with a
hash key or a hash id which contains the
details of my commits in this commit the
files were added this was a line that
was added if you look at the second
commit
i added these lines
i made this you know one line chain that
was there i also added this new file
which was not existing these are the two
commits that existed
and if you see
the timestamp of the commit
this is the commit which was committed
for 15 minutes ago so what does this
mean is that the commit is the timestamp
when we actually commented the code in
the client the pushing is just after we
have committed the change we have pushed
it so there's no timestamp of the push
that happened
this completes the first part of the
tutorial wherein i create a repository
on the client and then i pushed it to
the server after creating a repository
skeleton on the server
now let me demonstrate to you the ssh
configuration that is required for
creating a pair of ssh keys and ensuring
that i connect to the github server
using the ssh mechanism so for doing
that i need to first create a pair of
private and public key the command to do
that is ssh kijan
hyphen t i will use the rsa mechanism
for creating my keys capital c and i
need to specify the email id using which
i'm going to connect to or i need to
create the keys for
all right so generating a private and
public key pair it says
let me know what folder should i create
the keys in so by default the keys are
created in the user home directory under
a dot ssh folder so this is pretty good
for me so let me go ahead and say that
that's fine enter a passphrase
so let me enter some passphrase
keep in mind that i would need to
remember my passphrase because when i'm
going to authenticate myself using ssh
mechanism it will challenge me for this
particular passphrase i need to enter
the right passphrase so that i get
authenticated
so the key is generated and by default
it is created in this particular folder
so let me go over to that particular
folder
and this is the folder where the keys is
generated you would see a public key and
a private key that is created let me
open up the public key with
a notepad
and then copy the contents of the whole
file and now i would need to stick it in
on the server so that i can get myself
authenticated using ssh keys
so i've logged in to github using my
credentials and go to my settings
and you will see an ssh and gpg keys let
me click on that as of now there are no
ssh key or gpg keys so i will click on
new ssh key and let me paste my
public key that i've copied
and i would say add a ssh key
it prompts me for my password just to
make sure that
i've got the right kind of
authentication to be adding a new key so
this one looks good that means the keys
were added successfully let me check if
my ssh keys are working well
so i do ssh hyphen capital t
i would say get
at
github.com
this is just to double check if my ssh
keys
are authenticated correctly are you sure
you want the connection yes you want to
continue yes
all right now
a check for my passphrase let me enter
my passphrase
i hope i remember it correctly
all right
pretty good i have been successfully
authenticated so that means now my ssh
keys are good and just by using my
passphrase i can connect to my github
server using ssh all right so for the
second use case what i would do is
create a repository on the server with
some content in it and then clone that
repository cloning is nothing but making
a copy of that repository linking the
origin so that i create an exact replica
of the repository which is there on the
server on my local drive so let me first
create a repository on the server i will
create a new repository
let me give a name for my repository and
let me kind of initialize that with the
readme file i would call this my second
repo
give some description
this is my
second repo
that is created
straight
on the git server on the github server
to be precise
it's a public repository this time i'm
going to choose this option the reason
being that i don't want to create just a
skeleton as of now i want to create a
repository with some readme file in it a
random readme file with no content in it
but then i want a repository to be
created on the server all right i say
create a repository
so
a random readme file with some content
in it gets created and i can see there
are two urls to this repository https
and ssh so this time let me copy the ssh
url so that i will use this url to clone
this repository on the server
rather from the server to my local box
all right so let me navigate to my root
folder the folder that i created for
making all my repositories git
repositories if you see my first deposit
is already here so let me clone my
repository the second repo that i
created on the server the command to do
that is get clone the url of the
repository that i want to clone
oops
looks like i didn't copy the url
correctly let me copy that again
copy this url
all right so if you notice there's no
https to it i'm just cloning the url
that is ssh url of the repository
it asks for my passphrase again
okay
so i just had first repository earlier
now i have something called a second
repo this is an exact replica of
whatever was the repository content that
was created on the server so if i get
into
the repository there's just a simple
readme file that is there let me try to
add a new file out here i would say
notepad
second.txt
some text file i'm going to put in here
yes definitely you will not find that
file there
this is my second
file that
i will push onto the server
i'm going to put in some content out
there
i'm going to save this
and if i don't get status
it says this this is a new untracked
file do you want to add this file onto
the repository do you want to track this
file yes i definitely want to track this
file let me also commit my change to the
file
with the message
this is my first
commit for the second repo
giving some particular message
and this time around since i cloned my
repository from a server
the origin is already set for me i don't
really need to
add the origin and all that stuff
because what happened in the first case
was that i was creating a repository
from my local box and then pushing
another server which is why i had to set
up the upstream branches and stuff like
that in this case i have cloned an
existing repository from the server so
when i clone i get the replica along
with all references to my repository so
i don't need to do anything more other
than push the content i'll just say get
push to be on the safer side i would say
origin and master
ask me for the passphrase
okay it pushed the content onto the
server let me see if the contents have
come in here
okay wonderful i had only one comment
now i see my second comment so what was
added as a part of the second comment it
says a new file was added all this line
that never existed got added this is the
second file the content exactly what i
pushed onto the server
now this completes the tutorial when i
create a repository on the server cloned
it made some changes to the repository
and pushed it to the server using ssh
a quick recap of all the git commands
that we ran till now git init is used to
initialize a repository so if at all
you're creating a local repository you
can get into any of the folder which is
not a git repository and run this
command whenever you run this command a
magical folder by name dot kit gets
created in the folder
and from that time onwards git will
start tracking any changes that happen
to that particular folder it also
creates a new repository and a branch by
default the branch that is created is
called the master branch git add dot is
a wildcard character for adding any
number of new files into your git
repository if you have a bunch of files
one file two file ten files a folder
containing multiple files in it all of
them could be added into the repository
using this command so once you add any
number of files into the repository you
can keep on adding more and more files
into the repository once you're done
with that you want to commit the changes
that has happened in the repository you
use the git commit command git commit
hyphen m with a meaningful message
this will commit all the work items that
you have done in terms of the files that
got changed the files that got added all
this with one particular message get
status will give you the status of all
the files and folders any file that got
added any file that got created any file
that was deleted all status of the files
will be obtained using the git status
command git log will show you all the
commit history with the latest history
or the latest commit showing up on top
git add remote origin this command is
used whenever you want to link any local
repository to a server and this is when
you want to really push a repository
from the local to the server for the
first time git push hyphen u origin and
master this is the command that you
would use whenever you want to push
contents from the local repository to
the server git clone and the url of the
server this is the command that you
would run whenever you have an existing
repository on the server and you want to
make a fresh clone or a fresh copy of
that particular repository onto your
local box
more than often many developers or git
users find themselves in situations
where they would want to go back in
history and modify
or change some of the files that they
recently committed or checked into the
repository now from a perspective of get
this is a very very simple activity
however from a perspective version
control tool you will have to be really
cautious about the chain that you're
gonna do in case the changes are pretty
local none of the developers or none of
the other users who are collaborating
with you would be affected by this
change you're good to go ahead and make
this change however if your repository
has been pushed to the server and you're
trying to modify something from history
this would have a very bad or adverse
effect on all the other users who will
be using it you need to be really
cautious while running these commands in
case your repository contents are local
you have not pushed your changes to your
repository and if at all you made some
changes to the repository maybe to fix a
defect or to include a new feature and
you missed few things you can go ahead
and modify this with some of these
commands let's say i have this simple
repository called undo undo repo and if
at all i look at the logs of these i
have the commit histories which are like
this
i have about five commits that is there
in my repository and in c1 i've added a
file in c2 i've added another file in c3
i've also added some file in c4 i made
some changes to m1 and m3 and in c5 i've
added another file called m4 now this is
my commit history now let's say i made
these two comments but possibly i want
to club them together along with some
other changes because whatever changes i
did did not really fix things the way i
expected it to fix so there is a git
command called git reset this would
allow me to go back in history to go
back to any of the snapshot get rid of
all this commit history on the commit
messages but retain the changes that
were made as a part of these comments so
if at all i need to go back in history
and go back to this particular commit
and however i just want to get rid of
these commits that are there in terms of
the commit messages but i want the
changes that were there as a part of
these commits to still exist i would do
command called get reset
hyphen iphone soft
now this would go back or unwind my
changes back to this particular snapshot
getting rid of all the commit messages
that were there as a part of these two
comments but a soft would ensure that
the file changes that were done as a
part of these two commits would still
exist a full remain so the command for
that is git reset hyphen f and soft
which is the snapshot that i want to get
back to if this is the commit that i
want to get back to i just copy this
and i paste this
all right it doesn't give me any message
but if at all i do a good log pretty one
line
what it says is c1 c2 now the head which
is nothing but the current pointer which
is earlier pointing to c5 it's gone back
to c3 now what happened to the changes
that were there as a part of c4 and c5
if at all you do a git status if you see
the changes that were part of c4 were
some changes to m1 and m2 and c5 a new
file got m4 got added if i do a git
status
you would see those changes still exist
however from the git history or the git
commit history c3 is the topmost commit
that exists as of now c4 and c5 have
been gotten rid of but the changes that
were there still exist
all right now i can make some more
changes that i want if as a part of my
commit and possibly go ahead and commit
this whole thing as a new commit
altogether maybe
i'll open up a notepad and possibly
create a new file called m6.txt
say
one new file
that was missed out
i make this change
i go to a get status
all these files are still there i would
say git add dot
also get
commit hyphen m
c4
rewriting history
and i do a get
log
pretty
there you go
so c1 c2 c3 still existed and whatever
was the part of c4 and c5 the older ones
i've gotten rid of this along with those
old changes i also added a new file i
made some changes and it was able to
commit it now if you look at my gate
history it's all nice and clean however
do this activity only when you don't
push your git repository to the server
one other most powerful and useful
command while undoing or resetting the
history is something called as revert
this is a safe way of undoing some
things remember what i talked about when
exactly you can do a reset it's only
when your changes are local and it has
not been pushed to the repository take
this scenario wherein let's say i have a
git server
and i have the changes which are c1
c2
c3
and possibly c4
all right so this is a bunch of comments
that has happened this was the oldest
comment and this is the newest comment
and if at all developer one is the one
who's responsible for pushing these
contents
in the first place so he has got c1 to
c4 on his history
i'm going to jump all this c2 and c3 and
get into c4 and he's pushed all these
contents out here
and there are a bunch of people from the
server who has pulled this repository
and all of them are at the same level
now imagine a use case where developer
one then figures out that by mistake he
put in the c3 which was the wrong thing
to do and possibly you know he could
have done a better job of fixing this in
a different way so he wants to get rid
of the c3 or c4 or any one of these
comments
if he's going to do that and push to the
server first of all the git server would
not allow him to go back in history but
assuming that he forcibly pushed
something
what would happen to all these people
who are looking to work ahead from c4
all of them would be affected in adverse
way so
in short never go back in history if at
all you need to undo something go ahead
and put in a new commit to undo
something
let's take this example maybe if at all
a developer one wants to get rid of c3
better way to do that is by adding a new
commit which is ahead
say let's say c5 and what does this
commit do
this commit possibly gets rid of c3
instead of going back in history it
actually is taking your git history
ahead but as a part of this commit
you're undoing some part of the work
that was done as a part of c3
in short you're removing a commit but to
remove a commit you're adding a new
commit and this is why you're doing it
because there are a bunch of other
people who are
you're using this repository
collaboratively and were planning to get
ahead in terms of history they cannot
afford to go back in history and modify
something in history all right the
command to do this is called the get
revert command
so let me take up this repository which
has got a bunch of commits in it and if
at all i do a git log
pretty one line
i have these bunch of comments
and c1 i've added a file in c2 hour
another file in c3 i've added one more
file
and in c4 i made some changes and this
is the latest commit and this is the
oldest comment so if at all i see the
contents of the git
folder it contains m1 m2 m3 and m4
and
let's say looking at the previous use
case that i mentioned i may want to get
rid of this particular commit
i want to get rid of the c3 which is
nothing but i've added a file called
m3.txt but i added it by mistake
i need a better way of fixing it
possibly i look at it later on but for
now i don't want this particular commit
and the changes that were made as a part
of that commit to exist so the better
way to do that is using the git revert
command so get revert and the commit id
whatever i want to revert so if i want
to revert this
i copy this particular commit id and
bear in mind that considering reset
revert works on one commit at a time so
i can do
one commit revert at a time i can club
bunch of them together and do one commit
but otherwise the revert always works on
one commit at a time so get revert
paste this
essentially what i'm trying to do i'm
trying to undo this particular commit
while i'm undoing this commit what does
git do it safely adds a new commit and a
part of this new commit it unders
whatever changes that were done as a
part of this command so if i say git
revert this
all right i forgot to mention the
message which is why this window is
showing up but that message is good for
me i say write and quit
all right and if i do a git log
all right if you see this c1 still is
there in history
and our history is going ahead from c5 i
see another commit but what was there as
a part of this commit actually is
getting rid of this commit c3 so if at
all i see my files here there's only m1
m2 and m4
m3 was added as a part of c3 now i've
gotten rid of m3
by getting rid of the revert command for
c3 so this is a better way of undoing
things
now that we have acquainted ourselves
with few of those basic git commands let
me get into a very very interesting
topic regarding get which is about
branching the topic is interesting
because kit deals with branches in a
completely different way
compared to any other version control
tool
in most of the version control tools
whenever you create a new branch a
complete copy or a subset of the whole
repository is created which in my
opinion is very very cost inefficient
because it is a very very expensive
operation both in times of time and the
disk space
however in git you just create a very
very lightweight mobile pointer whenever
you create a branch there is no folder
or no copy of the repository that is
created in short the branches are very
very inexpensive and great so go ahead
and create any number of branches that
you need
however once you create your branches do
all the work relating to that branch in
that specific branch and once you've
completed your task go ahead and merge
your branches back into your base branch
and then delete the branch
let me go ahead and create a repository
with some branches in this and give you
a demonstration of that
so let me go back to my base directory
which is git demo and then i'm going to
create a new folder here
i'll create a folder called arc details
all right this is my folder here
all right i navigate into this folder
and let me create a repository here
i initialize a repository a dot git
folder is created without any
files in it so let me create a few files
on it
say notepad name dot text
organization name
i create a name.txt within this maybe
i'll create one more file in this
notepad
employees.txt
simply learn
has
over
3k employees
i just put in some content in this save
this content
all right
so if i try to look at status i just
see two files in it so let me go ahead
and
add these two files and let me commit my
changes so okay
commit iphone am or iphone m
first
so if i do a gig log
i see only one commit and there are two
files and you can see those two files
that is here
all right so at this stage let me go
ahead and create a new branch
and the command for creating new branch
is get
branch name of the branch so let me name
my branch as bangalore branch blr branch
and this created a branch
but i don't see any changes in the
folder structure or in the file that
exists here i've just created this
branch so if at all i do a git
branch
i see these two branches
and whatever star means i'm currently in
this master branch so let me go ahead
and get into the blr branch at this
moment the number of files that exist in
this repository is same there's
absolutely no change in any of the
branches both master and blr branch
point to the same snapshot
so let me get into
the other branch and the command to do
that is get checkout
plr branch
i've actually switched into bangalore
branch if you see the content of the
files there's exactly two files the way
it was earlier because i've created a
branch from my base branch which is a
master branch and when i created a
branch there were two files existing
here if you see the content of these
files they would all be the same
all right so let me create a
file that is specific to panel branch
so i would just say notepad
maybe i want to put on the address of
this organization specific to bangalore
in this address.txt so i say notepad
address.txt
also simply learn
bangalore office
say located in
[Music]
some arteries
i would say bangalore
that is the content of this file
and i'm creating all this new file in
this blr branch so i would say git add
dot
and i would say git
commit hyphen m
bangalore
branch
commit
all right if you see this now i have an
address dot text which is there only in
the bangalore branch that i am presently
on now let me switch back to my master
branch the command to do that is git
check out
master branch
if you remember when i forked out or
when i created a new branch from the
master branch i didn't have this address
or text in it so let me go back to git
git checkout master branch
and keep noticing this particular
what happened to the address.txt
it kind of disappeared
how did that happen it's all because of
this magical git folder so what happened
is now git knows that when you were in
the master branch
the
file that was there in the bangalore
branch which was called the
address dot text didn't exist
so
git is playing around with the file
system snapshot so if i come back let's
say i come back to get check out
bangalore branch
if you see this the address.txt file
appears
so this particular file is only present
in the branch and git is playing around
with the file system snapshot by moving
the pointers across and ensuring that
whenever i am switching to bangalore
branch i see this address dot text when
i go back to my master branch i don't
see this bangalore branch
contents which is the address dot text
alright now that i created this branch
maybe i may need to push this onto the
server so let me go ahead and create a
particular repository structure on the
server similar to whatever we did in our
previous exercise
so
the name of the folder needs to be
exactly this one so let me copy this
and let me create a repository very
quickly
go here and say new repository
all right this
is the name of the repository
get
branch demo this is what i'm going to
put in as a description i would say
public i don't want any readme files in
it because i already have a repository i
will just say create a repository
all right
let me use the ssh url yeah this is the
ssh url this is good for me so let me
copy this url
let me add it here
i'm linking my local repository with the
server
and i would let me come back to my
master branch
let me first push my master branch so i
would say git
push
hyphen u origin
master
it asks for my passphrase
all right
i pushed my master branch looks good it
says new branch master is created so if
i go back to my server and i do a
refresh
if you see it says only one branch
and it says what is the name of the
branch master
if you see the contents there is
employees.text and name dot text
now
let's try to push the other branch that
is there the command to do that is a
little different compared to
the way we created it on the client
because on the client we created the
branch with a git branch command now
this branch doesn't exist on the server
and i need to push this new branch onto
the server so the command would be
gate
push
hyphen u origin and the name of the
brand that i want to specifically push
all right now it created a branch out
here
let me do a refresh of this
all right it says two branches
if i get into this bangalore branch i
would see the address dot text if at all
i go back into master branch i would not
see this address.txt
wonderful
now let me do one thing let me try to
get the changes from the branch that i
created back into the master branch that
is what i would mean by
merging i would want the changes that is
there as a part of the bangalore branch
to come back into my master branch so if
i go to click checkout
bankrupt branch i see this attach.tech
this is there only as a part of
bangalore branch now assuming that i'm
done with the changes from the bandwidth
branch i want to get those changes back
into my master so let me come back
to my master branch
and the way to merge in the changes is
get merge
so what is that you want to merge i want
to merge the bangalore branch changes
and where will it merge it'll merge it
into the current branch that i'm on
presently i'm in the master branch so
this command would merge the changes
from the bangalore branch into your
master branch so with this if you'll
keep looking here the content that was
there that was added as a part of
bangalore branch which is nothing but
the address dot text this file should
appear as soon as we do a merge
all right so it happened
quickly and you would see this address
dot text that is here so if you see
let's check the contents in terms of the
git log
all right so there was only one branch
that we had earlier which had only one
commit right now we are at this
bangalore branch commit which was there
as a part of the bangalore branch
command
so with this change let me push this
change onto the server as well
git push
origin
master
okay those changes were pushed to the
server and now
if at all i do a refresh out here
okay i mean two branches the francis
master even if i'm in master brands i
should see this address dot text that is
there even if i'm in the bangalore
branch the content is all same because
we have merged these two branches
now that i've merged this branch i don't
need this branch anymore so i would go
ahead and delete this locally as well as
push it onto the server so that it gets
deleted from the server as well so
delete branch locally the command is get
branch
hyphen d and the name of the branch
only thing you need to ensure is that
you should not be currently on that
branch which you're trying to delete so
i would say get branch
and i'm presently in the master branch
so i can go ahead and delete the other
branch so get branch hyphen d bandwidth
branch
all right this got rid of our bandwidth
branch locally
if at all i don't get branch hyphen we
it shows there's only one branch as of
now however this branch would still
exist on the server because server
doesn't know anything about the changes
that we have done
we need to specifically push our changes
onto the server
okay there are two branches still here
so let me go ahead and push this changes
so that the branch gets deleted from the
server as well the command to do that is
get
push
origin
hyphen iphone delete and the name of the
branch
all right
so this went ahead and deleted the
branch
from the server let's check that
okay if you see now there's only one
branch
these are the basic steps that you would
need to know before you work with any of
the branches within git and as i said
before the branches are very very
inexpensive and good go ahead and create
any number of branches that you want but
just ensure that once you create your
branch finish of your task and once you
finish off your task go ahead and delete
the branch and before you delete the
brands please ensure that you merge in
the branches so that you get in or take
in the work that was done as a part of
that particular branch
to summarize the git branching commands
are as follows to create a new branch
you issue a command git branch the name
of the branch and this would
automatically spin off or create a new
branch from the existing branch from
where you issue this command if you are
on the master branch and if you execute
this command git branch new underscored
branch it creates a new underscore
branch from the master branch once you
create a new branch in order to get into
this branch you would type in git check
out the name of the branch
this would automatically switch the file
system snapshot between different
branches now the branches that are
created are by default created on the
local repository in case you want to
push any specific branch onto the server
you would have to issue a command git
push hyphen u origin and the name of the
branch so this will ensure that the
contents of the new branch are pushed
onto the server at any time if you want
to list out all existing branches on
your local repositories the command
would be git branch hyphen av assuming
that you did all your work in a new
branch and you're happy with the changes
you would want to bring back those
changes into the master branch the
command to merge the contents of any new
branch into a master branch would be git
merge and the name of the branch
this would automatically merge the
branch contents that you specified into
the branch on which you currently reside
if at all you are on the master branch
and if you issue a command git merge new
underscore branch this would merge the
contents of the new branch onto the
master branch so once you merge the
contents of any branch you would
possibly want to go ahead and delete
this branch so the command to delete
those branch locally is get branch
hyphen capital d and the name of the
branch this again would delete the
branch locally in order to make this
change on the server which is in order
to remove this branch from the server
the command to do that is get push
origin hyphen iphone delete and the name
of the branch this would also delete the
branch that you created on the server in
this session we're going to cover the
topic of what is angular
i'm sure all of you use mobile and web
applications be it from social media to
health care e-commerce and net banking
these apps are used by billions of
people across the globe now the main
reason we use these apps is that they
offer seamless user experience and
interface
but how are they developed to provide
such reliability one of the frameworks
that is widely used to build such robust
apps is angular so let's dive into the
session now
so here is a list of topics that we're
going to be covering
first up we'll see why angular was
introduced
then what is angular
features of angular
angular architecture
advantages and limitations of angular
the learning curve of angular and
finally we'll look at some of the
companies that deploy angular so without
further delay let's begin
why angular now javascript is the most
commonly used client-side scripting
language it is written into html
documents enabling interactions with web
pages in many unique ways
so as a relatively easy to learn
language with almost pervasive support
it is exceptionally well suited to
develop modern applications but the
question arises
is javascript ideal for developing
single page applications that require
modularity testability and other
features perhaps not however we have a
variety of frameworks and libraries
designed to help us with such things
with respect to front-end development
angular and javascript together bring in
structure and consistency to your web
applications
and also provide scalability and
maintainability
angular is specifically developed for
single page applications so now the
question arises what exactly is
angular angular is an open source
javascript framework written completely
in typescript
now it was primarily aimed to develop
single page applications and is
maintained by google
angular as a framework provides a few
advantages while also providing a
standard structure for developers it is
designed for web desktop and mobile
platforms if you have a doubt here as to
what exactly single page applications
are let me help you with that now these
single page applications are basically
applications that get loaded just once
so the main page gets loaded onto your
browser so any further interactions does
not lead to loading of subsequent pages
anything that has to be done further is
just an addition to the already loaded
page so these single page applications
are primarily developed using angular
moving ahead let's look at the features
of angular
we have four features that we're going
to be discussing
we have the document object model type
script data binding and testing now
let's look at them one by one now the
document object model treats an xml or
an html document as a tree structure
now here every node in the tree
structure defines an object representing
a part of your document
angular uses the regular dom now let's
suppose you've made 10 updates on a
single html page
so every time you make a change the
corresponding dom or the tree structure
needs to be updated
now angular updates the entire tree
structure of html tags
moving on to our next feature
we have typescript
now typescript defines a set of types to
javascript which helps you write
javascript that is easier to understand
now all the typescript code compiles
down to basic javascript that can run
smoothly on any platform now typescript
is not mandatory for developing an
angular application but it is highly
recommended the main reason is highly
recommended is that it offers better
syntactic structure while making the
code base easier to understand and
maintain now typescript can be installed
as an npm package now to do that you
just have to run the command npm install
hyphen g type script on your command
prompt next up is data binding now data
binding is a process that allows you to
manipulate web page elements using the
web browser now it mainly employs
dynamic html and does not require
complex scripting or programming
it is used in web pages that include
interactive components like calculators
tutorials games etc now incremental
display of a web page makes data binding
extremely convenient when pages contain
a large amount of data when it comes to
angular it uses two-way data binding so
any changes meeting the ui element is
reflected in the corresponding model
state
and conversely any changes made in the
model state
are reflected onto the ui state
this allows the framework to connect the
tom to the model data via the controller
the last feature we are discussing is
testing
angular uses jasmine to run its various
tests the jasmine framework allows
various functionalities to write
different kinds of test cases
karma is a task runner for the tests
that use a configuration file to set the
startup reporters and testing framework
so with that we've covered the features
of angular
so let's go ahead and understand
the architecture of angular
now angular is a full-fledged mvc
framework
it provides a strong opinion on how the
application should be structured and
offers bi-directional data flow and
updates to real dom mvc short for model
view controller is an architectural
pattern that separates the application
layer into model view and controller the
model here relates to all the data
related logic
view on the other hand is used for ui
logic of the application
and controller is the brain of the setup
now it is an interface between the model
and
view moving on let's look at the
advantages of angular
first up we have custom components
angular allows you to build your own
components that can pack functionality
along with rendering logic into reusable
pieces
data binding as discussed angular allows
you to effortlessly move your data from
your javascript code to the view and
react to user events without having to
write any code yourself
dependency injection angular allows you
to write modular services and have them
injected wherever they are needed
this greatly improves the testability
and reusability of the same don't worry
if you can't wrap your head around these
topics we're going to discuss them
further in the coming videos
next advantage is testing angular has
been built from the ground up with
testability in mind
you can literally test every part of
your application
comprehensive angular is a full-fledged
framework and provides out-of-the-box
solutions for server communication
routing and more
lastly we have excellent browser
compatibility angular is cross platform
and browser compatible an angular
application can typically run on all
browsers
beat chrome firefox safari and platforms
like windows mac os and linux now many
versions of angular have been released
ever since its inception all of these
versions have added to the efficient
working of the framework now here are
two different versions released first up
was angular 1. it was built on
javascript and completely based on
controllers next release was angular 2.
now this incorporated the component
based approach wherein the entire ui was
divided into several components and
lastly integrated to give the final
logic
next was angular 4 it included router
updation angular cli or command line
interface 1.0 was introduced however not
deployed
in this release the angular cli was
optimized and commands like ng update
and ng add were added
in the angular 7 release prompts were
introduced which provided tips in cli
about the functions being used
in angular 8 iv renderer and bazel were
introduced
and finally the most recent release was
angular 9. now this came with the better
framework and angular material now this
completely switched to the iv renderer
as a default compiler now that we've
learnt about the pros of using angular
let's look at some of the limitations of
angular
first up is a sleep learning curve now
since angular is a complete full-fledged
framework it becomes difficult for
learners to begin with
you need to be acquainted with simple
topics and then move on to more advanced
topics to become proficient in this
language
next up is limited seo options
now angular offers limited seo options
and poor accessibility to search engine
crawlers it's verbose and complex
now a common issue faced by the angular
community is the verbosity of the
framework
it also poses to be complex compared to
other front-end tools
and lastly migration now one of the
drawbacks of angular is poor migration
now it becomes difficult to port legacy
code to angular style architecture
also with each new release it is painful
to upgrade and a lot of them are not
backward compatible
next up let's look at the angular
learning curve
now if you wish to learn angular you
need to be acquainted with basic topics
in angular
some of them are directives
modules declarators components services
dependency injection
pipes and templates
now once you've mastered your basics you
will want to go and understand more
advanced topics such as change detection
zones aot compilation and rx.js
however the learning curve of angular is
clear cut
in the beginning it could be a little
intimidating but once you start using
the tool it becomes way more easier to
comprehend and understand what is going
on
and lastly let's look at some of the
companies that use angular today
many top tier companies like nike
forbes google hbo sony upwork among
others readily deploy angular so moving
on let's look at the prerequisites for
angular
first up we have node.js angular uses
node.js as its base for a large part of
its build environment
so as a result to get started with
angular you will need to have nodejs
installed on your environment so head to
their official website and download the
latest release for your corresponding
operating system
next up is the angular cli now this
command line interface is a tool that
makes it easier to bootstrap and develop
your angular applications now to install
the latest version run the command npm
install hyphen g
at angular
front slash cli you got to run this
command on your command prompt and
finally to confirm installation check
for its version
now the next thing that you will need is
an ide or a text editor to type your
code now there are several ides that you
can choose from but in this series we've
used vs code throughout so it is
available on all platforms so go ahead
and download it if you haven't already
now moving on to the final part is the
demo now that you have a basic
understanding of angular and its
prerequisites i think you're ready to
create your first angular application so
let's head to our vs code and begin
here i've created a folder called
angular on my desktop and opened it on
my visual studio code so to create your
app you need to open the terminal just
go here and
select new terminal
and now type in the command
ng
new
and provide the name for your app
so i'm just gonna say hello world
so now this is going to create
just say yes
so basically what happens is that when
you run the command it will
automatically generate a skeleton
application under the folder that is
hello world in our case and it includes
a bunch of files and installs all the
necessary dependencies for the angular
application
so this could take a while
so once you've created your application
to run it first change the directory so
let's say cd
hello world
and now use the command ng serve
now once it's compiled you need to go to
your browser and type in localhost 4200.
[Music]
once you do that
you can see your ui
you can see that the application has
been loaded onto your browser
and it says hello world app is running
so this is how you create your
application so let's go back to our vs
code now as you can see here
there are many files and folders that
are created right so let's look at a few
of them of course we can't explain
everything but i'll rush through a few
of them
so the first main component is basically
the root component now the root
component here is the index.html
so here if you open the file and see
it's a very small crisp code right but
the most important thing in the file is
this app root element
so what this does is it's basically the
marker for loading your application code
so this is extremely important so the
next important file is the main.ts
now this is a part of the bootstrapping
piece all right so the index.html file
is responsible for deciding which files
are to be loaded correct the main.ts
file on the other hand identifies which
angular module is to be loaded when the
application starts so this is just a
brief explanation as to what they are
doing
next we have the app folder now here we
have the
app.module.ts file now this application
module file can be thought of as the
code configuration of your application
so here's where the source code starts
from and moving on we have the
app.component.ts so these are all
typescript files hence the extension ts
now this file basically is a root
component of your application
and then we have the html file for the
same which defines the appearance of
what you can see on your browser so let
me just change the message that is being
displayed
so i'll say hey
welcome to this
angular
tutorial so let's save this
and when we go back to our browser
we can see the message hey welcome to
this angular tutorial being displayed
so like this we can make a simple change
and then it gets rendered onto your
browser so this was just a brief
explanation of what happens in the
background of your application
first we'll get acquainted to what
exactly angular components are
then i'll help you create an angular
component by showing a quick demo and
lastly we'll learn about component
decorator metadata but before we begin
make sure to subscribe to our channel if
you love watching new and interesting
technology videos also hit the bell icon
to never miss an update so what exactly
are angular components
now i'm sure everybody uses web
applications and one of the most widely
used applications is gmail correct now
to help you understand what components
are consider them as lego blocks now
they basically are combined together to
form the final application
so in this case here we have the logo
component then you have a sign in
component
an image component and then a create
account component now all of these
components generally don't affect the
working of each other
but however when embedded they define
the ui of your application
so i hope you understood what components
are
so to go ahead let's discuss some of its
common features now firstly they are the
building blocks of an application
generally you have a root component
which is basically the app component and
then it branches out into other
components creating a hierarchy
and these components are a subset of
directives now don't worry about what
deductives are because we'll cover them
later on in the series but to give you
an idea there are three types of
directives you have the structural
directives the attribute directives and
the component directives
only one component can be instantiated
per element in a template
now components are typically custom html
elements and each of these elements can
instantiate only one component
now don't worry you'll understand this
better when i show you the demo nextly a
typescript class is used to create a
component now this class is then
decorated with the at component
decorator now the decorator accepts a
metadata object that gives information
about the component now a component must
belong to the ng module in order for it
to be usable by another component or
application
and finally components control their
runtime behavior by implementing life
cycle hooks
so this was just a brief introduction to
what angular components are
now you will only be able to understand
the working of components when i show it
to you practically so let's head over to
a visual studio code
now here back in my vs code i've created
a folder called angulardemo within which
i've created an angular application
called demo components
once executed the browser looks
something like this
so if you haven't watched our previous
video on getting started with angular
that is angular hello world i highly
suggest you go through that video first
it helps you create your first angular
application so um
now let's go ahead and create our first
component now the command used to create
our component is ng gc and your
component name
once executed it creates four different
files now let's just see how this works
on rvs code now what you can do is head
to your terminal and type in the command
ng
g
c
and provide a name for your component
for example i'm going to just call my
component text component
all right
so what it does is that it creates four
different files you can see you have
four different files that have been
created and finally it updates the file
that is app.module.ts indicating that
this new component has been created so
here in your source folder
within which there's an app folder and
again here you can see that your four
different files have been created first
is the html file where you can define
all the code that you want for your
component next you have the css file for
your styling
then you have the dot ts file which
includes the component decorator and
finally you have spec.ts which is
basically a unit test file all right and
then in your app.module.ts
you can observe that the component that
you've created that is text component
has been imported that is what the
message conveys here all right now let's
go back to our app.component.html
now this basically has all the code for
your application so let me just get rid
of it
[Music]
and i'm just gonna
display a basic
heading saying
hello
welcome
all right so let me save it
and if you go ahead and look at your
browser
hello welcome message is displayed now
let's go back to our component
dot html file
and here
let me
provide a message
[Music]
let me say h
3
and let me display a message saying
welcome to this tutorial
on angular components
all right
now in your text component component.ts
file which is your typescript file
the selector mentioned here is app
hyphen text component now go ahead and
copy this
and in your final
component.html go ahead and create your
custom html tag
with the selector that you just copied
now this indicates that the component
that you just created that is the text
component is being incorporated in the
final render
so what happens is that whatever is
defined in the component.html file is
also being rendered in your final output
so when i save this
let's go ahead and check
our browser you can see that the message
welcome to this tutorial on angular
components is displayed
so this was a simple creation of a
component now for this let's give it
some styling
so here go to your dot css file and
provide some styling see for example
here i just say
text line
and let me say center and also in my
app.component.cs i'm going to give the
same thing and say each one
text align
is center
all right so let me save this
and there we go
now we can also create multiple
components and define the tags in the
app component
now the components are executed
sequentially
so now let's create another component
just to give you a brief insight into it
let's say
nggc
image component
now here i'm going to be adding the
simply learn logo so i'll show you how
that works
now you can see that a new component has
been created with four files again so in
my assets folder here i've added the
logo
so what i can do is back in my html file
i can go ahead and create an image tag
so first let me just display another
message here
just to avoid any confusion and let me
say this is the image component
[Music]
and then
let me say
image
source
equals
so the source is basically
assets
[Music]
slash
logo
dot png
and class
equals
center
all right so you can also head to your
css file and provide any sort of styling
that you need
so let me just say
text
align
to be center
and then let's create
a styling for the image
and here i mentioned the code for the
image
so let's save this
and from the dot cs file
let's copy the selector
and create a custom html tag in our
final component.html file
so there we go
let's save this and check the output
and there we go
first the hello welcome message is
displayed
next you have the message displayed from
the first component and then you have
the second component
so this is how you can create
your own components and don't forget to
incorporate these selectors into your
final html file
so moving on to our next topic component
decorator metadata now as mentioned
earlier the at component decorator
accepts a metadata object that provides
information about the component
correct here is a list of properties of
the metadata object first up is the
selector now basically the selector is a
css selector that identifies this
particular component in a template now
this corresponds to the html tag that is
included in the parent component you can
create your own html tag
however the same has to be included in
the parent component so to help you
understand that better let's head back
to our vs code and say for example in
our text component
here
the selector says text component
correct for the time being let's change
it to say n component
all right
now when you save it and look at the
browser
the message is not displayed
so what we can do is you can copy this
selector
and then include this
here
and now you can see
that the same component has been
rendered onto your output
all right so the selector plays a
crucial role in that
next up we have the template now a
template is an inline defined template
for the view now the template can be
used to provide some particular markup
the markup could typically include some
headings or paragraphs that are
displayed on the ui
next up we have template url now it is
the url for the external file containing
the template for the view so here you
can see
this is basically the external file that
contains the template for the view
next up you have styles now these are
also inline defined styles that can be
applied to the components view so any
code that you provide in the dot css
file can also be included here
next you have the style urls now this is
a list of urls to your style sheets that
are applied on your components view
next up you have providers now this is
again an array where certain services
can be registered for your component
lastly we have animations as the name
suggests these are animations that can
be listed for your components
first we'll understand what exactly
dependency injection is
then we'll understand the demerit or the
drawback of not using dependency
injection
then we'll understand dependency
injection as a design pattern
and finally i'll help you understand the
entire concept with the help of a demo
so let's begin
what exactly is dependency injection so
let's consider this i'm sure you're
aware that angular uses the concept of
components the entire ui of the
application is divided into several
components
now what if all of these components
perform similar tasks be it accessing
the database rendering images etc now
instead of writing the same piece of
code for every component you could write
the code once and then perhaps inject
the same code into every component
now this is supported by dependency
injection
now to give you a better example
consider two classes a and b now let's
assume that a uses the objects of class
b
and normally in object oriented
programming an instance of class b is
created so that a can access its objects
but using dependency injection we move
the creation and binding of dependent
objects outside of the class that depend
on them so dependency injection or di
keeps the core more flexible testable
and mutable also classes can inherit
external logic without having to create
on its own and lastly gi benefits
directives pipes and components
next up let's have a look at the
drawback of not using dependency
injection
now let's consider class
postal details that is dependent on the
number and the address class
in the postal details class the
constructor creates copies of the number
and address
so when you instantiate a new postal
details class the constructor
instantiates a unique number and address
now although this looks simple there's a
problem with this code
let's assume that the number and address
class constructors now accept parameters
when we change the numbers class the
postal details class gets broken
now to overcome this what we need to do
is we need to pass parameter to the
number constructor so this applies to
address as well the first drawback of
using this traditional method is that
the code is not very flexible
anytime the dependencies change the
postal details class needs to be changed
as well
and the second drawback is that the code
is not suitable for testing
once you instantiate the new postal
details class you get the same number
and address even if you change the
number and address classes every time
what if these classes are in turn
dependent on other classes
then it's going to be a chain reaction
so to overcome this we make use of
dependency injection
now let's look at di as a pattern
dependency injection as you all know is
a coding pattern where a class receives
its dependencies from an external source
rather than creating them on its own so
here in the above example we have moved
the definition of dependencies from
inside the constructor to the
constructor's parameters
so the postal details class doesn't
create the dependencies anymore
it just consumes them so the postal
dependencies class doesn't create the
dependencies anymore
so with that we overcome the drawbacks
of not using di
so now that you know what exactly
dependency injection is and how vital it
is let's look at a simple demonstration
to understand the concept better now
services classes modules components all
of these are benefactors of dependency
injection so in the demo i'm going to be
showing how dependency injection can be
used with the help of services and
injecting these services into classes so
the main
thought behind this is normally
components are used to ensure just a
good user experience
these components do not generally
execute tasks so to execute these tasks
we make use of services so a component
can delegate tasks like fetching data
from the server any network related
issues etc to a particular service and
these services can be made available to
components
with the same thought what i'm going to
be doing is i'll be creating a service
that performs the task of displaying an
employee list
later we're going to inject this service
into the class using dependency
injection
so let's head to our visual studio code
for the demonstration
all right so as discussed i'll have to
first create a component that displays a
button for the employee and then i have
to create a service class and inject it
into my component now this service holds
the employee details such as name
employee id email id etc
so first let's go ahead and create a
component
so here let me just type
nggc
and the name of the component i'm
providing is amp info
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
all right so as you can see here in my
app folder i have the component
with four different files all right so
the next thing we have to do is we have
to create a service so to create that we
make use of the command
ng g
s
you can either give s or service and the
service name i'm providing is records
so let me just say
records here
all right here you can see two files are
created there is a spec.ts file and the
dot ts file
all right so now the service contains
all the employee data that needs to be
displayed right so let's go ahead and
write the data so first we're going to
make use of three arrays i'm going to be
displaying employee records for three
employees so i'll have to create three
arrays and provide certain information
so let's go ahead and do that
all right so the area i'm creating is
called info one for the first employee
and i'm going to be
passing
information like name employee id and
the email id
so the arrays of type string
and within which let me just mention the
details i'm giving random information
i'm just saying adam taylor
and some random
employee id
and let's say 80 at abc.net
all right so i'm going to be creating
three records so i'll just copy the same
thing and paste for the rest too
let's just change here
provide a different name here
and same for the last one
and
let me change the name of the area as
well
all right so with the agenda to retrieve
this data in our component we make use
of the method for the same right so this
method returns the employee data
so let's go ahead and create this method
i'm going to call it get info
and then just say string
and then this will just return
this dot in four one
all right i'm going to be calling it get
info one for better understanding
same for the rest two as well
i'm just going to return different
arrays here
all right and lastly info 3 all right
now in order to retrieve this
information in our component we need
three more arrays right three more
arrays that will receive this data let's
go back to our component dot ts file
here
and then type in the following code
so i've created three arrays again or
info received one two and three
now what we need to do is we have to
accept the information that is being
sent from the service correct
now as
i mentioned services are implemented
with the help of dependency injection so
what we need to do is we'll have to
first import the service
into the component.ts file
the key reason behind doing this is that
when angular creates this component an
instance of the service class is also
made to perform the necessary tasks
correct so let's go ahead and just
import it here
so i'll say import
[Music]
records
services
i'm sorry service
from
and let's say records dot service
all right and what we have to do next is
that we must also declare this instance
that is being created in the providers
area of the component
all right
so
let's just say providers
and then say records
service
all right now we've created the instance
of this class
right however to access this instance an
object is also created so this object
will in turn access the methods and
variables of the service class
so for that we have to create another
object so let's do that here in our
constructor method
let's say constructor
private
and the object i'm creating is called
our service you can give a name
of your choice
and then i'm going to just say records
service
all right now this
object will help me retrieve data from
the service so let's go ahead and use
this in order to get the employee
details
or else i've created three different
methods here get info from service class
2 1 and 3 and these methods will
retrieve the data and add it to our
array here that is info received all
right
and lastly
we'll have to create an unordered list
in our html file here we haven't added
anything so let me get rid of this
so now i have to create three different
buttons for three different employees
and when the user clicks on the button
the data is retrieved from the service
and then displayed on the ui
right
so as you can see i've created buttons
for three different employees
and then i've made use of a bootstrap
class called list group info
and then i've
interpolated
info which displays the contents
of the info variable all right now in
order to call the methods in the dot ts
file we have to bind them with the
button so since it is bound with the
click event every time you click on the
button the information is
displayed
so now the last thing we have to do is
we'll have to create a custom html tag
for the component and then add it to the
main component
so let's just do that
let me copy
this here
and then in my
appcomponent.html let me get rid of this
and then let me just create this
i've just created the custom html tag
for my component
and now just to beautify the code i'll
write a heading
and let's say
employee
details
and then i'll also add the simply learn
logo
say image source
[Music]
i've
added the image here so let me just say
logo
dot png
i've also added some styling to it
all right so now let me just save this
and have a look at the browser
so here we go we have the logo here and
then employee details heading and then
we have three different buttons created
that is employee one two and three and
when i click on it
the information of the employee is
displayed the name the id and their
email address
so yeah so this is how you can make use
of dependency injection and inject a
service class into a component
dependency injection plays a crucial
role in angular
we'll understand what angular forms are
then we'll look at the different types
of form building supported by angular
next up we'll get acquainted with
features like form control and group
control
and we learn all of this with the help
of a simple demo
so without further ado let's begin
so what exactly are angular forms
now i'm sure every application that you
use comes with certain amount of form
filling correct be it your login
credentials or your sign up forms or any
sort of registration forms etc so forms
are an integral part of a web
application
you need forms to update your profile or
to enter sensitive information or also
to perform any sort of data related
tasks so now let's look at the different
types of form building supported by
angular
first up angular supports two types of
form building
first you have the template driven
approach and second you have the
reactive approach
now let's look at them one by one
so talking about template driven
approach in this method the conventional
form tag is used to create forms
so angular automatically interprets and
creates a form object with the help of
the directives
now controls can be added to the form
using the ng model tag
now multiple controls can be grouped
using the ng control group module so it
basically uses several module classes to
provide controls now if you don't get
this don't worry you'll understand
better when i'm showing you the demo
next up is json values so form value can
be generated using the form dot value
object
form data is exported as json values
when the submit method is called
lastly basic html validations can be
used to validate the form fields in the
case of custom validations directives
can be used so arguably this method is
the simplest way to create an angular
form
so moving on to the active approach now
this approach is the programming
paradigm revolving around data flows and
propagation of change
now with reactive forms the component
directly manages the data flows between
the form controls and the data models
now reactive forms are code driven
unlike template driven approach
reactive forms eliminate the anti
pattern of updating the data model by a
two way data binding so it does not use
two-way data binding
and typically a reactive form control
creation is synchronous and can be unit
tested with synchronous programming
techniques
so now let's go ahead and look at form
control and form group
so consider a typical form consisting of
fields like name age and location
now a form control is basically a class
that enables validation of these fields
for each input field an instance of this
class is created
now these instances help check the
values of the field and see if they're
either touched untouched dirty pristine
valid invalid and so on so this allows
you to check every field for the value
it makes it easier to understand which
field's value is invalid or which field
has not been entered etc
now moving on to form group
so a form group class represents a group
of controls a form can have multiple
group controls the form group returns
true if all the controls are valid and
provides validation errors if there are
any so i hope this was clear
so moving ahead let's look at the demo
to explain all of these features i'm
sure it will become extremely clear once
you look at the demo so for that let's
head to our vs code
so back in my vs code
i've created a component called form
component
and
i've also included the simply learn logo
just to beautify the appearance so once
you execute the code
this is what you're going to see on your
browser
so you just have the logo at the moment
the first thing we need to do is we'll
have to
import the forms module all right
so oh uh but before we begin let me tell
you what the use case is so we're going
to be creating a user registration form
which is going to include four fields
that is the first name last name email
id and a password
all right so now let me show you how to
import the forms module so in your main
app.module.ts file
you will have to import forms module
from angular forms
all right and then in your imports
you'll have to just call it here
all right so this is just a simple step
and now once you're done with that let's
go ahead and start our form creation
so here in my component.html
let's enclose the entire form within a
div tag
so here
let me say div
class
is a container
within which let me just have one
heading
it says user registration
all right and now let's go ahead and
create our form
so first let me just say form
now i'm going to create a div class for
every field so
say div
class
equals form group
i'll explain it to you a little later
[Music]
now first let's create a label
so label tag
for
basically it's the first name so let me
just say first name
and the tab will basically have
first name again
all right and let me just break the line
next we have the field so let's say
input
type is text
name is
first name
and we have a class which is
the form control class
all right
so this we have to do for all the other
fields
so let me just copy this
and
paste it like four times
i'll also add the tag three
for spacing
[Music]
let's do that here
and finally we'll have the button
so let's just add that here
with a type
submit
and let's just say submit on the button
so now let's go ahead and change these
values here
so here let me just change it to last
name
here as well
and here as well
and in this case it is going to be email
so let me just change it here
[Music]
and finally we have password so
let's add that here
all right so let's save this and just
have a look at our browser
so there we go we have our uh
user registration form ready
but i would like to
uh align it to the center so let me just
do that
so here in my css file i'm just going to
align all the div tags the center and
the label tag to the left so let me save
this and look at the browser now
and there we go we have our registration
form was a logo so this is how you
create a simple form
now we'll have to add a directive called
ng model
now this directive when added into the
input tag
will
provide form controls to every input
field
all right so here let's just go ahead
and say ng
model
that is it
so let me just copy this and paste it
for every other field
all right let me save this
and back in my browser
let me inspect
and here you can see different types of
classes like ng untouched ng pristine
ng valid are added
right so this indicates that angular has
recognized the form tag
and it has added these classes to the
form as well as all the fields
so this is achieved when you add the ng
model directive in your input tag now
back in my vs code now every form has an
output property attached to it called ng
submit all right so this property can be
bound within a method that method called
the subbit method
so once submitted this method is called
right so once we click on the submit
button this method has to be called so
to include that
we'll have to just save
form
ng submit
equals
submit
[Music]
all right so now we have to define the
submit method
in our
component.ts file so here let me just go
to our component.ts file and let me
just get rid of unnecessary code here
and let's define a function
called submit
and then here let me just
console.log
form submitted
all right so let me just get rid of this
as well it's unnecessary here
let's save this so what it means is that
every time you click on the submit
button
this method is called all right so let's
just have a look at the browser so first
let's go to our console
and when i click on submit it says form
submitted
all right
so the next crucial step is to generate
javascript representation now we'll have
to make use of another directive called
ng form
that is assigned to a template variable
okay so
this javascript representation helps
with validating all the fields so i'll
help you understand that better
so back in our html file
let's just create a variable first
let's call it
login all right
and say ng
form
okay
now the mgform object includes the
javascript representation
so now while you're calling the submit
method you're going gonna pass login as
a parameter
so let's just say login here
and in my ts file
again let's just say login
and along with it
i want login to be displayed so
i say login again
so now let's save this
and if you have a look at the browser
let's click on submit
and now here you can see the javascript
representation
so
within form
i can
check
for
email
or say first name and here for this
field first name you can see different
properties attached you can see invalid
is it invalid or is it
untouched
which is true or are there any errors so
this basically gives you all information
about the particular field
so we can make use of this feature to
validate the information
so we're going to learn about that in
our next segment
moving on to form validation one way to
ensure that incorrect fields are not
submitted is by disabling the submit
button
correct now apart from this you can also
specify certain properties in your input
tag for the corresponding input field
now um
let's say that the fields that
now let's say that the fields can't be
empty
and the form only accepts names with the
minimum length of 2 and the maximum
length of 7.
all right so here in my input tag
i just mentioned required meaning this
field cannot be empty
and min length
to
2
and
max length
to say 7
all right
so to check this
let's go to our browser
and here
let me submit the form without filling
the first name
and evidently there has to be an error
so when i submit it
and i look here
what's in forms and here controls
and my first name
you can see that
an error is shown here it says
required equals true
that means that there is one error
now you can make use of these form
control objects
you can leverage form control objects to
ensure field validation and display a
message whenever an error occurs
right so to do that you need to access
these objects like errors or invalid
or touched all of these properties or
objects need to be
accessed for that we'll have to create a
template variable
and then this variable is assigned to
this object
so back in our vs code
let's create
a variable
let me call it
name
and
let's say
ng
model
all right here the variable name
receives the control object
so here back in my browser when i submit
again without
the first name
you can see that the invalid
property is set to true
correct so this helps us use this
property to alert the user with the help
of a simple if logic
so back in my
vs code
let me create
another
div tag
within which i mentioned ng if
within which i'm going to use a simple
if logic
so let's say mgf
name which is
our template variable
name
dot touched
and named dot invalid
is true
right then i'm going to alert
so i'm gonna
make use of an alert
here let's say
alert
danger
all right
so in my css file i'll have to
mention the simple styling for alert
so here let me just say
so we're going to have the background
color red
for
danger all right
and here i'm going to display the
message
invalid in bold
so now let's go back to our browser and
check it
so let me proceed without entering the
last name it says invalid here
so this was a simple demonstration to
show you form validation
of course you can modify the code
depending on your requirement
say suppose the length of the first name
is too short then you can alert the user
with a different message
or
suppose they have missed out on filling
a form field then you can again alert
the user so you can basically make use
of the nested if condition right now
just try and help you understand that
better let me just show it to you
now back in my html
file
instead of invalid let me have another
tag a paragraph tag
within which i make use of ngif again
now ngf
name dot
errors
dot required
is true
then i display the message
first
name
required
all right
and
if
the length of the first name is
[Music]
not two
now if the length of the first name is
less than 2 then i'm going to display
another message so let me just say
name dot errors
dot min length
if this is true then i'm going to say
sorry
short
first name
all right so let's save this and have a
look at the browser
when i proceed without providing the
name it says first name required
but when i type in one character it says
sorry short first name but if i type in
another character it accepts so i hope
this made you understand how form
validation works
so this was just a simple demonstration
again now i highly recommend you explore
these properties and play around with
these objects
trust me it's really fun
so i hope this tutorial helped you out
i'm sure you all know that an angular
app is divided into several components
for example you have the logo component
you have the sign in component an image
component and say a create account
component
now these components are standalone
and each of them represents a part of
the user interface
now imagine if all of these components
performed common tasks for example
accessing the database
or rendering images on the view
tasks like those
now instead of having to write the code
for every component
you can just make use of angular
services
now the service can be written once and
then injected into all of these
components
now a service could be a function it
could be a variable or a feature that an
application needs
so the main use of a service is to write
code once and avoid rewriting of it
now the same code can be injected into
several components that make use of this
particular service
but what are angular services
so normally components are used to
ensure a good user experience now that
is the extent of it components make sure
that whatever is being rendered onto the
screen is right and pristine
but in order to execute tasks we make
use of services and this approach is
ideal
so a component can basically delegate
tasks like fetching data from the server
validating user input or logging
directly to the console to a particular
service
and these tasks can be made available to
any component in the app
so now let's talk about a few features
of angular services
now typically an angular service is
simply a typescript class with an at
injectable decorator
this decorator tells angular that the
class is a service and can be injected
into components that need that service
now they can be used to share the same
piece of code they can also inject other
services as dependencies
now these services hold valuable
business logic
and can also be used to interact with
the back end
now for example if you want to make ajax
calls you can have methods to those
calls in the service and then use it as
a dependency in files
and as mentioned earlier it can be used
to share data among several components
in angular services are singleton
meaning that only a single instance of a
service gets created and the same
instance is used by each and every
building block in the application and
finally a service can be registered as a
part of a module or it can be registered
as a part of the component now to
register it as a part of the component
you'll have to specify it in the
provider's array of the module
i'm sure you'll understand the concept
of services better if we look at a
simple demo
so in the next section we're going to
look at a demo but before that let me
tell you the use case
so basically in the demo what we'll do
is we'll create an employee details list
say for example you will have employee
information like name employee id and
their email id we'll create a database
of say three employees
and on the browser when you click on the
employee button it displays the
information about that particular
employee
and at the end we can also add
information to the employee's details so
without delay let's head to our vs code
and start learning angular services
hands-on so here first i've created a
folder called demo underscore angular
within which i've created a file called
hello world
so this was previously used for a
tutorial so the name is just hello world
so don't get confused
however when you look at the browser
i've written
an initial code here which is angular
services and i have the simply learn
logo
so back in my
browser this is what the ui looks like
so uh to
so to understand the concept of angular
services
first let's go ahead and create a
component
so here i am going to say ng
g
c
e info
i'm creating a component for employee
information
so as you can see
inside my app file we have the e info
component which has these four files so
if you're wondering what exactly
components are and how this is working
then i highly suggest you watch our
components video first
so now let's go ahead and create a
service
so i'm just typing in the command ng
g
service
here g stands for generate
and we're generating a service and the
name of the service that i'm providing
is data
so now it creates a service
which is going to be
a dot ts file
so you can observe that dot service is
appended this indicates that it is a
service
all right
as mentioned earlier we have to display
the employee details correct so for that
in my component.ts file i'm going to
create an array
that displays the employee information
in our case i'm creating a three
different employee records so for that
i'll have three different arrays
so let me just call the arrays info
received
one indicating this is the information
of
first employee
and this is going to be of type string
and i'll just initialize it to null
for now
all right and i'm going to create
two other
arrays
and let me just
change
the name of that is all right
so now uh to retrieve the information
i'll have to create a method again i'm
creating three methods for uh the three
different employee records
so i'm going to call the array get
info
[Music]
from service
1 indicating it's again for employee 1
and
i'm just gonna leave it as it is for now
i'll tell you how the information is
being received
and i'm gonna do the same for the other
two uh employee records
so let me just
copy paste and here i'm just going to
change
the name of the methods
all right
so this is the initial code for
retrieving information
however we have to create the employee
record in our service
so back here in my
data.ts file
what i'm going to do is
i'll create
three different
records
for the employees
so let me say info 1
which is going to be of type string
[Music]
all right
and
let me just give random names say for
example i say john
matthew
[Music]
all right
and
employee id say e
354
and let me just give a random
email id and say jm at abc.net
all right so i'm gonna do the same for
the other two uh records
so let me just create another one and
call it info two
and
the name i'm providing is say rob
listen
with a different employee
id say 673
and i'm just going to make it
rw at
abc.net and another record
for employee number three
and
i'm just gonna say rose adams
[Music]
with
some employee id
and
an email id all right
so now
we've created the employee records
so what i have to do is i have to create
a method
that returns these employee records
correct so for that i'm just going to
create another method called get info 1
which is of type string
and it just returns
this
dot info 1.
all right
similarly for the rest of the two
records i'm just going to retrieve them
[Music]
let's say in four two
and get in for two
and again i'm just going to make it get
in for three
[Music]
and this is gonna
return
in four three
all right so i'm sure you've got an idea
as to what i'm doing here
so basically this information is going
to be retrieved in our employee
component correct so for that i'll have
to make use of dependency injection
so here i'll have to import the service
that i've created so let's go ahead and
say import
[Music]
the service was data service
all right
from
[Music]
slash data dot service all right
now the main reason we're doing this is
to tell angular
that when the component is created
the service instance is also created and
this instance is being used to perform
particular tasks and for that we'll also
have to include this in our providers
area so here
let me just say providers
[Music]
and let's say
data service
now to access this instance of service
that is created we make use of a
property
so this property basically allows us to
access all the methods that are defined
in the service class
all right so here in my constructor
method i'm just going to say
private
and you can give any name for your
property and here i'm just giving the
name d service
all right and which is of type
data service
[Music]
all right
so now with the help of this property i
can retrieve information from the
service
class so here i'm just going to save
this
dot
info receipt
equals this dot d service
dot
get info one
[Music]
all right so what it basically does is
that it calls the get info one method in
our service
which returns the information of the
first employee
and this information is being stored in
the array that is info received one
so similarly for the next
two methods i'm just going to use the
same
piece of code
let me just change it here
and
same for the third one
[Music]
all right
so now that we have the logic behind
what is being displayed
let's go ahead and create the ui for it
here in my html file
i'm going to create
an unordered list
[Music]
and now i'm going to make use of
the ng
for director
to uh basically loop over the record and
display everything
so for that i have to make use of a
particular variable so i'll just say
let info
of
info received
so um you can check here in our ts file
the
array is info received correct so i'm
going to make use of the same array here
and since it's displaying the first in
employee record i'm just going to
say
info received one
all right and let me just create a class
a bootstrap class of list
group
item of list group info
and we're just gonna have to interpolate
in
all right that is basically going to
display what the information holds what
the info variable holds
all right and here is where let me
create a bootstrap class
called list
group
all right i hope this was clear to you
so basically here
the information is being retrieved with
the help of this method right that is
get info from service one so in order to
call this method we'll have to bind it
with a button all right so that's what
we're going to do
let's just
copy this and here i'm going to create a
button
[Music]
all right
and the type
is button
[Music]
with name
button again
all right so i'm going to bind it with
the click event
so what happens is that when i click on
it
this particular method gets called
all right i'm just pasting the method
here
and finally let's just
provide the name employee one
for the button
all right
so similarly we'll have to do the same
for
the other two records as well
let me just make this look better all
right
so what i'm going to do is i'm just
going to paste the same
twice
and here i'm going to just change
the names i'll say 2 here
and this is again for employee 2
and i'm going to change this as well
it's going to be employee i'm sorry it's
going to be in 4 received 2
this is going to be in 4 received three
and finally employee three
all right
and lastly we'll have to include
the selector that is app hyphen e info
in our main
component
or html so here
let me just
create a custom tag all right and save
this so now let's go back to our browser
and see what it looks like
so here you can see that three different
buttons have been created for employee
one two and three and when you click on
it
it retrieves the information that is
the name the employee id and their email
ids
so we've successfully created an angular
service and injected it into our
component to retrieve information all
right so now the last part of the use
case that we discussed
was uh to add another
detail that is the employee detail in
the record
all right so for that we'll have to take
uh input from the user and in our case
we're taking the location now we're also
adding the same location for all three
employees
so this is what services do you know
they can be used to update modify alter
anything that happens in the back end so
you can tweak the code a little bit
and you can change the entire uh view of
your application you can add information
you can delete you can retrieve you can
alter etc all right so for that what
we're going to do is back in the html
file
we'll create a form
that basically takes the input
so i'm just going to say um
form
all right
within which i'm going to be defining a
div class
[Music]
within which i'm going to be defining a
div tag
inside of which i'll have
the input tag
of type
text
and uh the name i'm going to be
providing it will be location
all right
and we'll have a value and i'll just
[Music]
leave it blank and finally i'll have ng
model so if you're confused as to what
i'm doing here then i suggest you watch
the angular forms
uh video
it basically teaches you uh how to work
around with
angular forms
all right and now
after this we're going to have a button
so let me say button
[Music]
all right
[Music]
and i'm going to just say add
info
okay
all right so now when i'm creating the
form i'll also have to create a
template variable to access all the
values within my form so if i have to
access the location then i need a
variable to access it so here let me
just go ahead and create a template
variable let me call it
frm
and i'm going to make use of the ng form
directive
so this tells angular
that
this variable can be used
to
access all the values within the form
and since i'm using form here
i'll have to import it in my
module
file
so here
i just go ahead
and
say import forms module from angular
forms and here in my imports
[Music]
i'll just say forms
module
okay so i've imported the forms module
so now back in my html file
what i'm going to do is that i'll have
to make use of this template variable
to update my information correct
so i'll have to create another method
that will update information into the
records
so here in my component.ts file i'll
have to create another
method
and i'm going to call this method update
info method
all right
and
this basically takes in the template
variable that is form
[Music]
and let me just specify any
okay and what this is going to do
is that it updates
the record correct so i'm going to say
this
dot
d service
dot
add info now you must be wondering what
add info is
i'll just let you know in a minute and
and the value that i'm going to be
passing will be the value that you've
provided as an input which is nothing
but form
dot value dot location
all right so now
what happens is that i'll have to again
specify what add info is and this method
is going to be defined in the service
file correct
so here
i'm going to create another
method that's add
info
and i'm going to pass info as a
parameter
and what this method does is that it
just pushes the information or the data
into the arrays
so since i'm going to be pushing the
same information into all of these
arrays that is info 1 in photo and info
3 i'm just going to say this dot info
one
dot push of info
all right and the same for
[Music]
the other two areas as well
let me just
change these all right
so what exactly i'm doing is that i have
i have a method called add info which
gets information from the component
all right and it basically pushes this
information into the array and also i
have to return it so i'll say return
this dot info
1
all right
and i'll save it
and here we have another method called
update info which basically calls
uh the add info method in our service
and passes the value to it
and in my html file
also note that the button type here is
submit
and not button
so
what happens is that
now the value that we've received as an
input has to be
uh passed on to the method that is
update info so here
i'll say ng submit
[Music]
and
i'm going to call the method update
info
and i'm going to pass
frm
as
the argument
and now let's save this
and execute
so all right here you can see that we
have an input field and a button saying
add info
so now i can just go ahead and see type
usa
and when i say add info
and when i check on my
employee one details usa has been added
to the list
and same goes with employee 2 and
employee 3.
so i hope this simple demo on angular
services helped you understand the
concept better i highly recommend you
play around and explore other
possibilities
let's understand what exactly is
bootstrap
bootstrap is a powerful toolkit
basically a collection of html css and
javascript tools for creating and
building responsive web applications and
pages it is a free and open source
project based on github and originally
created by twitter
now to put it more easily bootstrap is a
giant collection of handy reusable bits
of code written in html css and
javascript
it's also a front-end development
framework that enables developers and
beginners to design quick and responsive
websites
now there are several advantages to
using bootstrap to name a few bootstrap
comes with a responsive grid
you don't have to spend time working on
your layouts
bootstrap comes with its own code for
automatically resizing images based on
the current screen size
it also comes with different components
that you can use for your web page
these components could be navigation
bars drop downs progress bars thumbnails
etc
it also offers excellent documentation
and is customizable
so bootstrap comes in extremely handy to
create responsive
user interface
so now before using bootstrap it needs
to be embedded into your application
so let's see how to embed bootstrap into
angular
now there are two ways to do it
first up is by using the bootstrap cdn
or the content delivery network
now this enables users to load css
javascript and images remotely from its
servers
the other method is to use bootstrap npm
bootstrap jquery and other packages and
frameworks can be installed via the
command prompt
in the tutorial that i am going to be
showing you i have embedded bootstrap
using npm alright so i'm sure you'll
only understand the concept better when
you look at a demo
so let's go ahead and create an
application with the help of angular
bootstrap so in this tutorial what i'm
going to be showing is the creation of a
blog post
so let me show you what we're going to
be doing
so here i've created a simple
blog
for simply learn and i've added the
simply learn logo i've also written a
few lines about
simply learn and what they offer
i've also mentioned their tag line
and when you scroll down you can see
that i've mentioned the different
courses they're offering
and when you click on the more info
button
it navigates to the official page that
gives you the overview for that
particular course
so this is for lean six sigma the same
for full stack web development
as well
and
the same for the last one that is cyber
security
and finally i have added a simple video
here to just make it more uh beautiful
so i've added a simple video
and lastly
i've also
linked our youtube channel so when you
click on the youtube icon
it will navigate to the
youtube channel
to our youtube channel here
all right so this is what we're going to
be creating
uh using angular bootstrap so i'm
hoping you're all ready for it so
without further delay let's jump in so
first let's find the template that we
want to use for our blog
so for that i'm going to just go ahead
and say
[Music]
bootstrap blog template
[Music]
and i'm just going to click on the first
link that i get
and here
you can choose the template that you
like
so i'm just going to look for more
templates here
and the one that we are going to choose
is
oh yeah this one so which is small
businesses so you can go ahead and click
on that
you can then click on live preview
and once you do that
you can just
say view frame source
so here you can see that the html code
is available
it has the head section and then the
body section
so the head section consists of a lot of
meta tags
and then you have the title
and then you also have the css file
references
and then if you look at the body tag you
have different code for different parts
of the
ui there's code for navigation bar and
then you have page content code
heading row
call to action and all of that
and lastly you have the footer
so what we're going to be doing is that
we'll take all of the code and then
we'll have to create components for each
of it and then we'll include all the
components in our main
html file
so that is the best practice that
angular uses so we're going to make use
of components
and you can also see that
when you scroll down you can see that
it has certain dependencies so here it
has the bootstrap dependency and then
you have jquery so
we'll have to
download them
so we'll have to install them
and as mentioned earlier we're going to
be installing them with the help of npm
so for that we'll have to head back to
our vs code here
back in my vs code i've created a
folder called angulardemo
and then i've also created a file called
demo components
and here
i'm just going to say cd
demo components
within which i'll say npm
install
jquery
[Music]
so this could take a while
and once you've installed jquery go
ahead and type npm install
bootstrap
[Music]
all right so we've successfully
installed jquery and bootstrap
so now we need to add the references to
these javascript files to do that
go to your
angular.json file
and here we have to add them in our
build section so here you can see we
have styles and scripts so in our
scripts array we define the relative
path to these javascript files
so these files are generally
stored in your node modules so go ahead
and
here you can look for bootstrap
here you go and
then in your dist file
and then click on js
and then you can see you have
bootstrap.min.js
oh well i'm sorry we need
bootstrap.bundle.min.js so here
you can just right click and say copy
relative path
and back in my json file in my scripts
i'm gonna just paste it here
and make sure to
make it a path by providing by providing
forward slash
[Music]
all right and then the next thing we
need is the
jquery.min.js files so for that
again in our node modules you'll have to
look for jquery so here there's jquery
and then click on dist
and then we have jquery.min.js
so again let me just
copy the path
and paste it here
[Music]
follow the same procedure for this as
well
all right so we've embedded both our
files in our
angular.json file
so now in our code here in the beginning
they've also included the css file
so we'll have to embed that as well so
here back
in
bootstrap
let me just add the css file as well
that's
bootstrap.min.css i'm just going to copy
the relative path
and just provide it here
[Music]
let me just change these
to forward slash
[Music]
okay so we have our custom style sheet
so what i'm going to do is i'm just
going to copy this
and just paste it in our
[Music]
and then you can just paste it here
all right
so i think we've added all the
dependencies
and the custom style sheet and
everything so now let me just
close all of these files
what we can do now is that we can go
ahead and uh take the code from the
source here so i'm just going to copy
the body tag
all right
so
i'm going to copy this till the footer
and then i'm just going to paste it in
my
component.html file
[Music]
so as mentioned earlier i will create
components and then place the code for
specific parts of the ui in these
components
so
let me just see if i've got everything
here
okay
so i'll be creating four components
the first one will be for the navigation
bar
the second will be for the introduction
and then the third one will be
to display the courses that we're
providing
and then lastly we'll have the footer
component
right so first let's create these
components i've also created a
components folder here in my app folder
so i just have to
type in the command
ng g c
first we'll create
the
component for the top navigation bar so
i'm just saying n g g c so i'm just
gonna say components
slash nav bar
[Music]
all right so
the component has been created so what
i'm going to do is i'll just
copy this
[Music]
and paste it here
[Music]
all right and the next component i'm
going to be creating is for the
introduction right so i'll say ng
g
c
components slash intro
all right so
so i will have to take
this code here i'm also going to be
including the call to action part
so i'll just
copy paste this one in my
intro.html file
so let me do that and then i'm going to
have the
main course content
component so for that i'll say nggc
components slash courses
[Music]
and we're going to copy the next part of
the code
[Music]
all right until
till the footer
[Music]
let me just add it here
and finally we're going to create the
component for the footer so
i'll say ng gc
components slash
footer
and the last part of the code i'm just
going to add it there
[Music]
all right
so now we'll have to create the custom
html tags for these components and then
place it in our html file right so first
one that we created was the navigation
bar so here
head over to the ts file
just copied the selector
[Music]
and then here
and then in our app.component let me
just
create the tags
similarly for intro
[Music]
i'm just going to copy the selector
[Music]
and then for courses
so
[Music]
app hyphen courses
that is well
[Music]
and then lastly we have the footer
component so let me just copy that
[Music]
paste it here
all right so we've included all the
components so let's just run this
application and see if everything
is displayed intact so here let me just
say ng
serve so when you execute the command
you can see that the template is being
displayed so you have the navigation bar
you have the
intro component and then we have the
courses component and finally we have
the photo component right okay so now
that we have the template ready we can
go ahead and customize it according to
our needs
so now i'm going to be making a few
changes to the code we're going to add
the simply learn logo we're going to
change the tag line here we're going to
display something else over here
all right so let's go back to our vs
code to customize
and display the final output
so here
the first thing that i'm going to be
doing is
changing the message here i'm gonna
display simply learn for that
in our navbar component
let's go to the html code
and here instead of start bootstrap let
me just type in simply learn
[Music]
all right
so when you save it and when you look at
the browser
you can see that
learn is displayed
and the next thing that i want to do is
i want to add the image right i simply
learn logo
so what i've done here is i've already
added
the logo
dot png file in my assets folder
so i'll just go ahead and provide the
path to this
so that's going to be in our intro files
so here
image source
is going to be
[Music]
assets
slash
[Music]
logo.png
so let me save this
so there we go the logo is displayed
so the next thing is we'll have to
change
this part of the ui so the information
that i want to display is this
i'm going to be displaying
walls number one online boot camp and
other information so what i'm gonna do
is back in my vs code i'm just gonna
delete
this
and instead of that i'm just gonna
copy this that's world's number one
online bootcamp
[Music]
and then within the paragraph tag i'll
display something else so let me get rid
of this
[Music]
let me just copy the information that i
want to display
paste it here
[Music]
and let me just give a line break
[Music]
let me save this and see if it's
displayed
so yeah we can see that the information
is being displayed
next up here instead of displaying call
to action message i'm going to display
uh explore programs message so let's go
back to our vs code
let me just say explore
programs here
and then
lastly
instead of this message here
i want to display the message get
certified get ahead with our programs
so back in our vs code
i'm just going to get rid of this
[Music]
and paste this instead
[Music]
so when you
have a look at the browser
let me refresh this
you can see it displays the message get
certified get ahead and all of that
uh well now what i'm going to do is i'm
really not happy with the font size and
everything so i'm just go ahead and add
certain styling you can customize this
and provide your own font size and all
of that
so here i'm just going to mention style
and then say font
size
and i'm going to make it xx large
all right so let's see
[Music]
yeah all right so it's the font size has
increased so i think i'm happy with this
all right so the next thing we have to
do is add information here for our
courses
so back in our vis code
we'll have to go to the courses
component so here i'm gonna just uh type
in the code for the different courses so
i already have it here
so the first thing is this message that
i want to display let me just copy that
and for our first tag i'm just gonna say
post graduate program ending six sigma
and the next information i'm gonna be
providing is the duration
so here
let me just get rid of this
paste that here
let me just break the line
to beautify the
code
and then
and here for our
reference link i already have the link
here
so i'm just going to paste that so once
you click on the
more info button it will automatically
navigate to this page
all right so let me save this
next up i'm going to do the same for the
other two courses as well
so it says postgraduate program in full
stack development
and then we're going to mention the
duration and the cohort so
let me paste that
and also
provide a blind break
and then
link i have it here so
i'm just going to paste that
[Music]
and finally for the third card i have
the third link here
[Music]
let me get rid of this extra core and
paste this instead
[Music]
and then let's also provide the link for
the
same all right
so let me save this
and have a look at the browser
so you can see that
the information has been added
you can see it displays postgraduate
program in lean six sigma full stack
development and cyber security so once i
click on more info it leads you to that
page
that shows the overview all right
so now the next thing on the agenda was
to uh display a short video and then the
link to our youtube channel so let's go
ahead and add that in our
courses component
uh so what i'm going to do is i'm just
going to get the code to add a video
from google and then i'm going to uh
provide the source
which is going to be the video that i
want to display
so i've received the code i'm just going
to paste it here
so you can get the code uh on google so
go ahead and just paste that
also for the source i have a video in my
assets folder which i have provided here
so when i save it and look at the
browser here we go you can see the video
here
all right
and once clicked it starts playing
[Applause]
[Music]
all right and lastly we'll have to
provide the logo for youtube and then
the link to navigate to the youtube page
so let's go ahead and do that
[Music]
so here again i've pasted the code
for the youtube logo so here you can see
that i've added the image that is
youtube.png in my assets folder and i've
provided the source
and accordingly i've also added
the styling i've provided a white
background and i've also aligned the
text to the
center of the page
all right and i've also displayed the
message saying check out our youtube
channel for technical videos and
tutorials and then i provided the link
to our channel on youtube
so let me just save this and head back
to the browser
and here you can see that
we have the youtube logo
and we have the message displayed
so once you click on the
logo it navigates to the simply learn
channel on youtube
all right so uh if you want you can also
change the message here for the footer
so here in footer.html i can just
remove this and
paste this i say simply on solutions and
all rights reserved
when i save it and look at the browser
it must get updated
so yeah there we go
so with the help of bootstrap we have
successfully created a website which is
basically a blog
and we've also added the reference links
and images and logos to customize it
according to our requirements
so yeah this is it this is how you make
use of bootstrap and embed it into your
angular
for more responsive and better user
interface let's have a look at the
basics of routing
now i'm sure that you observed that the
url changes every time you click on a
particular link or on an icon on the
user interface correct now this
basically indicates that you are
navigating throughout the application
now to achieve this navigation we use a
mechanism called routing routing is
essentially used to navigate through a
website or a web application
but how is it achieved in angular
especially in angular routing plays a
major role it is used to create single
page applications
now these applications are loaded just
once and new content is added
dynamically
applications like google facebook
twitter and gmail are a few examples of
single page applications
the best part of using single page
applications is that it provides an
excellent user experience and you don't
even have to wait for new pages to load
which by extension makes single page
applications extremely fast but how is
this new content loaded
enter routing now routing is the
mechanism that as discussed earlier
that is used to navigate through the
application and load new content
routing helps angular configure the
route and the component that needs to be
displayed
now i'm sure you're going to understand
the concept of routing better when you
work on it hands-on
so in the demo we're going to be
navigating to the login and the home
pages of a web application with the help
of routing
so let's head to our visual studio code
so basically the objective of our
application
is to navigate to home
and the login pages so when i click on
the login icon here
it loads the login
page
and here you can see the extension
slash login and similarly with home once
you click on it some new information
gets added and the url changes
with the slash home appended
all right so this is the main objective
of our application so to create it let's
head back to our vs code all right so
here i've created a folder called demo
and underscore angular and i've created
a file called demo routing now the first
thing you want to do is open the
index.html file and make sure that the
base tag is added
now although this is generally
added when your app is created if it is
not then add a base tag with href
attribute which is set to a forward
slash
all right now this is generally done to
tell angular to construct the url while
navigating with a forward slash all
right and the next thing you want to do
is open your
app.module.ts file and check if the app
routing module has been imported
if not go ahead and import it and then
also mention it in your imports array
with that the initial setup is done
now to create the nav bar the code that
i'm going to be using is already
explained in the previous video that is
angular bootstrap i highly suggest you
go through that video before watching
this
so uh the code is already available i'm
just going to create a component and
write the code for it
and paste the code in it
so let's do that
let me say
ng
gc
navbar
[Music]
all right so this component is now
created
now here in my html file
i'll just get rid of this and paste the
code for the nav bar
so here we go i've pasted the code for
the navigation bar
and back in my
app.component.html file
i'll just remove all the
unwanted code here
and just specify the
custom html tag for my navbar
so
let me just create one here
all right let me save this let me just
run the application and see if it's
displaying correctly
all right so when i open the browser
the navigation bar has been created
along with
these different options that's home
about services and login
all right and we also have the simply
learn icon here all right now the next
step is to generate the components to
display the login page content and the
home page content
now again i have used bootstrap to
define the user interface for these
files you can easily find the code
online just search for
bootstrap login templates and depending
on your requirements you can choose the
appropriate one
so first let's create the components for
by two files that is for the home
component
and the login component
so
let's go ahead and do that
ngc
i'm just going to call it login for my
login component
all right and then i'm gonna say nggc
home for the home component
all right
so i'm just going to copy the
code for the login component
so back in my login.html
file
[Music]
i'll just paste the code here
okay
also note that i've added the simply
learn logo in my assets folder
and then just provided the source for it
here in my login component
all right
so next up is the home component
and if you've seen the previous video
that is angular bootstrap you might have
seen that we created three different
components that is intro courses and
footer which included the content for
the intro message for the courses and
the photo message correct so here we're
going to just paste the code for all of
these three
and then just display it when the home
button is clicked
all right so what i'm going to do is
i'll just
paste it here
[Music]
so this basically has all the content
one thing i want to tell you is that in
the previous video we made sure that the
code was written in three different
components however for this i've just
added all the code in the same component
now i agree that this is not the best
practice so if you want you can go ahead
and create three different components
and separate the code into these three
components and just add the custom html
tags in your home component
i'm just hoping you're following me
right now
and also here in my assets folder i've
added
a video and the youtube logo that needs
to be displayed
when the home icon is clicked
all right so now that we've created the
home and the login components
the next step is to configure the routes
for the application
all right so here you can see that we
have a file called app routing module.ts
file
so here
we have the routes and the router module
that is imported
and we also have a constant called
routes which is strongly typed to routes
from the router package
all right now this array is used to
define all the possible routes in the
application
now each route is basically an object
with a path
so here in my routes array
i'm just going to go ahead and create
the paths that is we have two different
routes right one is for login and one is
for home
so i'm just going to create a path
object so let's say path
i'm sorry within curly braces i say path
[Music]
and then the path that i'm going to give
is
login
this is basically what will appear
on the url
all right
and the component that needs to be
navigated to is nothing but the login
component
so let me just say login
component
as you can see the login component has
been automatically imported
now same with
the home
path so let me just say
path
home
and the component that needs to be
rendered is the home component
[Music]
all right
now the next step is to link these
routes to a button in the nav bar that
is the home and the login button right
so we're going to make use of the nav
tag and an anchor tag for this
you can see that we have a nav tag
and an anchor tag
which encloses the login and the home
components
all right now we're going to make use of
two directives
from the router package called router
link and router link active
now these are specified within the
anchor tag the router link basically
holds the path to the page
and the latter that is the router link
active specifies one or more css classes
that will be applied when the router
link is active
all right so to do that let me just
add
router
link
all right in our case it is home here
and we're going to have another
director called
router link active
[Music]
and we're just going to say
active here
[Music]
all right
same for the login icon here
let me just copy this
[Music]
and instead of home
the path we created for this was login
[Music]
all right
so this is how you can bind the route to
your specific button on your ui
now despite of all this
how are we specifying where these
components are to be displayed
right the answer to this is using the
router outlet directive now again this
directive is available in the router
package
so we have to add that in our app
component.html file
so here just go ahead and type router
outlet
[Music]
all right
so with that we've created a simple
navigation bar which has different
options that is home about services and
link and once the user clicks on the
home icon it displays the content that
is in the home component dot html file
and once the user clicks on the login
component it displays the content in the
login.html file
all right it's as simple as that
so now let's go to the browser and see
if it executes correctly
so all right we have the navigation bar
and once i click on the home i can hear
all right yes we see that all the
content has been loaded
you can see we have uh the intro section
we have the courses section and the
footer section as discussed
and the most important part is that here
in our url you can see that slash home
has been appended this shows that a
route has been created that navigates to
the home component
so we've successfully created a route
here
and for login component when i click on
this icon
you can see that the path changes here
and the login component gets displayed
alright so this is how routing is
achieved in angular hello this is
matthew with simply learn so let's cover
what we're going to go through today so
we're going to go through what node j is
what the architecture for node j is how
can you use node package manager which
is one of the tools that comes with
node.js it's actually a very important
tool uh what are the different types of
node.js modules there are the http
module and that is defaulted and with
node.js the file system the events the
express framework and
working with databases and industry
trends so quite a lot to cover but we'll
get through it quite quickly i think
so what is node.js so node.js is an open
source cross-platform javascript runtime
it allows you to build web applications
inside and outside of a client's browser
it is absolutely fantastic for creating
web applications a really great way to
speed up your delivery it's also great
for developing solutions that are
asynchronous and event driven and uh
what you'll find is that with node.js
one of the other things that you'll find
is that it's just absolutely loaded with
tools that really allow you to
accelerate the way that you deliver your
solutions
a little bit of history node.js was
originally developed by ryan dial back
in 2009
the latest version as of this discussion
right now is version 13.3.0
one of the most popular open source
solutions out there just a ton of people
contributing to it so let's kind of deep
dive into the architecture
so node.js uses a architecture what's
known as a single threaded event loop
and this allows it
to handle multiple concurrent clients
very easily so we visualize that and
what happens is that you have your
requests coming in and you have your
event queue and then a threaded pool
which does your computation database and
file system analysis and then we have
our event loop that just spirals through
very quickly and actually helps you
manage the transactions it's a very
efficient way of
running the communications throughout
the system
node package manager is a key tool that
comes with
node.js it has really two functions one
is it allows you to
access online uh repositories um
such as express or mongodb or uh allows
you um to and you can go out you can
actually search those uh for packages
online go to search.nodejs.org
there's something like 50 000 different
packages that you can use um it also
comes with a command line utility that
you can actually come in and and
actually manage your packages and you'll
find that with all of the solutions i
think there's about a dozen um node.js
videos that we've created and all of
them you'll see that we use mpm in every
single one of those demos so it's really
key that you have npm it does install by
default when you install node.js so um
you'll have it now a good way to be able
to validate which version of node.js you
have is to open up your terminal window
and then type in npm dash dash
uh version and that lets you bring back
the version number of your mpm module
then once you have npm you can actually
then go in and install a module name
right from npm so
in installing a module is really easy
you just type in npm install and the
module name the example here is express
and then source express
js really fast way of being able to
install codes and what's great about it
is that as you're writing out your
script you actually can put in the
script how to um to have the default
install modules so that whoever takes
that package will have exactly the same
environment that you're watching so
let's deep dive into modules because
there are key components of working with
node.js and so modules are really just
like they're kind of like javascript uh
libraries um so extensions to uh node.js
um it's just a to be able to have a
module um inside of your application you
have to use the uh require function and
then uh you can then uh specify uh
like for instance if there's a default
module such as http um then you can just
put in http uh but if you need to be
able to uh require a module that's
outside of the defaults then you can
actually have
the install from npm which we did in the
previous slide actually install what the
module is such as express
so there are a bunch of core modules uh
http for a default web server
is installed
you also have url for url passing query
string which allows you to work with uh
methods um but you know you have here a
list of the different types of modules
that you can use so let's deep dive into
one of the modules which is the http
module and the reason why you want to
deep dive into it is because you can use
http quite a bit just to get up and
running with different solutions so um
as i said http is a
core module um it's really designed for
being able to transfer data over the
internet as you would with any other
http service it does use the require
method um so that when you run it you'll
actually have
you can actually require the http module
to be instantiated when you're building
out your solutions and the web server
will then will
come up running so for instance in this
instance
we could
say we can do a very simple script and
if we go through first line here is var
http equals require and then requiring
the http server to be instantiated and
then after that in line two we actually
they create a function and that function
is going to have two key elements uh the
res right um is uh puts um posts a hello
world uh comment to the screen
then
we have a end to the response and then
the final line actually will then post
out to which port
to look for on the local host so here we
have an example of the response so the
local host is uh going to port 8080 and
there we have the text for hello world
again really easy we created a default
um script and
forced the script to post out onto a
default port and we did that all in half
a dozen or so lines of code so let's
jump into node.js file system so with
node.js file system um it allows you to
actually allow you to work with a file
system on a computer again it uses the
require method um to be able to be used
in a solution so if you want to have the
files that have been used inside of your
code you do have to use the require
command for that so let's jump into
nodejs events and so every action on a
computer is an event such as opening up
a file connecting to the internet really
anything that you do
with the click of a mouse is an event
and node.js has a built-in module that
helps you manage and listen for those
kind of actions to happen and so here we
have an example of a basic event model
inside of node.js you know we have in
the top line we explicitly call out the
events so that we know that we're
looking for something to actually happen
uh inside of our script now we create
the object for the event emitter
allows us to listen for that and then we
create a function that listens for the
handle that gets created we're looking
for what type of events to actually be
created so it's on click event
and that's the trigger so whenever you
go ahead and you know click on the
terminal window you just click popping
out in your terminal so let's look at
node.js express framework so node.js
comes with a http server but if you want
to really take it to the next level and
you want to build out a more
sophisticated application you want to
use the web framework that comes with
node.js for building out both web and
mobile applications and so here we're
going to require express which actually
installs express.js
express.js is a very popular open source
project by itself but it's bundled into
um it can be bundled into your node
project by using npm and so we step
through the first line actually goes out
and calls out express to be installed
and then we put together a function that
does our requests and responses that get
managed from
node.js and that allows us to have our
objects go back and forth and be passed
within a web server environment in this
instance we're actually listening to
port 8081 on our default host and we're
actually using server.address to listen
for our host and our port on our server
and we're able to then dynamically
create a console message so if we look
at the example here now we've actually
got a console message that's popped up
onto the screen that is a def which is
dynamic uh to
our own individual environment so if we
were actually to move and be posting and
pushing out our solution to a different
name server then that name server would
appear on our console and here we have
our message as it appears printed from
the web server onto our browser page now
you may wonder why would you use
express.js and it seems to be very
similar to the default http uh server
that's bundled in node.js the reason why
is that you can build just more
sophisticated applications with node.js
than you can with just your traditional
the default http service
so let's jump into node.js with
databases node.js as you can imagine can
be used with a lot of different
databases um a default is my sql but you
can also use mongodb and there are
connectors for both um that make it very
easy so for instance with my sql you can
actually just use the my sql connector
and it will install my sql and you can
be up and running and connected to my
sql in you know really minutes um you
don't have to wait for a long time to uh
set up a server environment and get it
running for what you need and the same
is true for mongodb mongodb the
difference between that and my sequel is
mongodb is a nosql environment
we actually have a mongodb video where
it shows node.js and mongodb working
together with each other i highly
recommend you
for you to check that out if you want to
see how that works and as you can
imagine i'm putting in mongodb is also
very very easy you just put in the
variable to require mongodb and in the
terminal window you would just do npm
install mongodb you actually install the
full mongodb environment on your local
machine so you can actually do your
development testing and you then have to
use the mongodb compass tool to be able
to access and view your solution as
you're building it locally so let's go
through a demo of putting together a
very simple uh weather application using
an api and that allows you to see how
you can actually control node.js
with your own scripts
let's go and create a
node.js
weather app called weatherly so what you
can see is we just put in a
address and it came back with the degree
celsius in bengal and you can put in you
know new york and sect weather and we're
actually playing against an api here
that allows us to get the actual
temperature and so here we have it's 22
degrees in new york city right now so
let's go ahead and show how you're going
to build this out so the first thing you
want to do is we're going to use node.js
that's what we're building all of our
solutions are
node.js which is nodejs.org is the
website
and you have options for downloads uh
we're gonna go with the the latest
download
and you also have a download options
where you can download for other
operating systems and by default when
you actually go to the website you'll
detect which os you're running and give
you the appropriate download but you can
go and choose out other versions if you
wanted to and you'll also notice that uh
the latest version of node also includes
uh node package manager or npm
and we'll need that for some of our
solutions that we're building later on
to validate whether or not you have node
included so you can actually just go in
and type node
version and terminal window and that
you'll come back with the version number
if it's installed that's the caveat if
you don't have it installed then you
won't come up with anything and you'll
know that you have the wrong version
same thing for npm go to npm dash dash
version and if it's in store boom you
can get a version that's um that you can
validate is yours and we're up and
running with the latest versions of node
here
and you also want to have a text editor
now my personal preference is vs code or
visual studio code um you go to
code.visualstudio.com
and it's um an open source software from
microsoft um it's really good it's and
it will run on all uh leading um os's
and it allows you just to run and
install a really nice text editing tool
and and it's it's really like notepad on
steroids but it's just really really
good
and then you also we're going to be
using uh the open weather map for an api
and so if you do open weather map uh in
google search it'll actually show a link
for their weather api
and you'll be able to connect that here
we're actually just going to go
and show what the open weather map
website looks like but across the top
you can see that we have different
options and api is one of those options
we're going to be using that quite a bit
in our application so there's different
apis in yet such as the current weather
the forecast and uh daily forecast for
16 days and if you click on any one of
these such as the current weather
forecast it'll actually show you
what the api will look like now one of
the things that you'll need for your api
is you need the city name plus your api
key and i'll show you how to get that in
a moment but these are the different
types of calls that you can make
all right let's go back to
our terminal window so we're going to
open up the s code
and
we want to go ahead and open up a folder
we're going to create a new folder we're
going to be building our our project
just be on the desktop and we're going
to create a new folder here and we're
going to call this for the weather dash
app we're going to select that folder
and open it
and this will be now the folder that
we'll be building our solution in and
then we can get rid of the welcome
screen we don't need that anymore so
let's go ahead and open up terminal
window and this is one thing you can do
is you can actually run terminal window
inside of vs code really nice so let's
go ahead and format this folder so that
it's actually a
node package manager fold a formatted
folder so npm init
and by default we're running on our
folder and so it's now going to go ahead
and create the package.json file now
we're going to name the the uh we can
give it a name we can call it weatherly
um but then we can just go with the
defaults for the rest of the application
so just kind of keep hitting return and
then what you'll see on the in the
folder is we now have a package.json
file and yeah we put in the name there
but then we have the rest of the
metadata uh index.js is going to be the
key uh file that we build our
application from so let's go ahead and
create a file called index.js
and
well we're going to open that up yep and
that makes sure that matches up you got
to make sure everything matches up for
these files just
otherwise if you get it wrong
then your files are going to load
anything so there's plenty of core
constructions and and so make sure that
express is required express
is a http server um it's really nice to
use as part of the man framework of
mongodb
express
react and node.js we're also going to
put in a element called bodyparser which
gets used with
express and then we're going to request
put in a request and we kind of require
a request to be installed
and then we're going to make sure that
we have these installed in our channel
window so going to do npm install
save express
and
body parser
[Music]
and request this will install everything
into our folder
and it's going to go ahead and download
the latest versions
and this is one of the benefits of using
npm is that
as you are packaging together your
application it will pull out and ensure
that the developers all have the latest
and greatest
all right so now we see that our
dependencies have been installed we have
everything
supporting um our
requirements and so let's go ahead and i
will start defining our app and so our
app's going to be an express app
and we're going to have an api key that
we want to reference and this is going
to be from the weather
app that we'll be using
and
these are just some variable some
constants for our application
and app.use express
static
and we can make it public all right so
let's create a new folder and we're
going to call that folder public
and inside the public
we'll create a sub folder we're going to
call this one css
this is going to be our styling
and we're going to create another folder
called images
this allows us to
use body parser to pull in
url encoded
elements
so app set
view
engine
and we use egs and egs is a
extended template design for
js that we can use
right embedded javascript
and we're going to listen on port 3000
and so we're going to run our server
it's going to be localhost server and
it's going to run on port 3000.
in our console.log we have put
instructions to tell us that the
weatherly app is listening on port 3000
all right so we're going to go and
initialize node.js we're going to type
in node index.yes and this will
initialize the app
there we go you can see that the app is
now running on port 3000 so if we come
over to our localhost
and oh an error can i get oh that's
probably because we have
two apps running on the same port
so let's just cancel the other one
and so let's go app
dot get
and put in our function
[Music]
render
index.js oh that's right that's right
now make sure we're rendering the
correct part of our solution
okay so let's create a new folder under
views and we call this one index.egs
and that stands for embedded javascript
which is
is a template
model that we can use
for
rendering
our code
right so we're just going into our egs
file and
putting in our defaults
so i'm gonna
link to our style guide
and css
and here's our link
css
style dot css
and
we have this in the downloads
go ahead and download this we're gonna
have a default css file that you can use
all right so under css would i type in
css
so we actually have something reference
and
[Music]
so let's put in the link
now i'm going to go ahead and link to
some fonts
if you haven't used
any of the google fonts before they
great online repository where you can
install
uh really i think they have hundreds of
fonts now
and we're going to use open sounds
[Music]
okay
all right
so let's start putting together our
content on our page so open our
container
and a form
element
so we want to be able to have a post
element so we can actually
submit
what country or what city we're looking
to get
the weather for and then we'll have a
response
so it's just going to be a text field
followed by a button
so but
city as the name of the text field
and then the placeholder will be enter
city
so that will be actually in the text
field
so we refresh
i'm still getting an error let's go back
to look at our code
we need to rerun this rerun so node
index.js
and we're still getting error
so we couldn't find the module
ejs so we need to make sure that we're
pulling this into our code correctly
so this
mp oh that's right we need to install
ejs so let's install that
here we go
installed
let's rerun index.js
there we go
very simple page you can see that we
have enter a city
now we can go back
all right so let's go in
and
[Music]
i'm gonna put input type
id
submit
and this is going to be a
submit
and we're going to be looking to get the
weather and that's going to be
the text on the button
and we already have some class files
already defined in our css document
you'll see it in a moment
it's going to be ghost top button
and the class here is going to be ghost
dash input
let's rerun that index.js
now you see that we have a button there
we don't have any styling yet we need to
bring that over
let's go over to our css file and it's
blank
but we already have
everything already written
in a package and so again you'll find
the complete program here can be
downloaded
in the
details for this video
and you can see that we have all the css
starting correctly saved so make sure we
save that file
type in the comment styles are
let's close out that comment
and so you can go to
https
codepen
dot io
and it's
slash official underscore
naveen
slash pan
slash
rjk and that will give you all of these
files
all right let's rerun everything so node
index.js
all right so we're starting to get some
styling and we have
our text field
and our button
let's go back to
vs code
we're going to hit some more
more css fire and formatting
you'll see we actually have to pull in a
weather jpeg we'll put that into the
images folder here
so we'll just drop that in boom there we
go
there's our nice fluffy cloud
save that file
you'll see that everything is pulling in
correctly
for
our
index.egs file
let's go back down to terminal window
rerun the index.js node and now
we get a much more pleasant design
so you can actually see the text isn't
white for the get weather button
and we have that now base container
which is
the first thing that you see on screen
okay
all right so let's go back to index.egs
all right so what we want to be able to
do is put the the weather on our screen
here
so we're going to update the
field set now
so let's go to styles
and we're going to place in as default
style
for fieldset
and of course we have to go in and
rerun
the index.js file
you just see a little bit more padding
around
the actual application
and
here we go
and we've got an error that's all right
means we can
fix this
come in to our solution
and our index.js file
and we're going to add in a new feature
here that allows us
to
post
post and refresh the page when we post
and
we will put in
[Music]
the city and we'll pull that from our
input text which is labeled city
the url
so i'll just be
playing this is the structure we need to
capture
that's our api call
so here's our
url
type in the full path
and we have to make some changes here
obviously so
we want to dynamically press in the city
name so let's change that here
we put in
dollar sign which is the
escape key to allow us to play our own
um commands and so we can put in city
this will be allowed to pull us from the
input text field for city and now we
need to put in our api key so let's just
reduce that and we'll put in the dollar
sign and we'll put an api key which is
again
pulling from the api key at the top here
so obviously we'll have to put our api
in there but that does allow does
prevent us from having to rewrite that
over and over again which is good
and then console log
body city
okay so let's sign in and oh we're
already signed in so that's good so
that's my account
but you can sign in with your own we
need to get an api key so that's apis
and
[Music]
create a key name
so this one we're going to call it
weather
weatherly that's the name of our app
and here we go
here's our api key that's been created
so we just want to copy that
so
put in to notepad
um
you will have to generate your own api
key though if you reuse the one i'm
using here it simply won't work for you
because it's tied to the app that i've
created
so just go ahead and just render your
own api key
all right so let's go and grab your api
i'm going to go back over to our app
we'll just paste in the api here
i want
[Music]
okay so now we should have be able to
dynamically
pull
from our api so we'll rerun the code
and let's go over to our weatherly app
all right so centro city
let's type in bangalore
and here we are in
our log it's pulling in bangalore so we
know that that's been captured correctly
which is good
now we're going to
write in the commands to
complete our application
okay so we're going to respond
okay let's render it into the
index file
and if there's an error
please try again
not
let's pass the
adjacent packet
into the body of the script
so as you see there's it's a fairly
basic application allows us to
pull and push api content pretty easily
if there's any error messages
i'll make sure that we
tell us tell the user to try again
save our code
and
we'll put the weather
response
and this will be city up with
the weather
text
and in this
weather city so these are all values
we're playing from the json file
from the
api that we're pulling back
okay
good
good looking good
make sure everything matches up
correctly
send a message to our console log
looking good
let's rerun the app
node index.js
okay everything's running correctly
let's rerun the app
good we'll type in bangalore
hit get weather
and now we have all the information
yeah in
[Music]
our terminal window so by pulling that
body actually pulls back the full json
packet that we get from
the api request
and you can see that we have just
different matchups here so
like for instance you see clouds
is a description
we have temperature
and we can
then start manipulating
all of that content
and so we want to make sure that the
value comes back in metrics so we just
added in a new
value there so
we ran the script let's go in and
rewrite the application
type in bangalore
because previously the if you don't then
everything comes back in
kelvin
so now we have the temperature has come
back in metric so 28 degrees
about 305 degrees kelvin which is great
because now we can actually start using
this content
as you can see there's a lot of content
here so we can actually
um
really use it to
modify our presentation
so let's type in new york to see some
additional information
and go back to vs code
and now you see that new york we have
new york
just the weather for that
right let's go back to our egs file
and now we can actually start
doing some
pulling in some of the data that we
received back
from the api call
all righty so let's put in for our
weather response
i'm just putting a paragraph here
okay
so if
error
is no
okay
um and so this is the
egs template doing the work
so here's our template
bring back the weather information
and it's going to reference the
formatting that we have
developed already
okay
let's rerun
okay here we run the application
[Music]
type in bangalore
and there we are we have
and we can do
oh that was just a error message so
let me see that we got our error message
correct
so then
we're able to pull in the correct
messaging
for our weather
so we wanted to change
the
structure we can certainly do that
and so if we type in new york
it's going to default to new york city
it's 23 degrees with clear in new york
and that's our demo
so finally let's look at some of the
industry trends and why you'd want to
learn node.js so
there are some number of really key
things one of them is that javascript
simply is just an extremely popular and
highly in demand
scripting language having node.js is in
the top 10 most in demand jobs worldwide
so there's lots of opportunities
we've seen things such as you know
node.js
the number of downloads has increased by
40 over the last year um is just
tremendously the number of people
looking to install node.js not so much
because they're just trying to download
install it's because they're actually
using it which is fantastic um more
importantly some of the biggest
companies out there are using node.js so
you can actually get work with them and
we're seeing that just the poor value of
javascript continues to increase so
on the right hand side of the screen you
see that javascript is now the number
one
programming scripting and markup
language
out there
outside of html and css and so just you
know just tremendous popularity and what
we're finding is that node.js developers
continue to get more and more salary
options um you know you can see here
that uh in india the average salary
option is around 613 000 rubies which is
just phenomenal and then in the united
states you know a a mature uh node.js
developer can be easily looking for a
salary of 104
or more thousand a year in this session
we will learn about the database and the
need for a database then we will
transition to sql and see some basic sql
queries
after knowing what a sql query is we
will see the features and application
subscript query and then we will have a
hand on some of the basic sql queries so
hey everyone i am abisar ruja from
simply learn and welcome to this video
on sql basics for beginners but before
we begin if you love watching tech
videos subscribe to our channel and hit
the bell icon to never miss an update
let's start with database
a database is a vast collection of data
that is stored and retrieved
electronically from a system in today's
world data has become the new oil which
has mandate companies and businesses to
rely on an excellent database to store
the vast amounts of data
every millisecond the tech giants are
accumulating vast amounts of data that
need to be stored the database comes
with features to update and effortlessly
manipulate data and not only that
these database provider companies ensure
the data to be safe and secure they also
provide tools to extract useful
information to help the companies make
meaningful decisions
after knowing about the database let's
see how sql communicates with the
database to get desired results
sql stands for structured query language
the structured query language is the
standard language used by database
operators and developers to carry out
different operations from manipulating
updating and retrieving data from
relational databases
now let us see how we write a basic
query
there is a customer table with columns
customer id customer name
age gender date of purchase address item
and price
and we need to extract the customer id
and customer name from this table
so we will write a query select customer
id comma customer name from customers
semicolon
when we will execute the query in mysql
workbench we will get the desired result
that is the output table with customer
id and customer name
this is how we write a query to extract
the information from the database we'll
see some more queries as the session
proceeds
now we'll see what the features of sql
are
sql lets you access any information
stored in a relational database
with sql queries data is extracted from
the database in a very efficient way
the structured query language is
compatible with all database systems
from oracle ibm to microsoft
and it doesn't require much coding to
manage databases
now we will see applications of sql
sql is used to create a database define
its structure implement it and lets you
perform many functions
sql is also used for maintaining an
already existing database
sql is a powerful language for entering
data modifying data and extracting data
in a database
sql is extensively used as a client
server language to connect the front-end
with the back-end the supporting the
client-server architecture
sql when deployed as data control
language dcl
helps protect your database from
unauthorized access
after knowing sql with its features and
applications
let's go through some basic queries in
sql
that is ddl data definition language dml
data manipulation language dcl data
control language tcl transaction control
language
ddl or data definition language consists
of the sql commands that can be used to
define the database schema
let's see ddl commands create command is
used to create the database or its
objects like table index function views
store procedure and triggers
drop is used to delete objects from the
database
truncate is used to remove all records
from a table
alter is used to alter the structure of
the database
dml or data manipulation language
consists of the sql commands that deals
with the manipulation of data present in
the database
insert into command is used to insert
data into a table update is used to
update existing data within a table
delete is used to delete records from a
database table select this command helps
you to select the attribute based on the
condition described by the workflows
tclo transaction control language these
commands deals with the transaction
within the database commit commands
commit a transaction
rollback command rollbacks a transaction
in case of any error occurs save point
it sets a save point within a
transaction set transaction it specifies
characteristics for the transaction
dcl or data control language it consists
of the commands such as grant and revoke
which mainly deals with the rights
permissions and other controls of the
database system
grant command gives user access
privileges to database
revoke it withdraw user success
privileges given by using the grant
command now we will have hands on some
basic queries in my sql work match now
we will see some basic queries executing
in my sql workbench
so we'll start
and first query will run will be use
sys
that is the database
this command is used to select the
database
in which we want to create or manipulate
any data
now we'll see another command that would
create a table
now we will add attributes to the
customer table that would be the columns
first will be the customer id
and we will
act at
it as a primary key
the next attribute we would add would be
customer name customer underscore name
and its data type would be vector
next attribute
would be h
within data type
next attribute would be gender
with character data type
next we will add as date of purchase
we date data type
now we'll add another attribute that
would be addressed
with data type where care
next we would write
the attribute item
that would be the item purchased with
data type where care
next would be the price
okay for price we will make it as float
and
let's shift this to next line and now
we'll execute this command
yeah you can see that the table is
created
now we have to insert values into it
for that
we'll write a command insert
into
customers
values
and
i have all the reports written in the
notepad
so i will copy these
and paste it here
these are 20 records
like all the attributes they are in the
order
so we have written
all the records in the order only
like customer id that would be 101
customer name that would be joseph
age that would be 22 gender may date of
purchase this is the date of purchase
address pune
item that is vegetable purchased price
that is 80.
so now we will run this command
and all these
records they would be inserted into the
table
and these are 20 commands
20 reports
you can see insert into customer values
the command has been executed and they
have been inserted into the table
now we'll see
the table
for that we'll write the command select
star
from
customers
here you can see the table
in the output grid
okay i will make sure you will see the
whole table
with all the 20 codes
yeah
you can see
all the 20 reports they have been
inserted
now you see
another command
and for that we would just
get the output as customer id and
customer name in the output grid for
that
we'll write the command select
customer id
comma
customer name
from
customers
semicolon
and we'll run this command
and we will get both the columns
customer id and customer name
in our output grid
now let's see another command that would
be draw
the drop command just removes the
component from the database
so we'll write
drop
table
and table name that would be customers
and semicolon
and we will execute this command
now the table has been removed from the
database
to verify whether the table has been
removed from the database or not we will
run a command select
star from
customers semicolon and execute this
command
and what we will get is select start
from customers error code table says
customers doesn't exist the table has
been removed from the database so the
drop command worked here
now we don't have any table that is the
customer table has been dropped from the
database so we have to create that table
again
so we'll go at the top
okay
yeah
and we'll create the table again
and we'll insert all the reports again
into the table
both the commands have run
now we will
run this command to see whether the
table has been created and the reports
have been inserted into the table or not
both commands have worked
now we'll see another command
that would be truncate
the truncate command just manages all
the records from the table
truncate
table
table name
semicolon
and just run this command
the command has been executed
now we'll see
yeah you can see that all the records
from the table has been vanished so the
truncate command worked here
now to carry other operations we have to
insert all the reports again into the
table
we'll do that
we'll again go upwards
and run this command
insert into customers values
and all the records
and will execute this command and that
command has been executed and all the
records
are again in the table so run this
command and check it
yeah you can see all the reports then
set it into the table
now let's see another command that would
be alter
alter command is used to update any
recovered into the table you will see
folder
table
table name that is customers
and now what we should do
uh okay we'll drop the column h
from the table
so we'll write command drop
column
h
semicolon
i'll run this command
the command has been executed
and now we'll check whether the each
column has been dropped or not
select star
from customers
semicolon
and we will execute this command
yeah you can see
the age column has been dropped off the
table
so the alter command has been executed
successfully
okay so now we'll see another thing uh
like if you want to comment something
during the execution you can do that
just write two minus signs
and the text
this would be the comment
and you can also use
slash
star and that
text
inside it and star and slash
so this is also the comment section
you can write comment
with this syntax or with the syntax they
both work
now we'll see another command that would
be update
this is also used to manipulate data in
the table to update any record into the
table
so we will write
update
table name that would be customers
and what we should update okay we will
update our record
uh we will change the customer name
and address
and we have the primary key as customer
id so we'll use that
so update customers
set
customer name
equal to
james
coma
and address
equal to
boston
where
customer id
equal to
one zero one
okay
you can see here in the table one zero
one
customer id the customer name is joseph
and the address is pony
we have updated command and we will
execute it let's see okay okay
we have an error here
oh yeah that's correct we will execute
this command
here the command has been executed
successfully and now we check the table
with the command select star
from customs
semicolon
you can see the row has been updated
the customer name is james here and the
address is boston so the command has
been executed successfully
now we'll see another command that would
be delete
so delete command is used to delete any
particular record for any particular row
so we'll write the command delete
from
customers
where
customer id
equal to one zero two
semicolon
so the second row that is with customer
id one zero two that would be deleted
and we will execute this command
now we check into the table
yeah you can see
the record has been deleted
now we'll see distinct command
that is used to return different values
so we will write command select
distinct
and the column name for which we want
different values
to be in the output grid
we select address
from
customers
and we will execute this command
yeah
these are the address these are the
cities in the address
which are different and which are unique
and we have get that through the
distinct command
now we will see minimum command minimum
command is used to get the records
or get the data that is minimum of all
the data
so
for that we will write the syntax
select
minimum
like min
in bracket we will write the attribute
name or the column name
for which we want the data to be minimum
as
less price
this would be the attribute name
from customers
so we will execute this command
and what we would see is
that 60 would be the last price
like the customer table they have the
column price and in that we all we have
all the prices and from that
the minimum price is 60 and we have get
it at less price
similarly we have the maximum command to
get the maximum amount from the column
we will use the maximum command
select
max
in bracket we will write the attribute
name
as
max price
from customers
and we will execute this command and
what we get is 3400 is the maximum price
from the price column
now we'll see another command that would
be count
count command it returns the number of
rows according to the query so we'll run
the query and see like how it works
we'll write select
count
and the attribute name
that would be
a customer id
customer id
from customers
semicolon
and when we'll run this command we will
get 19 as a result that is it counted
the number of customer ids that is 19 in
the table
now let's see another command
that would be average so it just gets
the average of the numbers
and how we do it
let the query
select
avg
and the attribute name for which you
want the average
from
table name
semicolon
and we'll execute this command and we'll
get the average of the price
from the customers table
now if you want
to add up all the prices from the
customer table
you can use the command
sum
so how will execute that command
select sum
in bracket we will write the attribute
name that would be price
from
customers semicolon
and we'll run this command
and we'll get the sum of the prices from
the customer table
now we'll see where command
where command is used to filter records
uh let's see through syntax
so we will write select
star
from customers
where
address
uh yeah we will
where address equal to
pune
[Music]
semicolon
and then we will run this command
and
yeah this is the table we will get
telecodes with addresses
so this is the functioning of wear
command now we'll see group by command
that is used to
just group the number of rows that have
the same values
we will see it through the syntax
like we will write
select
count
attribute name that would be customer id
comma
address
from
table name
and group by
accordingly with
address
here the comma will not come
yeah this is the command
select count customer id
comma address from customers group by
address when we will execute this
command yeah we will get this table
that would be these are the different
addresses and these are the number of
times
the number of persons who live in this
address with the count with respect to
customer ids
now let's see having close with the help
of an example only
select
count attribute name that would be
customer id
comma
address
from
table name that would be customers
group by
address
having
account
customer id
greater than
unit 3 4 3 2
3
semicolon and then we will execute this
command
and you can see
the output we have got through this
command that is group by command
was this
and when we have added having close
having count customer id greater than
three
we just got the customer id count with
four
now we'll see another command
that is order by
select star from table name that is
customers and we will order this output
by address
semicolon
we have got the output with respect to
the address
the address has been assigned
alphabetically here
in this particular project we'll be
having a basic angular setup ready so
you know it very well to develop an
angular application we have used a
similar technique called
downloading the angular cli version and
we have used ngnu and the name of the
project is project and this particular
project does nothing has only one single
component name called app as you can see
it right now here
under the src you have a got app folder
appcomponent.html
and here you see app component.ts
so that is one of the very very basic
component angular can hold in
so
this edge table contains a very simple
message called welcome and component.ts
contains nothing special it is just
holding one title
and
app.module.ts if you see it contains
nothing special whatever it comes as a
predefined preloaded it contains only
those particular type of modules
and in my
app.module.ts sorry
yeah if you talk about call package.json
inside my package.json we have some
additional dependency added
which i will tell you like what
dependencies are part of angular which
comes as a pre-loaded are by default
available
now you can see here
animation compiler core forms localized
these are all by default are there a
part of that we have also taken
this bootstrap as an additional
dependency so we talk about call ng
bootstrap
okay which is the additional dependency
we have taken bootstrap jquery oper.js
rxjs which anyways comes by default and
here
these dependencies will be playing
additional role during your development
time
okay rest everything gonna be remain
same as it is but yes these additional
dependencies like in jquery poker and
your save
lib and you talk about like in bootstrap
okay jquery these libraries are
additional to those the one which comes
as a by default
okay so once you have those additional
dependencies added into your project do
not forget that in your angular.json
you need to have
additional declarations to be get added
okay as you can see now under the
scripts part
okay under the styles part you see the
under the styles we have kept our
bootstrap.min.css
and under the scripts we have kept all
those necessary
dependencies with regards to our js
called demo
chart pie chart by demo you talk about
bootstrap you talk about jquery so these
are the additional dependencies we have
kept under the scripts part which is
here under your wrangler.json
okay and under the styles we have got
bootstrap through which we can directly
include these bootstrap related stuff
directly into my project
so that would be
the first thing which will start with
okay so
if i want to start my application i will
certainly say npm space start let me say
npm space
start
if it is launching my application
okay please use sudo
now it is launching
and under the port number 4200 my
application will be starting up now it
is saying port maybe this application is
ready somewhere
so
let me check if it is available
okay so application is already running
so inside my 4200 if i try to run i can
see this by default message welcome
appears so that's the only thing with
regards to your project so nothing fancy
it is just a basic stuff your
application have some basic set of
dependencies added and along with this
uh you have some
new dependencies and you just you say
npm space start and under the localhost
4200 your project will get ready okay so
in my previous example you remember like
we have created and
done with our basic setup and now it's
time for us to go back and create some
new component into my project
now what are the first component i'm
looking forward for that is called
navbar for creating a navigation so
inside this first of all i want to open
the new one
okay so i want to say ng space g space c
space
nav bar
so let the new component get ready okay
so we have about never component ready
with me
so this is what my navbar is and inside
this nav bar i want to add some
additional dependencies inside my html
okay
so here
i may have lot of tags associated with
me
but here i want to start with my body
tag
okay so this is what i want to start
with my body tag
okay and here onwards we want to start
all my development so within my body tag
i will be writing a lot of other tags
too but first of all let me try to have
some additional dependencies to get
added here
so i want to add the div
and here
i would like to have some additional
dependencies to be get added as you can
see right now it is for jquery it is for
your bootstrap it is such scripts
okay this is for
charts this is for chart areas data
tables so these dependencies are very
much required in order to start your
basic development
okay and i want to continue
developing this example by adding some
new logic one by one
okay now what logic i want to add it now
so i will be using bootstrap as a basic
code
okay so first of all i want to use the
body with some body
class equal to i want to give this name
called sb hyphen
nav
hyphen fixed
that is actually the bootstrap class
which we're associating with here
and here after that
we'll be starting with my div tag
so after body
here see this is the sb hyphen nav
hyphen fix which we have used now i'll
be using some
nav tag now
and inside my nav tag i want to say
class
equal to
sb hyphen
uh top nav
space
nav bar
space
nava hyphen
expand
okay space nav bar
hyphen we want to use the dark theme so
i'll be using navbar hyphen dark and
space bg
hyphen
dark
so this is the first thing we are using
it now now inside my nav
okay we want to use few more important
details like i'm saying like anchor
okay so with this anchor i want to say
a
before hdf we want to say class
equal to navbar
never hyphen brand
okay space nav bar
or else we can say href
we can use this
just add this single quotation and just
say h ref hr is equal to
index dot
html to go back
and after this will be also using
this img tag also so we just use this
img
src will be using some logo
okay which will be there under the
assets
okay under the assets i'll be having
logo dot
png
okay and we would like to also
uh say some controlling this
some width and height so we just use
width equal to what 80 percent
okay and we want to use
height
equal to 120 percent
so where's 80 percent height 120 percent
alt
is maybe something optional you want to
give it i just want to leave it now we
do not want to give art as an
alternative
and if you also want to give style
so i say style
equal to now i say padding
hyphen top
colon
here i say
10
pixels
okay that's it
so that's where exactly the main logic
is let me try to bring this back
okay and here the anchor tag is closed
after this i'll be using my
button diagonal
with this button we want to add some
class
class equal to btn
space btn
iphone
link
followed by btn
hyphen sm because i want to have a small
size button and i want to say order
iphone one
space
order
iphone
lg
hyphen 0
okay
followed by id
equal to
sidebar toggle
what i'm saying sidebar toggle and after
that some more new properties like an
href i do not want to go anywhere so i'm
just saying
hrf equal to what
hash in the single quotes
like this
okay and that's it
so within this button
i would like to offer
some i class so here i say i class
i
class equal to
uh
okay fas fa hyphen bars
okay this is a special class available
and
that's it
which is there
now here the i class is getting close
and here the button is getting close now
okay so this is the first part of my
code now
okay now we talk about call navigation
or nav bar search so here i'm starting
with my
never
search
okay so inside my navbar search we would
like to offer
some more new number of fields so called
form
okay so i start with my form
now with this form
i
may not say action for a time being so
i'm just removing this action from this
instead we are saying form class
equal to
d
d hyphen
none
space md
hyphen
inline
okay hyphen block
hyphen
block
okay so md hyphen inline iphone block
after that you have to suggest form
hyphen
and here you see inline because i want
to go ahead with the inline form
and also ml
hyphen auto
space mr hyphen 0
space mr iphone md
hyphen
3
my iphone
2
space my iphone md
hyphen 0
so this is what all about our form but
within this form is not a closed it is
just a first portion of the form plus
along with this will be also offering
the dip class so we just use
them
here i say
class equal to
input hyphen
group
input hyphen group
and
now inside this input action group i
want to use input plus
input type equal to text
and here i say class
input
class equal to
form
hyphen
control
solve hyphen control we would like to
add few more classes here first it is
form control type equal to what type it
is a type text and now we say
placeholder equal to
search
for
okay this is the property for me where i
want to use it
and
a part of that
search for we're giving it so since it
is giving so we do not need to give
double quotes
search for us single quotes is okay now
and now
area
hyphen
so the first property i'm trying to use
it a part of this area search we say
area
hyphen
okay
described by and here we give the value
called basic iphone
hyphen
add-on to
okay so this is how we are trying to add
it now
after this what next
after this we would like to use another
div tag now
div
and here we say
class
equal to
inside this class we may offer few more
details
uh
okay like i can see input group
input iphone
hyphen group
iphone
append
okay that is a div class and inside this
dip class
i would like to use also another button
here we say
class equal to
vtn space vtn hyphen
primary okay type equal to what it is a
button
so
that's it
and after that within this button i
would like to use
i
class
equal to
fs space fa hyphen
search
okay that's it so this is how we are
making it
first and now we'll be going ahead with
the next level okay so let's get started
with the next point now so we have
finished our div and dip form now let me
try to organize it properly
okay
now the div div and this part is getting
close and now we would like to talk
about our navbar part
okay so here
i'm starting with the nav point so here
excellent battery
and i here i give the name called navbar
just to tell you like this would be the
navbar related
uh stuff
here i'll start with my url tag now
so inside my ul i say you will space
class equal to
navbar
okay so we have a call navbar hyphen
nav
okay space ml
hyphen
auto
space ml hyphen
md
iphone 0
so that is for my ul so within this ul
i'll be having
some li class also so we have got li
within this li i am saying
class
equal to
now what are the details i want i say
nav hyphen
item
[Music]
okay nav hyphen i item space
drop down
okay so now hyphen item space what a
drop down log
now within this
li tag okay i want to use lot of other
tags too
so first tag i'm using this for anchor
tag
okay
so
in this anchor tag we want to say a
and followed by
class equal to
well i'm saying nav hyphen
link
followed by drop down
hyphen toggle
after this space id
equal to
user
drop down
okay add equal to what user drop down
href
equal to we just make it as just a hash
because we're not taking anywhere
after this hash we say roll
equal to
button so role will be a button type
and the job doesn't get over here we
also have some option called
data hyphen
toggle
okay data hyphen toggle equal to drop
down
equal to drop down
space we also want to use some area
has popup
okay you can see there's a property
called idiot has pop-up so i just said
true
yes exactly it does have
and we also want to say area hyphen
you see now area hyphen expanded we're
also saying
false
a part of that
we also want to use some image within
this
so
image
so
in this image we want to say src
src will be entered
okay
assets under the assets it will be under
id
dot
png this is already sorry jvg
there's already one value available
inside this id png alt we don't want it
as of now
if you want you can add it otherwise i'm
just leaving it blank i'm just using
this option called style equal to now
border hyphen
border
hyphen radius
okay this hyphen border it is how much
you want to give i'm saying 50
that is a css style
okay and followed by width
how much weight you're giving it i'm
saying 50 pixels
50
pixels
okay
that's the whole idea for this
now the anchor tag is getting closed
okay so here the anchor tag is closed
after the acne tag is closed we would
like to give another tip class now for
the drop down
so we say
this div class will have some of the set
of properties which is available i say
div
class equal to
drop
[Music]
down okay iphone menu
and
followed by
iphone
menu
hyphen
right
okay
and
followed by we want to use area
area
hyphen
you can see this option called label by
okay equal to give the option name
called user
drop down i'm just giving the value user
drop down
value has been given now within this div
tag itself will be adding some new more
values
what those values will be i'm saying
anchor tag
class equal to
now that is an anchor tag
class equal to drop down
drop down hyphen item
okay space
href
equal to
hash
href equal to what hash
we're giving the value call what
settings
okay now i just copy this line
okay and
let's have only two for a time being so
drop down hyphen item hdf settings and
we give you one more option that's
called activity log
activity
log
that's the value
for activity log
okay anchor tag is getting close now
here after that we use another tab tag
here
it's called nested tip tag
okay so in this div tag we want to use
class
equal to drop down hyphen item
drop down hyphen
item
and
i would say better drop an iphone
divider
drop down hyphen
divided as a value and
in the same div tag
this div tag is getting closed here and
we're using one more
okay
and class
equal to drop down hyphen item
dropdown item item hrx equal to
give the value the one which you want to
give it i'm saying hash
okay
it's difficult to what hash
let me close this
yeah hdf equal to hash and
we just use router link
equal to as you know it variable uh in
typical navigation we always use the
router link rather than normal href and
here we're giving the name call what
login
okay and here we can use
router link active equal to
active
okay
and here we get the name called
logout
log
[Music]
out
okay so that's the value which we are
giving it now anchor tag is closed and
here the div tag is closed li ul and nav
so let me organize it
this one
this one
this one
and lab tag
let me format this
okay so that's what my file is
okay so let's continue to this so we
have created the value till now and we
want to start with this div diagonal
now with this dev tag
we would like to have few more classes
added now
we say
div id equal to
you can just give the name called layout
site info
layout
sign name
so this is the first value we are taking
it now
with this layout side now
a part of this would like to use another
div tag now
and inside this
div we would like to offer the id
equal to
layout
site nav
whatever name we have used it underscore
now
that is a
second div type we have it now
now within this we want to use the nav
okay with this snap we want to say plus
equal to
sb hyphen sidenav
sidenav
hyphen
menu
so that value we are passing it to this
okay that is for
sb hyphen sidenav view
or along with this rather than menu i
can have another option with me to make
it even more better sb hyphen site name
space
accordion
sorry
accordion
okay
so
according we're going to give you the
kind of flipping type of moment one
after another sp hyphen
side now
sb apple sidenav hyphen
dark
and space id equal to
side neverword
side
nav
accordion
so this value we are using it now with
this nav
so within this snap
we would like to bring another div class
now
by saying live
and inside this div we will say class
equal to
uh i would say sp
hyphen side nav
hyphen
menu
okay
now within this div tag we want to use
another dev diagram
so you might be thinking so many tips i
guess that is why we want to make it
more organized we said dev
class
equal to
nav
okay now within this div tag we would
like to use another dive
here we want to say sp hyphen
sp iphone site name
hyphen menu
hyphen heading
site name iphone menu hyphen heading
okay and in this we is giving the value
called
code this is the value
of this
okay so this is what for the first dip
tag
now within this div tag
when this step tag is closed we want to
use the anchor tag now
a
class equal to
nav hyphen
link
okay nav hyphen link followed by
hdf equal to give the name called
index dot
html
so this is your href one second
hdf equal to index.html
now now within this anchor tag we want
to use the div tag now
okay and in this div we would like to
say class
equal to
uh sp
hyphen
nav hyphen link
hyphen icon
so div class equal to sp hyphen nav
hyphen link hyphen icon so this is a
class of my tip tag right now
okay
now
this particular
class inside this we want to use
the
i class i'm saying i
plus equal to fs
space fa
hyphen
tachometer
tachometer hyphen alt
okay
and we are closing this i tag is getting
close the tip tag is getting close
okay and within this i'm giving the
value call what
okay
so a class equal to
giving this call
nav link and hsf equal to index dot
html and here we have the div tag which
is
getting close now and here the anchor
tag is closed
and after the anchor tag is closed we
can use few more div tags inside this
okay let's see about which of the div
tags are now left with here we start
another div tag
now inside this div we say
class equal to
sb
hyphen
sign nav
okay let's be hyphen site name iphone
menu
hyphen heading
hyphen heading and now we want to use
one tool name called interface
so here we have a called div diagonal
after this we would like to use another
anchor tag
okay and now with this anchor tag we
want to say class
equal to
now
um as we know it very well we have given
this call menu heading so we get nav
link collapse so we say nav
hyphen link
space
collapse
okay so that is a
class which we are using it now with my
anchor tag
okay collapsed after that we are saying
href
equal to hash
okay h f equal to what hash and
data hyphen
toggle
equal to
collapse
so that's the value we are giving it to
my data toggle now
after that we're giving some more values
here
one value we are giving is called data
target
yeah data target equal to
here we're giving this id
by saying collapse layout
collapse
okay there is a daily target and we just
want to say area
hyphen expanded
area hyphen expanded equal to false
and one more property i want to give it
is called area hyphen controls
area
hyphen
controls
okay
equal to collapse layout
collapse layouts
one second let me try to add it here
and edit it here
collapse layouts
okay so anchor tag is there so within my
anchor tag where it is getting closed i
just want to give
one more dev tag inside this
yeah so here we have got
okay so within this div tag
we want to give some additional property
to this div
so
we know it very well what type of data
is we are talking about so we set if
class
equal to
sp
hyphen nav link
usb hyphen
nav link
okay hyphen icon
there is another class we're using it
now and uh
sorry
sv hyphen nav hyphen link
that the first property we have taken
let me close this
and uh
okay so sb hyphen nav hyphen link
and
a part of this you can just use hyphen
icon
iphone
icon
okay within this
uh i can use
i class
so here i'm using i
class equal
to so which class you want to use i am
saying fs
space fa ifm
angle
okay
hyphen dom
so this is your i class which we are
defining it right now
okay closing this the i tag is getting
closed along with the div tag now
okay and anchor tag is anyways getting
closed
okay anchor tag is getting close here so
inside this we would like to give with
the div tag is getting close we want to
get home
any value which you want to give so
we're giving what over here
and this is where it's getting
close right now
okay
so after the div tag is getting closed
we're using this
and
[Music]
so later on we can go back and try to
implement more ideas okay so we have
finished in one point of
areas now we would like to go back and
start working with the row level now
so now here with my application we want
to use
the another div tag now
so within this div tag we want to use
some classes we said
space
class equal to
row
okay after this i use one more div tag
and in this div tag we want to use one
more property here called
[Music]
class equal to call
hyphen excel
hyphen six
so six columns layout we are trying to
add it now here we are trying to say div
and with this div we say class
equal to
now see the properties now do class
equal to we're using card
space
mb hyphen 4
card space mb hyphen 4 we're using this
property
now after that we would like to use
another div tag
with using div
plus equal to
header
i would rather say card hyphen header i
will say
card hyphen header so this div class
and inside this we want to say i
i
class equal to
some addition
declaration i'm saying fs space
fa hyphen
chart
hyphen
area
space mr hyphen 1
so
closing this so i tag is getting closed
here we're going to give the value name
called weekly analysis
weekly
weekly analysis okay so with this div
tag it is getting closed i want to bring
another tip tag inside this
now with this div tag
we want to write another class here
that is known as call class equal to
card hyphen body
so we want to give class equal to card
hyphen
class equal to
card hyphen
body
okay
and
this classical card acts in body we want
to bring
another thing inside this that is called
img
equal to now here
from the assets we want to use
area
chart
area chart dot
png so that location we want to use it
now followed by
width equal to 100
okay
and
height
equal to 280
okay and here the tip tag is getting
closed
okay
so we're talking about this dev tag and
there's another tip tag is getting close
below this the third div tag is also
getting close now
okay so we totally have three div tag is
getting close and we would like to use
another tip diagonal
we want to set them
class equal to once again
call hyphen
xs
excel
hyphen six
so six columns layout you're talking
about
and after that we say div class
div class
equal to card
space mb iphone 4
okay dev classical card space mb hyphen
4 and again we use another div tag
okay and inside this div we say class
equal to
header
name class equal to what
header rather i would say card hyphen
header
card hyphen header now
now within this dev tag we want to use
another i class
yeah so within this card hyphen header
we want to use the
another chart so as we've already seen
we have used this uh
assets
hyphen chart area.chat png in a similar
way we would like to use the same
technique now for the monthly report
also
okay
so
we have a call called sn6 card mp4
okay we are using what card header so
in this
the way we have used weekly analysis
i just copy this the same
okay and i pasted it here
okay and here what i try to offer
not weekly analysis i would rather offer
monthly report
okay monthly report and after the div
title is close card body
and now we talk about call bar chart.png
bar
chart dot png width equal to 100
div div tag is getting closed here
so this is how we're trying to use it
now
so just like that we can keep on using
some another properties too now
here
we want to use one more div
okay in this div tag
we feel class
equal to
now let's provide another property here
so we said deb class equal to card
okay space mb
iphone
4
and other details too
we were on this position called card
hyphen mv hyphen force
and followed to this we want to use
another div tag
by saying div class equal to card hyphen
header div
class equal to
card hyphen
header
so that is another div class we are
using it now so inside this div class we
want to use another i
i
class
equal to here i'm using once again fas
space fa
hyphen
table
space
mr
hyphen one
okay that's the position we are using it
right now
okay
and after this i tag here we define this
option name called employee data
employee data
so here the div tag is getting closed
okay so
now our three properties we have taken
it now weekly monthly report
employee data now we would like to
create a table now
so whatever you are looking forward for
let's start we are saying div
class equal to
card hyphen
body
okay now within this div class equal to
called hyphen body we're using another
tab tag here now
okay and inside this dev tag we'll say
class equal to
table hyphen
responsive so we want to use table
hyphen responsive
fine now after this we want to create a
table
okay within this table
okay we would like to create table
headed multiple things but let me add
some classes here i'm saying table
class equal to we want to use table
[Music]
space
table hyphen border
[Music]
border and after that we use id equal to
just give the name called data table
after this data table we say width
equal to 100
hundred percent and also we want to use
cell spacing
cell
spacing
so some spacing we are giving equal to
zero
that is for my table and now inside this
table i can have
table head
okay under the table head i will be
using tr
so tr under which should be having
ph which is called table heading
so we're giving the first property
yeah so here i give name
like this i just copy this
and take few more property
name position
here we give call office
then age
then we keep started
and one more
and that is on salary
so these are part of table heading
tr is closed the head is closed now we
would like to use t body
we would like to use keyboard you know
inside the t body we want to use tr
which is your table row under this we
want to use what
td that is called a table data so here
we can give the name
so the first value we are giving is
called tiger
nexon let me copy
and paste it
so that is the first value second is
nonstop position so we are saying
system architect
okay system architect that is what my
table data
next we're looking forward for office
we give the office name called edinburgh
next
it is asking for
your age let's give the age call
61.
next is asking for the start date so we
just give
slash 04
slash 25 and yet we can give it
last which is asking for the salary and
just say
dollar
any random value i've given it more
okay so this is the first stable row is
basically closed
like that we can have multiple records
with me
i copy this
and have another
and have another
so as my number of records you want you
can basically have it now
okay let me quickly change the name
this value called content
next value which we have it is called
tokyo
age
63
okay same
and here we can give
okay
and here you can change the values later
on if you want but for the display
purpose
it's okay
okay so here
the
multiple things are getting closed your
tea body is getting closed
your table is getting closed
your div tag is getting close your div
tag is getting closed and
after this we have got one more
that is the other okay after closing the
last dip tag we would like to also close
the main
okay after this main
uh we would like to start working with
this photo part now
in this footer
uh we would like to add some new classes
here i'm saying class equal to
py
iphone 4
space vg hyphen
light is space empty hyphen
auto
okay
followed by we can use the another div
tag
and inside this div we can use
class
equal to
container hyphen fluid
container hyphen fluid
now there's another div
tag
okay inside this div we want to use what
class
equal to
d hyphen flex
okay space
align
hyphen
items hyphen
center space
justify
hyphen content
hyphen between
space
small
okay now inside this div we would like
to use another div
we set the
class
equal to text mounted
text
hyphen
muted
okay and we would like to
offer
here that's called copyright
copyright
okay and
copy
okay
space
give the name
dot
simply here or else
like this
okay so div tag is getting closed here
now after that you can use
hlf
equal to you can just give hash
okay and now you can give the value call
what privacy policy
privacy policy
okay and here in privacy sequence you
can just give
ampersand
okay
and
okay
and after this again href
so after this
we can use but first anchor tag is
getting closed here after this privacy
policy
okay so
now other hrefs here hash
rather than privacy policy i'm gonna
give terms
okay in terms
give space
okay
conditions
okay terms and conditions
you don't need this now
and that's it so dave dave
photo is also getting closed dev tag is
also getting closed
so
photo
also and
there's another div tag is getting
closed and after that
another day will be included
okay
and that's it body will be closed post
that okay so there are a lot of space
let me try to remove
that's it so now let me format it
so guys our navbar component is ready
and after that we go back and try to add
few more things into my code now we're
going to create a few more components
into my code so first component a part
of this
what we have seen i'm going to create
one more component name called toggle so
ng space g space c
space
toggle
okay a part of that we want to create
few more components here there is one
routes
so ng space g space c space
routes
okay
so this component is ready along with
this
as we know it very well
like there are certain components which
we have created we also would like to
create few more components into my
application
okay by saying
ng
space g space c
space uh
[Music]
let's see
so under the routes we have got what
charts is another component which we
have seen now
okay now in a similar way i would like
to create one more components under the
routes and that is one for login
component is ready along with this login
we would like to create a register
and
along with this we would like to also go
back and create one more component here
that is called
password
so charts log in register password
so four components are ready now and
they're all inside what they're all
inside under the roots
okay so these all components are now
ready with me and we'll be basically
making all those components
associated inside my routes part
clear now so which component used what
that we have to basically consider it
now
so since they're all of the components
now
so under my
app.routing.module.ts we have to
basically provide a routings here now so
here we know calls for routes equal to
blank so let me try to say
path
okay path colon
if nothing has been given so the by
default component will be what
component
will be
nav bar
component
so this network components automatically
comes up here
after that
if
path is of what
is static
component
is what
toggle component
okay and here we are saying
path match
colon
full
okay
along with this we're giving one more
path
colon login
so here
component
colon
login component
i'm going to put comma
concurrency small
okay now like this next we talk about
call path
colon
register
okay and here
component colon
register component
now let's talk about what path colon
what
change
password
so here we say
component
comma
component colon
which command we are trying to say
password component
next
we want to say path
colon
charts
then
[Music]
component volume
charge component so these are the
components are now available to me so
these components are now all set and
later on we'll be combining all the
files together
in my system one by one
okay everybody so our all components are
now all ready so you see like we have
got navbar
which contains all the necessary tags
whichever is required for my application
here we have a basically the login and
this login.component.html
actually contains all the relative part
which is
related to your login like you can talk
about call
email you talk about your password you
have a call remember me and forgot
password these type of details are
available inside your
logincomponent.html now so this is
basically the code okay which contains
your login related stuffs now
so it contains only few properties like
you talk about like email address
it contains what a password and only the
buttons through which user can
login through
followed by when i see my
password so this
password
file that is called
password.component.html
it contains
the details regarding to your password
so that the user can
give the password details or in case of
the user has
or want to change the password so we can
give the details like okay you can enter
your email id
address where i can send the password to
you so here
we have this email address we haven't
implemented
your
i would say any kind of
sending the email to your
registered email id that logic hasn't
been implemented but it's just for the
demo like how exactly you can bring this
password
uh forgot condition inside your system
now so this is what the password and
here we have a link for the login and
here we have a registration
followed by if you think about call
register register contains that
register.component.html and here if you
see there are a few details which i'm
expecting from the user like in first
name last name email password confirm
password so these are the quick fields
which i'm expecting from the user to
enter
and here it's a button for
you know
confirming a password and this is what
exactly the links which are available
for the login
okay and for the login.html file so this
is a simple registration form which is
available to me
and that is last which is available for
me for that for me that is called
toggling part
in toggle part we are just offering
the details with regards to your how in
case if you want to toggle you can
change the settings okay based on
between the settings and activity
okay so these are the links which are
available through which you can change
all different type of toggling part
whether you would like to enable or not
enable
this is something which is related to
your page in case if you click on that
link so 401 page 404 page 500 page which
will be available to us
now let's try to run the code and check
how the final application really looks
like in
okay so now i'm trying to run my
application
by
same
npm space start once again
okay
okay
and now i'm trying to say
in game space start
let the project start now
and we'll see how it really looks like
it
so it is compiling all the files
okay and finally let's try to execute
localhost 4200
let me see what is an issue right now
okay let me check meanwhile try to run
it run it again
okay now i finally uh i'm into my
current project right now so
it was the wrong location where the
project was available so i just like to
say npm space start and let the project
run
so project is picking up till the time i
say localhost four to double zero
and beautiful guys this is how exactly
projects really looks like it
isn't is an amazing right now
see how beautiful your project really
looks like
this is what exactly the dashboard you
have it and this is the nav bar which is
available to you
getting it now see how better and
beautiful it looks and organize so this
is like in real time dashboard which is
available you can see the bird days you
have it
you talk about
you know company announcement
quick links these are all basically
available these are the charts which you
can see can give some dummy values and
these are charts will be really
available to you
so this is how the employee records
which we had it which we are displaying
it right now and this is how exactly the
chat looks like it
so weekly analysis and monthly analysis
this is a dashboard and here the links
are there but they're all dummy links we
haven't made it but you can certainly
make it further
okay you can search for
anything but it is not working right now
because it is just for the display
because nothing more than that
it is a home which you can see written
like in profile
this is like the profile which we have
created
by default the name is called kate adams
uh and this is designation like an
account it
and like you can talk about like
home under the home you have a profile
we have called settings
so nothing is the research in the
settings so it is just a static record
attendance
it will be bringing you back to the same
page we have a call confirmation
travel expenses these are basically the
dummy links which are available we
haven't made it
which you can
see new development
okay part of that you see like profile
we have it settings
account activity if you see we have
called login and register these three
page if you remember we have created it
under this system
so you can see we have a got login we
have a call register we have a call
password
these are you are able to see this now
when you say change password you see
like
how they have given to you they're not
actually working but they're just like
in dummy option and you can see it will
be taking you directly to the signup
option
okay now here
in your
settings once again you can look forward
for the login
it works like in
a typical model how it comes
apart of that we also have this
call register
so these are the fields of registration
form
and
you see about activity activity we have
because these pages are available there
are basically dummy pages which we have
created download confirmation so really
it this project really gives you the
kind of sense of in a real time how
your
application angular application can
really
make your
ui more attractive which are more
competitive in market so i hope you guys
love this project so we have developed
most of the codes by our own
except few
which we have taken it from uh
online that is nothing but call uh
especially those images as well as
uh what to say some javascript related
libraries if you see which we are using
it right now here you think about think
about this uh
your
navbar.com.html if you see like these
are the libraries we have taken it from
internet
because certainly we don't type it
because it is taking long time to type
certainly we have taken from
internet and some images also we have
taken it from the internet which are
there under the assets folder too
so if you see under the assets we have a
lot of images like an area chart bar
chart chart so this we have downloaded
from the internet in this we are going
to talk about the maven here
now we will be talking about that how
exactly we can uh make use of maven here
in performing various kind of operations
whether it's a build compilation various
kind of stuff there so let's talk about
it why exactly we use maven here
now me1 is something which uh is a kind
of a build tool which is there for most
of the job-based projects here so this
tool also helps us in building up the
source code by downloading some couple
of dependencies these dependencies are
something which is being configured by
the developers which a developer feels
that uh the project is dependent on and
he requires those dependencies to be
downloaded so uh this tool is
specifically used to build and manage
any kind of a job-based project whatever
the complexity of the topic or the
project is there so this tool will be
able to handle that particular
requirement or that project so it
simplifies the uh day-to-day work of a
java developer and helps them in their
projects for performing daily to daily
activities
right now meven also helps us in getting
the specific jar files for each and
every project so if you are going you
can pretty much make a jar file bar file
or er file any kind of a package
mechanism you can follow for your maven
there so to download the dependencies we
don't have to actually go to the
official website of each and every
software you can easily get it uh the
dependencies of each and every third
party binaries on the mvnrepository.com
this is a website which is present on
which if you visit you will be able to
download the dependencies which is
required by your project or by your
specific
project over here so it totally depends
on how exactly you want to download and
you want to get together a specific
repository over here so
mvnrepository.com is the one if you
visit you will be able to download and
go through all the jar files dependent
jar files as independences which you
require for your current project
right so now what exactly is a maven all
about so let's see on that part
so maven is a popular open source build
tool which is uh developed by the apache
group and the primary uh ownership of
this tool is to build publish and deploy
several projects at once maven is
written in java and it can be used to
build projects written in c shaft scala
ruby etc so apart from java these are
the different programming languages or
the tools which is supported by the
maven here for performing the build
activity so the tool is used for build
and management of any kind of a
job-based project it simplifies the
day-to-day work of a java developer and
helps them to automate most of the
compilation or build
perspective tasks on the projects
right now maven is a kind of a bomb
based project so it also known as an
project object model and it focuses on
of simplification and standardization of
the building process in the process it
take cares of all the followings here
bills dependencies reports
distribution releases mailing list so
all these things are being taken care as
in this particular process here and
ultimately it's an availability inside
the maven that how the overall build
process needs to be automated and
standardized here so all these
particular mechanisms is can be followed
as such over here so that we can have a
good
standards and the simplifications
implemented as such here now what
exactly is a maven repository all about
so maven repository is a something which
is a
kind of a directory or it's kind of a
location where we have all the jar files
packaged all together in a single
location so depending on the software
which you want to download the dependent
java files can be downloaded from there
so the metadata refers to the palm files
relevant to each project here this
metadata is what allows maven to
download the dependencies now there are
three type of repositories from where we
can download the dependencies the first
one is the local repository second one
is the remote repository and the third
one is the central repository so these
are the primary three type of
repositories which is available there
for a per specific maven over here
so whatever repository you want to
follow you want to access you can pretty
much access it and you can go with that
right
now the local repository will be primary
present onto your pc that's the way that
how it's present there and the uh
particular remote repository something
which you can store on any remote
machine or remote server and the central
repository is something which you can
have it onto the internet so usually the
central repositories is something in
which we can actually host our different
kind of dependencies and the jar files
over there
so local repository on the machine of
the developer where the project material
is saved so all the particular
dependencies jar file will be available
on your local machine remote machine is
the location where you can actually
store all your particular dependencies
from where you can download these
dependencies whenever you require it so
this and repositories work similar to
the central repository whenever anything
is needed from the remote repository
it's first downloaded if into your local
repository and then it will be utilized
so if you feel that the dependency is
something which is not there in the
local it will be first downloaded from
the remote repository and then it will
be utilized or will be referenced onto
the local machine there
and central repository is refers to the
maven community repository there where
you will be able to see each and every
dependency present on that repository so
maven downloads the repositories from
here in the local repository whenever
they're needed or whenever required all
these dependencies are cached locally
from where it will be referenced in the
next or you know whenever we want to
refer that we will be able to do that
particular reference easily on that part
so this is the way that how the three uh
particular repositories or movement
repositories really helps us for
performing various kind of automations
as such here
right now what are the basic concepts of
maven here so some of the couple of
basic concepts which is present in maven
is like for the first time we have the
project object model so project bomb
reference to the xml file which has all
the information regarding the project
how this particular project should be
built up how the different build process
should be automated there it also has a
description of the project details
regarding the versioning version
information is also stored as such in
this xml file in this
particular form reference file as such
over here the xml file is which is there
in the project home directory so maven
is uh something which search for the
palm file in the current directory if
it's able to find that particular pom
file so it will execute or it will
proceed with the build step otherwise
they it will halt there itself so this
spawn file is very important because it
will act as an kind of a build script
and primarily the maven tool will be
able to process each and everything
which is configured as such in this
specific xml file there and according to
that only it will function or it will
proceed further
right now second thing is the
dependencies and repositories so
dependencies are usually refers to the
java files so the java libraries which
we need in our into our particular
project so while uh working on the
project we may be having the dependency
on couple of dependencies so these
dependencies we have to actually
download or we have to actually refer
and once these a particular information
or these details are referred so what
will happen that uh we need to download
these uh specific dependencies from the
particular maven repositories so if the
dependencies are not present in your
local repository then maven will try to
download it from the central repository
and cache it into your local repository
but first of all it will look on into
the local repository and if it is not
present in local then it will go to the
remote or the central repository
then we have build lifecycles and phase
and goals there so build lifecycles
consists of the sequence of build phases
and each field phase consists of
sequence of goals here now each goal is
responsible for performing a specific
task when a phase is uh running all the
goals related to that phase and its
plugins are also used to following the
compilation preparing the artifacts
downloading the dependencies all
different things being done by the
plugins here
then we have the build profile so build
profiles refers to a set of
configuration values now generally we
have the generic build process for all
the environments all the particular code
base there but sometimes we do have some
kind of a differences there so that is
where we can go for the profiles because
a specific profile can have its own
configuration and whatever it's required
for the build process we can have
different different configurations
stored inside the maven build script
here
then with different build profiles are
added to the bom files and which enables
the different uh build as such here so
depending on these profiles we can
actually decide that how we need to
proceed with the build process and how
the different kind of build automations
needs to be performed here
then a build profile helps in
customizing the build for the different
environments so that also we can perform
as such while workforming or while
working on the different components and
the different management here so a build
profile is something which you can
configure you can utilize and depending
on that build profile we will be
deciding whether to proceed further or
how to decide on that particular factor
so these are something which we need to
take care or we need to work according
to which we can decide that how the
specific configurations and specific
automation needs to be performed here
now
usually when we go for the uh maven
there so we have to use some couple of
maven plugins now the goal of
using these specific plugins is to
automate some of the basic stuff like
compilation creating the var file
creating the java file so when we are
using the plugins we don't have to
configure the steps or write the steps
that how these uh specific plugins
should be installed or should be
referenced it's ultimately the uh
internal configurations which we are
looking forward or which we are using
while working on these specific plugins
so you can download some couple of
plugins using which we will be able to
decide that how a specific goals needs
to be achieved here so maven has its own
standard plugins that can be utilized so
if uh you know want to go for a custom
one so you can do that but pretty much
you can go for the default one and uh
you can pretty much have some specific
goals executed with the help of these
build plugins
now next thing is the maven architecture
so uh in maven what happens that uh
let's talk about the basic architecture
of maven here so
the maven executable when it's deployed
so it usually uh reads the palm.xml file
which is the build script here now once
the uh specific found xml file is being
read out so it will uh process the
components it will uh you know download
or it will process the dependencies
plugins life cycles phases and goals and
even the build profiles and uh if any
kind of interaction is required so it
will try to connect to the central
repository or remote repository and
according to that it will provide the
information and provide the details as
such so mu repository is something which
is very important because it's
ultimately trying to connect to the
maven repository and try to achieve the
various kind of automation here so it's
very important because ultimately it's
trying to help us to go for the uh
complete end-to-end build automation
when we'll go for a specific palm-based
build automation
so uh movement is it will read the
palm.xml file then download the
dependencies defined into the power xml
file and that dependencies are cached
locally from the remote or the central
repository now then uh create and
generate a remote report according to
the requirement and execute the life
cycles phases goals plugins etc so it
will process the power xml file then and
whatever the plugins and goals or the
life cycles which is configured there
step by step each of them will be
executed into a sequence
now let's talk about the overall build
life cycle of the maven here so what
happens that uh the maven build life
cycle is something which is a kind of a
collection of different steps there and
this is something which is followed to
perform a build automation for a
specific project so they are pretty much
three steps which is being done so first
one is the default so it handles the
project deployment there second handles
the project cleaning which is a clean
there and then we have site so it
handles the creation of the project
sites documentation there
so these are the three built-in
particular life cycles which is
available there at the waiver level
which you can utilize to perform a
various kind of particular steps
execution for your project
right so the build cycle has uh the
different build phases or stages there
because when we are performing a build a
variety of things needs to be performed
over here so the first one is the
compile then test compile is there so
compilation is there for the source file
and test compile is there for the test
cases test will execute the test cases
package will package the bundle then we
have the integration test to run the
integration test cases then we have the
verify then install goal is there and
the last one is the deploy which is
there to deploy the artifacts to the
artifactory so all these things are the
different phases and the stages which is
being followed as per a specific build
here so during these builds these are
the different phases and these stages
which we normally follow for performing
the build automation
now what is the exactly advantage of a
specific maven here so that is something
which we need to talk about that how the
particular automation needs to be done
or how we can actually go for the
configurations where we feel that yes we
want to perform or we want to take
certain benefits out of the
implementation of maven here so for that
what happens that we have to see that
the various kind of uh benefits the
first one is that apache maven helps
manage all the processes there such as
building documentation releasing and
distribution in project management here
so the tool simplifies the process of
project building it increases the
performance of the project and the
building process all together and the
task of downloading jar files and other
dependencies is also done automatically
we don't have to indulge in any kind of
download part as such manually over here
right and uh maven provides easy access
to all the required information so maven
makes it easy for a specific developer
to build a project in the different
environments so we don't have to worry
about the environment we don't have to
worry about the infrastructure nothing
is required everything is available
there inside this package and you know
depending on the particular you can
write the source code on one machine and
you can pretty much do the build on
another machine and this is the reason
how the build automation really happens
on the first place because the developer
is writing the source code in one
location and the same code is deployed
onto the uh particular or built onto
this jenkins or any kind of build tool
there
in maven you can easily add new
dependencies so you must write the
particular dependencies in the form file
so if you feel that you want to download
some particular dependencies so all you
have to do is that you have to put that
dependency into the a specific pom.xml
file there and depending on that the
execution will be really performed and
executed as a chair
right so let's talk about the demo now
so let's see that how exactly we can go
for this demo and we can perform the
various kind of automations
so this is the virtual machine which we
have here on which the maven is already
installed so we can run like mvn
so maven will be available as in
point 3.6.3 here now i'm going to run a
particular command called uh mvn
archetype generate here
let me create a directory here
our temp directory
and to perform this activity over there
so mvn
archetype
generate now once we run that so what
will happen that it will uh download
some of the binaries there because
uh ultimately what we are trying to do
is that we are trying to generate a new
project like a maven project so a couple
of uh particular plugins will be
downloaded by the maven executable so
that it can achieve that particular
execution so we just have to wait for
downloading all these values now here
it's trying to give us a particular
attributes like it's asking the
different attributes over here so what
exactly we want to configure so if you
want to configure you can provide that
details otherwise you can perform or
whatever the setup you want to perform
now here it's asking for the version so
uh which kind of version we want to
follow so i'm going to follow like five
here so i'll press five
then a group id which is there so uh
it's basically a kind of a group
mechanism so i can say like com
dot simply learn so that's the value
which i'm providing here artifate id i
can make it like a
sample project or something like that i
can do
so that will be the artifact uh
id which is there so
version i am keeping the same only so
and uh yeah so package same here
so i just want to create so i'll just
provide the value called yes and enter
so with this what will happen that a
sample project will be created here
right so whatever the artifact id you
provided so according to that the
project is created in this directory so
you have to go into this directory and
see that what exactly the files are
created there so you have the power.xml
file now this form.xml file when i open
so you can see here that there are some
attributes like you can have the values
uh related to what version or group id
you want to follow so this is the group
id this is the artifact id so this is
jar file by default you can change it
according to your requirement then this
is the version and if you feel that you
want to do the changes to the name that
also you can perform here so by default
the junit dependency is added but if you
want to keep on adding your own custom
dependencies you will be able to do that
now in this case if you run like mv and
clean install so it will be considered
as in particular maven project
xml file is already there present in the
local directory so according to that the
execution of the steps will be performed
and according to that you will be able
to get some desired values here so
ultimately in the target directory you
will be able to see that some couple of
jar file or a specific jar file is
generated here so you can see that in
the target directory this jar file or
this artifact is generated here so this
is a way that how we can actually go for
a generic one like a new particular
project and later on you can depending
on your uh understanding you can keep on
adding or you can keep on modifying the
dependencies and that's how you can get
the final result there
so that's it for this demo uh in which
we have find out that how exactly we can
go for a particular project preparation
with the help of mvn executable let's
get started with jenkins jenkins in my
opinion is one of the most popular
continuous integration servers of recent
times what began as a hobby project by a
developer working for sun microsystems
way back in early or mid 2000s has
gradually and eventually evolved into
very very powerful and robust automation
servers it has a wider option since it
is released under mit license and is
almost free to use
jenkins has a vast developer community
that supports it by writing all kinds of
plugins plugins is the heart and soul of
jenkins because using plugins one can
connect jenkins to anything and
everything under the sun
with that introduction let's get into
what all will be covered as a part of
this tutorial i will get into some of
the prerequisites required for
installing jenkins post which i will go
ahead and install jenkins on a windows
box there are few first time
configuration that needs to be done and
i will be covering those as well so once
i have jenkins installed and configured
properly i will get into the user
administrative part i create few users
and i will use some plugins for setting
up various kinds of access permissions
for these users i will also put in some
freestyle jobs freestyle job is nothing
but a very very simple job and i will
also show you the powerfulness of
jenkins by scheduling this particular
job to run based upon time schedule i
will also connect jenkins with github
github is our source code where source
code repository where i've got some
repositories put up there so using
jenkins i will connect to github pull up
a repository that is existing on github
onto the jenkins box and run few
commands to build this particular
repository that is pulled from github
sending out emails is a very very
important configurations of jenkins or
any other continuous integration server
for that matter whenever there is any
notifications that has to be sent out as
a part of either a build going bad or
built being good or built being
propagated to some environment and all
these scenarios you would need the
contains integration servers to be
sending out notifications so i will get
into a little bit details of how to
configure jenkins for sending out emails
i will also get into a scenario where i
would have a web application a maven
based java web application which will be
pulled from a github repository and i
will deploy it onto a tomcat server the
tomcat server will be locally running on
my system eventually i will get into one
other very very important topic which is
the master slave configuration it's a
very very important and pretty
interesting topic where distributed
builds is achieved using a master slave
configuration so i will bring up a slave
i will connect the slave with the master
and i will also put in a job and kind of
delegate that particular job to the
slave configuration finally i will let
you know how to use some plugins to
backup your jenkins so jenkins has got a
lot of useful information set up on it
in terms of the build environments in
terms of workspace all this can be very
very easily backed up using a plugin so
this is what i'm going to be covering as
a part of this tutorial jenkins is a web
application that is written in java and
there are various ways in which you can
use and install jenkins i have listed
popular three mechanisms in which
jenkins is usually installed on any
system the topmost one is as a windows
or a linux based services so if at all
you have windows like the way i have and
i'm going to use this mechanism for this
demo so i would download a msi installer
that is specific to jenkins and install
this service so whenever installed as a
service it goes ahead and nicely
installs all that is required for my
jenkins and i have a service that can be
started or stopped based upon my need
any flavor of linux as well one other
way of running jenkins is downloading
this generic war file and as long as you
have jdk installed you can launch this
war file by the command opening up a
command prompt or shell prompt if it
layer on linux box specifying java
hyphen jar and the name of this war file
it typically brings up your web
application and you know you can
continue with your installation the only
thing being if at all you want to stop
using jenkins you just go ahead and
close this prompt you either do a
control c and then bring down this
prompt and your jenkins server will be
down other older versions of jenkins
were run popularly using this way in
which you already have a java based web
server running up and running so you
kind of drop in this war file into the
root folder or the httpd root folder of
your web server so jenkins would explode
and kind of bring up your application
all user credentials or user
administration is all taken care of by
the apache or the tomcat server or the
web server on which jenkins is running
this was a very older way of running but
still some people use it because if they
don't want to maintain two servers if
they already have a java web server
which it's been nicely maintained and
backed up jenkins can run attached to it
all right so either ways it doesn't
matter however you're going to bring up
your jenkins instance the way we're
going to operate jenkins is all going to
be very very same or similar one with
the subtle changes in terms of user
administration if at all you're
launching it through any other web
server which will take care of the user
administration otherwise all the
commands or all the configuration or the
way in which i'm going to run this demo
it is going to be same across any of
these installations all right so the
prerequisites for running jenkins as i
mentioned earlier jenkins is nothing but
a simple web application that is written
in java so all that it needs is java
preferably jdk 1.7 or 1.8 2gb ram is the
recommended ram for running jenkins and
also like any other open source tool
sets when you install jdk ensure that
you set in the environment variable java
home to point to the right directory
this is something very specific to jdk
but for any other open source tools that
you've installed there's always a
preferred environment variable that you
got to set in which is specific to that
particular tool that you're going to use
this is a generic thing that is there
for you know for any other open source
projects because the way open source
projects discover themselves is using
these environment variables so as a
general practice or a good practice
always set these environment variables
accordingly so i already have jdk 1.8
installed on my system but in case you
do not what i would recommend is just
navigate on your browser to the oracle
home page and just type in or search for
install
jdk 1.8
and navigate to the oracle home page
you will have to
accept the license agreement and there
are a bunch of installers that is okay
that you can pick up based upon the
operating system on which you're running
so
i have this windows 64 installer that is
already installed and running on my
system so i will not get into the
details of downloading this or
installing it let me show you once i
install this what i've done with regard
to my path
so
if you get into this environment
variables
all right so i've just set in a java
home variable
if you see this c colon program files
java jdk 1.8 this is where my my java is
located c program files
c program files java
okay so this is the home directory of my
jdk so that is what i've been i've set
it up here in my environment variable
so if you see here this is my java home
all right one other thing to do is
ensure that in case you want to run java
or java c from a command prompt ensure
that you also add that path into this
path variable so if you see this
somewhere i will see yes there you go
sequel in program files java jdk 1.8 pin
so with these two i'll ensure that my
java installation is nice and you know
good enough so to check that to double
check that or to verify that let me just
open up a simple command prompt
and if i type in java iphone version
all right
and java c
iphone version
so the compiler is on the path java is
on the path and if at all i do this
even the environment variable specific
to my java is
installed correctly so i am good to go
ahead with my jenkins installation
now that i have my prerequisites
all set for installing jenkins let me
just go ahead and download jenkins
so let me open up a browser and say
download
jenkins
all right lts is nothing but the long
term support these are all stable
versions weeklies i would not recommend
that you try these unless until you have
a real need for that um long term
support is good enough and as i
mentioned there are so many flavors of
jenkins that is available for download
you also have a docker container
wherein you know you can launch jenkins
as a container but i'll not get into
details of that in this tutorial
all right so what i want is yes this is
the war file which is a generic war file
that i was talking to you earlier and
this is the windows msi installer so go
ahead and download this msi installer i
already have that downloaded so let me
just open that up
all right
so this is my downloaded jenkins
instance
or rather installer this is a pretty
maybe a few months old but this is good
enough for me
before you start jenkins installation
just be aware of one fact that there is
a variable called jenkins home this is
where jenkins would store all this
configuration data jobs project
workspace and all that specific to
jenkins so by default if at all you
don't set this to any particular
directory if at all you install an msi
installer all your installation gets
into c colon program files 86 and
jenkins folder if at all you run a war
file depending upon the user id with
which you're running your war file the
jenkins folder there's a dot jenkins
folder that gets created inside the user
home directory so in case you have any
need wherein you want to backup your
jenkins or you want jenkins
installations to get into some specific
directories go ahead and set this
jenkins home variable accordingly before
you even begin your installation for now
i don't need to do any of these things
so i've already downloaded the installer
let me just go ahead with the default
installation
all right so this is my jenkins msi
installer i would just i don't want to
make any changes into the jenkins
configuration c colon program files is
good for me yeah this is where all my
destination folder and all the
configuration specific to it goes i'm
happy with this i don't want to change
this
i would just say go ahead and click
installation
okay so what typically happens once the
jenkins installation gets through is
it'll start installing itself and there
are some small checks that needs to be
done
so and by default jenkins launches on
the port 8080 so let me just open up
localhost 8080
there's a small checking that will be
done as a part of the installation
process wherein i need to type in the
hash key all right so there's a very
very simple hash key that gets stored
out here so i'll have to just copy this
path
if i told you you're running as a war
file you would see that in your logs
all right so this is a simple hash key
that gets created every time when you do
a jenkins station
so as a part of the installation it just
asks you to do this
so if that is not great it will [ __ ]
about it but this looks good so it's
going ahead
all right one important part during the
installation
so you would need to install some
recommended plugins
what happens is the plugins are all
related to each other so it's like the
typical rpm kind of a problem where you
try to install some plugin and it's got
a dependency which is not installed and
you get into all those issues in order
to get rid of that what jenkins
recommends there's a bunch of plugins
that is already recommended so just go
ahead and blindly click that
install recommended plugin so if you see
there is
a whole lot of plugins which are bare
essential plug-ins that is required for
jenkins in order to run properly so
jenkins as a part of the installation
would get all these plugins and then
install it for you
this is a good combination to kind of
begin with and mind you at this moment
jenkins needs
lots of bandwidth in terms of network so
in case your you know your network is
not so good few of these plugins would
kind of fail
and these plugins are all you know on
available on openly
or mirrored sites and sometimes some of
them may be down so do not worry in case
some of these plugins kind of fail to
install you'll get an option to kind of
retry installing them but just ensure
that you know at least most or 90 95 of
all these plugins are installed without
any problems let me pause the video here
for a minute and then get back once all
these plugins are installed
my plugin installation is all good there
was no failures in any of my plugins so
after that i get to create this first
admin user again this is one important
point that you got to remember
keen given any username and password but
ensure that you kind of remember that
because it's very hard to get back your
username and password in case you forget
it all right so i'm going to create a
very very simple username and password
something that i can remember
i will
that's my name and
an email id is kind of optional but it
doesn't allow me to go ahead in case i
don't so i just given an admin and i got
a password i've got i remember my
password this is my full name
all right i say save and finish
all right that kind of completed my
jenkins installation
it was not that tough was it
now that i have my jenkins installed
correctly let me quickly walk you
through some bare minimal configurations
that is required these are kind of a
first time configuration that is
required so and also let me warn you the
ui is little hard for many people to
wrap their head around it specifically
the windows guys
but if at all you're a java guy you know
how painful it is to write ui in java
you will kind of appreciate you know all
the effort that has gone into the ui
bottom line you are a little hard to you
know wrap your head around it but once
you start using it possibly you'll start
liking it
all right so let me get into something
called as manage jenkins
this can be viewed like a
main menu for all jenkins configuration
so i'll get into some of those important
ones
something called as configure system
configure system this is where you kind
of put in the configuration for your
complete jenkins instance few things to
kind of look out for this is a home
directory this is a java home where all
the configurations all the workspace
anything and everything regarding
jenkins is stored out here
system message you want to put in some
message on the system you just type in
whatever you want and it's probably show
up somewhere up here on the menu number
of executors very very important
configuration this just lets jenkin know
at any point in time how many jobs or
how many threads can be run you can kind
of visualize it like a thread that can
be run on this particular instance as a
thumb rule if at all you're on a single
core system number of executors two
should be good enough
in case at any point in time there are
multiple jobs that kind of get triggered
the same time in case the number of
executors are less compared to the
number of jobs that have that woken up
no need to panic because they will all
get queued up and eventually jenkins
will get to running those jobs just bear
in mind that whenever a new job kind of
you know gets triggered the cpu usage
and the memory usage in terms of the
disk right is very high on the jenkins
instance so that's something that you
got to kind of keep in mind all right
but number of executors 2 for my system
is kind of good label for my jenkins i
don't want any of these things usage how
do you want to use your jenkins this is
good for me because i only have a
primary uh server that is running so i
want to use this node as much as
possible quite pretty each of these
options have got some pair minimal
help kind of a thing that is that is out
here by clicking on these question marks
you will get to know as to what are
these particular configurations
all right so this all look good what i
want to show you here is there's
something regarding the docker
timestamps git plugin svn
email notifications
i don't want that what i want the yes i
want this smtp server configuration
remember i mentioned earlier that i
would want jenkins to be sending out
some emails and what i've done here is
i've just configured
the smtp details of my personal email id
in case you are in a in organization you
would have some sort of an email ids
that is set up for a jenkins server so
you can specify the smtp server details
of your
company so that you know you can
authorize jenkins to kind of send out
emails but in case you want to try it
out like me i have configured my
personal email id which is on my gmail
for sending out notifications so the
smtp server would be
smtp.gmail.com i'm using the smtp
authentication i have provided my email
id and my password i'm using the smtp
port which is 465 and i'm you know reply
to address is the same as mine i can
just send out an email
and see if at all this configuration
works again gmail would not allow you to
allow anybody to send out notifications
on your behalf so you'll have to lower
the security level of your gmail id so
that you can allow a programmatically
somebody to send out email notifications
on your behalf so i've done already that
i'm just trying to see if i can send a
test email with the configurations that
i've set in
yes
all right so the email configuration
looks good
so this is how you configure your uh you
know your gmail account in case you want
to do that if not put in your
organization smtp server details which
are for the valid username and password
and it should all be set
all right so no other configuration that
i'm going to change here all of these
look good
all right so i come back to managing
cans okay one other thing that i want to
kind of go over is the global tool
configuration
imagine this scenario look at it this
way jenkins is a is a continuous
integration server it doesn't know what
kind of a code base it's going to pull
in what kind of a tool set that is
required or what is the code that is
going to pull in and how is it going to
build so you would have to put in all
the tools that is required for building
the appropriate kind of code that you're
going to pull in from you know your
source code repositories so just to give
you an example in case your source code
is a java source code and assuming that
you know because in this demo this is my
laptop and i've put in all the
configurations jdk everything on my
laptop because i'm a developer i'm
working on the laptop but my continuous
integration server would be you know a
separate server without anything being
installed on it
so in case i want jenkins to you know
run a java code i would need to install
jdk on it i need to specify the jdk
location of this out here this way
okay since i already have the jdk
installed and i've already put in the
java home directory or rather the
environment variable correctly i don't
need to do it git if at all i want the
jenkins server to use git git is a you
know command bash or the command prompt
for for running git and connecting to
any other git server so you would need
git to be you know installed on that
particular system and set the path
accordingly
gradle and maven if at all you have some
mavens as well you want to do this any
other tool that you're going to install
on your system
which is your continuous integration
server you will have to come in here and
configure something
in case you don't configure it when
jenkins runs it will not be able to
find these tools for building your task
and it'll crib about it
that's good i don't want to save
anything
manage jenkins let me see what else is
required yes configure global security
all right the secret is enabled and if
you see by default it's the security
access control is set to jenkins own
user database so what does this mean you
know jenkins by default it uses file
system where it stores all the usernames
which hashes up these user names and
kind of stores them
so as of now it jenkins is configured to
use its own database assuming that you
are running in an organization you would
probably want to have a you know some
sort of an ad or an ldap server using
which you would want to control access
to your jenkins repository rather
jenkins tool
so you would specify your ldap server
details the root dn
password or the manager dn and the
manager password and all these details
in case you want to connect your jenkins
instance with your
ldap or ad or any of the authentication
servers that you have in your
organization
but for now since i don't have any of
these things i'm going to use this own
database that's good enough
all right so i will set up some
authorization methods and stuff like
that once i put in few jobs so for now
let me not get into any of these details
of this just be aware that jenkins can
be connected for authorization to an
ldap server or you can have jenkins
managing its own servers which is
happening as of now so i'm going to save
all this stuff
that's good for me so enough of all
these configurations let me put in a
very very simple job all right so job
new item you know a little difficult to
kind of figure out but then that's the
new item so i'll just say you know first
job this is good for me i just give a
name for my job i would say it's a
freestyle project that's good enough for
me i don't want to choose any of that so
unless until you choose any of this this
particular button would not become
active so choose the freestyle project
and say okay
at a very high level you would see
general source code management build
triggers build environment build and
post build in case you install more and
more plugins you will see a lot more
options but for now this is what you
would see so what am i doing at the
moment i'm just putting up a very very
simple job and the job could be anything
and everything so i don't want to put in
a very complicated job for now for the
demo let me just put in a very very
simple job i'll give a description
this is an optional thing this is my
first
jenkins job all right i don't want to
choose any of these again there are some
helps available here
i don't want to choose any of this i
don't want to connect it to any source
code for now
i don't want any triggers for now i'll
come back to this in a while build the
environment i don't want any build
environment as a part of this build step
you know i just want to you know run few
things so that i kind of complete this
particular job so since i'm on a windows
box i would say execute windows batch
command
all right so what do you want to do i
will let me just echo something echo
uh hello
this is my first jenkins job
and possibly i would want the date and
the time stamp
pertaining to the job i mean the date
and time in which this job was run all
right very very simple command that says
you know this is my first job it just
puts out something along with the date
and the time
all right i don't want to do anything
else i want to keep this job as simple
as this so let me
save this job
all right so once i save this job you
know the job names comes up here and
then i need to build this job and you
would see some build stray out here
nothing is there as of now because i've
just put in a job i've not run it yet
alright so let me try to build it now
you see a build number you would see a
date and a timestamp so if i click on
this you will see a console output if i
go here
okay as simple as that and where is all
the job details that is getting into if
you see this
if i navigate to this particular
directory
all right so this is the directory what
i was mentioning earlier regarding
jenkins home so all the job related
stuff that is specific to this
particular jenkins installation is all
here
all the plugins that is installed the
details of each of those plugins can be
found here
all right so the workspace is where all
the jobs that i've created whichever i'm
running
you know there will be individual
folders specific to the jobs that has
been put up here all right so one job
one quick run
that's what it looks like pretty simple
okay let me do one thing let me put up a
second job
i would say second job
i would say freestyle project
all right this is my second job
i just want to demonstrate the
powerfulness of the automation server
and how simple it is to automate a job
that is put up on jenkins
which will be triggered automatically
remember what i said earlier about
jenkins because at the core of jenkins
is a very very powerful automation
server all right so what i'm going to do
i will just keep everything else the
same i'm going to put in the build
script pretty much similar to
second job
that
gets triggered
automatically
every
minute all right let me do that
percentage date
and i'll put in the time
all right so i just put in another job
called second job and it pretty much
does the same thing as what i was doing
earlier in terms of printing the date
and the time but this time i'm just
going to demonstrate the powerfulness of
the automation server that is there if
you see here
there's a build trigger
so a build can be triggered using
various triggers that is there so we'll
get into this github
triggering or hook or a web hook kind of
a triggering later on but for now what i
want to do i want to ensure that this
job that i'm going to put in would be
automatically triggered on its own let's
say every minute i want this job to be
run on its own
so build periodically is my setting
if you see here there's a bunch of
help that is available for me so for
those of you who have written cron jobs
on linux boxes you'll find it very very
simple but for others don't panic let me
just put up a very very simple regular
expression for scheduling this job every
minute
all right so that's
one
two
three
four
five
all right come up come up come up all
right so five stars is all that i'm
going to put in and jenkins got a little
worried and is asking me do you really
mean every minute oh yeah i want to do
this every minute let me save this and
how do i check whether it gets triggered
every minute or not i just don't do
anything i'll just wait for a minute
and if at all everything goes well
jenkins would automatically trigger my
second job in a minute's time from now
this time around i'm not going to
trigger anything look there you see
it's automatically got trigger
if i go in here
yep second job that gets triggered
automatically you know it was triggered
at 42
1642 which is 442 my time that looks
good
and if everything goes well every one
minute onwards this jog will be
automatically triggered
now that i have
my jenkins up and running a few jobs
that has been put up here on my jenkins
instance i would need a way of
controlling access to my jenkins server
this is wherein i would use a plugin
called role based access plugin and
create few rules the rules are something
like a global rule and a project rule
project specific growth i can have
different roles and i can have users who
have signed up or the users who might
create kind of assigned to these roles
so that each of these users fall into
some category this is my way of kind of
controlling access to my jenkins
instance and
ensuring that people don't do something
unwarranted
all right so first things first let me
go ahead and install a plugin
for doing that so i get into manage
jenkins and manage plug-in
a little bit of a confusing screen in my
opinion there's updates available
installed and advanced as of now we
don't have the role based plugin so let
me go to available it'll take some time
for it to get refreshed all right now
these are the available plugins these
are the install plugins
all right so let me come back to
available and i would want to search for
my role based access plugin so i would
just search for role and hit enter
okay role based authorization strategy
enables user authorization using the
role-based strategy roles can be defined
globally or for particular jobs or nodes
and stuff like that so exactly this is
the plugin that i want
i would want to install it without a
restart
right looks good so far yes
go back to the top of the page yes
remember jenkins is running on a java
using a java instance so typically many
things would work the same way
understandably you want to restart
jenkins once in a while but as a good
practice whenever you do some sort of
big installations or big patches on your
jenkins instance just ensure that you
kind of restart it otherwise there would
be a difference in terms of what is
installed on the system and what is
there on the file system you will need
to flush out few of those settings later
on but for now these are all very small
plugins so this would run without any
problems but otherwise if at all there
are some plugins which would need a
restart you know kindly go ahead and
restart your jenkins instance but for
now i don't need that it looks good i've
installed the plugin so where do i see
my plugin i installed the plugin that is
specific to the
user control or the access control so
let me go into
yes
global security
and uh i would see this role-based
strategy showing up now
all right so this comes in because of my
installation of my role based uh plugin
so this is what i would want to enable
because i already have my own database
set up and for the authorization part in
the sense that who can do what i'm going
to install i mean i've already installed
a role based strategy
plugin and i'm going to enable that
strategy all right i would say save
okay
now i've installed the role based access
plugin i would need to just set it up
and check that you know i would go ahead
and create some roles and ensure that i
assign users as per these roles all
right so let me go to
manage jenkins
configure
all right let me see where is this
configure configure global security is
that where i create my roles
nope not here
yes manage and assign roles
okay again you would see these options
only after you install these plugins so
for now i've just enabled the plugin i
have enabled role-based access control
and i would go ahead and create some
rules for this particular jenkins
instance so i would say first
manage rules
so i would need to create some roles
here and the rules are at a very high
level these are global rules and there
are some project rules and there are
some slave rules i'll not get into
details of all of this at a very very
high level which is a global role let me
just create a role a role can be kind of
visualized like a group
so i would create a role called
developer typically the jenkins instance
or the ca instance are kind of owned up
or controlled by qa guys so qr guys
would need to provide some sort of uh
you know limited access to developers so
that's why i'm creating a role called
developer
and i'm adding this role at a global
role level so i would say add this here
and you would see this developer role
that is there and each of these options
if you hover over it you would see some
sort of a
help on what what are these you know
permissions specific to so what i want
is like you know it sounds a little you
know different but i would want to give
very very little permissions for the
developer so from an administration
perspective i would just want him to
have a read
kind of a role credentials again i would
just want to view kind of a rule i don't
want him to create any agents and all
that stuff that looks good for me
for a job i would want him to just
possibly
read i don't want him to build i don't
want him to cancel any jobs i don't want
him to configure any job i don't even
want him to create any job i would just
want him to read few things i would not
give him possibly a role to the
workspace as well i mean i don't want
him to have access to the workspace i
would just want him to
read a job check you know i have read
only access to the job run
um no i don't want him to give him any
any particular access which will allow
him to run any jobs view configure
yeah possibly create
yeah delete i don't want to read yes
definitely
and this is the specific role so what
i'm doing i'm just creating a global
role called developer and i'm giving him
very very limited roles
in the sense that i don't want this
developer to be able to run any agents
nor create jobs or build jobs or cancel
jobs or configure jobs at the max i
would just want him to read a job that
is already put up there
okay
so i would save
now i created a role
i still don't have any users that is
there on the system so let me go ahead
and create some user on the system
that's not here i will say configure
managing cans manage users
okay let me create a new user
i would call this user as yeah developer
one sounds good
some password
password that i can remember
okay his name is developer1
d at
d.com or something like that
okay so this is the admin with with
which i kind of configured or brought up
the system and developer one is a user
that i have configured so still have not
set any rules for this particular user
yet so i would go to manage and gains
i would say
manage and assign roles i would say
assign roles
okay so if you see what i am going to do
now is assign a role that is specific to
that particular i will find the
particular user and assign him the
developer role that i have already
configured
the role shows up here i would need to
find my user whoever created and then
assign him to that particular role so if
you remember the user that i created was
developer one i would add this
particular user and now this particular
user what kind of a role i want him to
have because this is the global rule
that it created so developer i would
assign this developer one to this
particular global rule
and i would go ahead and save my changes
now let me check the permissions of this
particular user by logging out of my
admin account and logging back as
developer one
if you remember this role was created
with very less privileges
so
there you go i have jenkins but i don't
see a new item i can't trigger a new job
i can't do anything i see these jobs
however i don't think so i'll be able to
start this job i don't have the
permission set for that the maximum i
can do is look at the job see what was
there as a part of the console output
and stuff like that so this is a limited
role that was created and i added this
developer to that particular role which
was a developer role
so that the developers don't get to
configure any of the jobs because the
jenkins instance is owned by a qr person
he doesn't want to give developer any
administrative rights so the rights that
he set out by creating a developer role
and anybody who is tagged any user who's
tagged as a part of this developer role
would get the same kind of permissions
and these permissions can be you know
fine grain it can be a project specific
permissions as well but for now i just
demonstrated the high level permission
that i had set in
let me quickly log out of this user and
get back
as the admin user because i need to
continue with my demo with the developer
role that was created i have very very
less privileges one of the reasons for
jenkins being so popular as i mentioned
earlier is the bunch of plugins that is
provided by users or community users who
don't charge any money for these plugins
but it's got plugins for connecting
anything and everything so if you can
navigate to or if you can find jenkins
plugins
you would see index of over so many
plugins that is there all of these are
wonderful plugins whatever connectors
that you would need if you want to
connect jenkins to an aws instance or
you want to connect jenkins to a docker
instance or any of those containers you
would have a plugin you can go and
search up if i want to connect jenkins
to bitbucket
bitbucket is one of the git servers
there's so many plugins that is
available okay so
bottom line jenkins without plugins is
nothing so plugins is the heart of
jenkins for you to connect or for in
order to connect jenkins with any of the
containers or any of the other tool sets
you would need the plugins if you want
to connect or you want to build a
repository which has got java and maven
you would need to install maven and jdk
on your jenkins instance if at all
you're looking for a net build or a
microsoft build you would need to have
ms build installed on your on your
jenkins instance and the plugins that
will trigger ms build if at all you want
to listen to some server side web hooks
from github you will need github
specific plugins if you want to connect
jenkins to aws you need those plugins if
you want to connect to a docker instance
that is running anywhere in the world as
long as you have the url which is
publicly reachable you just have a
docker plugin that is installed on your
jenkins instance sonar cube is one of
the popular static code analyzers so you
can connect a jenkins build you can
build a job on jenkins and push it to
sonar cube and get sonar cube to run
analysis on that and get back the
results in jenkins all of these works
very well because of the plugins now
with that let me connect our jenkins
instance to github i already have very
very simple java repository up on my
github instance so let me connect
jenkins to this particular github
instance and pull out a job that is put
up there all right so this is my very
very simple uh you know repository that
is there called hello java and this is
what is there in the repo there is a
hello hello.java application that is
here or a simple class file that is
there it's got just one line of system
dot out so this is already present on
github.com at this place and this would
be the url for this repository
if i pick up the https url this is my
stps url so what i would do is i would
connect my jenkins instance to go to
github provide my credentials and pull
out this repository which is on the
cloudhosted github.com and get it to my
jenkins instance and then build this
particular java file i'm keeping the
source code very very simple it's just a
java file how do i build my java file
how do i compile my java file i just say
java c and the name of my
class file which is hello java and how
do i run my java file i would say java
and hello
okay so remember i don't need to install
any plugins now because
what it needs is a git plugin so if you
remember when we were doing the
installation there was a bunch of
recommended plugins so git is already
installed on my system so i don't need
to install it again so let me put up a
new job here it says git job it would be
a freestyle project that's good for me i
would say okay
all right so the source code management
remember in the earlier examples we did
not use any source code because we were
just putting up some echo kind of uh
jobs we did not need any integration
with any of the source code systems so
now let me connect this so i'm going to
put up a source code and git would show
up because the plugin is already there
svn perforce any of those additional
source code management tools if at all
you would need just install those
plugins and jenkins connects wonderfully
well to all these particular source
control tools okay so i would copy the
https url from here i would say this is
the url that i'm supposed to
go and grab my source code from but all
right that sounds good but what is the
username and password so i'll have to
specify a username
and password all right so i would say
the username this is my username and
this is my https credential for my job
okay so this is my username and this is
my password i just save this and say add
and then i would say you know use this
credentials to go to github and then on
my behalf pull out a repository all
right if at all at this stage if there's
any error in terms of not able to
jenkins not able to find git or the git
dot exe or if my credentials are wrong
somewhere down here you would see a red
message saying that you know something
is not right you can just go ahead and
kind of fix that for now this looks good
for me i'm going to grab this
url what am i going to do
this step would pull the source code
from the github and then what would be
there as a part of my build step
because this repository just has a java
file
correct hello.java so in order to for me
to build this i would just say execute
windows batch command and i would say
java c
hello dot
java that is the way i would build my
java code and if i have to run it i
would just say java
hello
pretty simple two steps and this would
run after the repository contents are
fetched from github
so java c java that sounds good i would
say save this and let me try to run this
okay if you see
there's a lot of you know it executes
git on your behalf it goes out here it
provides my credentials and says you
know it pulls all my repository and by
default it will pull up the master
branch that is there on my repository
and it kind of builds this whole thing
java c hello java and it runs this
project java hello and there you see
this is the output that is there and if
at all you want to look at the contents
of the repository if you can go here
this is my
workspace
of my system hang on this is not right
okay gate job if you see here this is my
hello.java this is the same program that
was there on my github repository
okay so this is a program that was there
on the github repository all right so
this was the same program that was here
and jenkins on our behalf went over all
the way to github pulled this repository
from there and then you know it brought
it down to my local system on my jenkins
instance it compiled it and it ran this
particular application
okay now that i have integrated jenkins
successfully with github for a simple
java application let me build a little
bit on top of it what i will do is i
have a maven based web application that
is up there as a repository in my github
so this is the repository that i'm
talking about it's called amv and web
app it's got it's a maven based
repository as you would know maven is a
very very simple java based
build tool that will allow you to run
various targets and it will compile it
will based upon the goals that you
specify it can compile it can run some
tests and you can you can build a war
file and even deploy it into some other
server for now what we're going to use
maven is just for building and creating
a package out of this particular web
application it contains a bunch of
things and what is important is just the
index.jsp it just contains an html file
that is there as a part of this web
application so from a perspective of
requirements now since i'm going to
connect jenkins with this particular
repository git we already have that set
we only need two other things one is
maven because jenkins will use maven so
in order to use maven jenkins would have
to have a maven installation that is
there on the jenkins box and in this
case the jenkins box is this laptop
and after i have my maven installed i
also need a tomcat server
tomcat is a very very simple web server
that you can freely download i'll let
you know how to quickly uh download and
install the tomcat all right so download
maven first
okay there are various ways in which you
can kind of download this maven there is
zip files
binary zip files and archive files so
what i've done is i've just already
downloaded maven and if you see i've
unzipped it here so this is the folder
with which i have unzipped my maven
so as you know maven again is is one
open source build tool so you'll have to
set in a few configurations and set up
the path so mvn hyphen iphone version if
i specify this after i set in my path my
one should work and if at all i echo
empty home which is nothing but the
variable environment variable specific
to my onenote it is already set here
so once you unzip my mav1 just set this
m2 home variable to the directory where
you unzip your mav1 also just set the
path to this particular directory slash
bin because that is where your maven
executables are all found
all right so that's with maven and you
know since i've set the path and the
environment variable maven is running
perfectly fine on my system i just
verified it okay next one is a tomcat
server
download apache tomcat server 8.5 is
what i have on my system
so i'm just going to show you where to
download this from
this is where you download tomcat server
and um
i already have the server downloaded
again this doesn't need any installation
i just unzip it here and it kind of has
a bin and configuration i have made some
subtle changes in the configuration
first and foremost tomcat server also by
default runs on port 8080. 8080 since we
already have our jenkins server running
on port 8080 we cannot let tomcat run on
the same port there will be a port clash
so what i've done i have configured
tomcat to use a different port so if i
go to this configuration file here there
is a server.xml
let me open this up here
all right okay so this is the port by
default it will be 8080 i've just
modified it to 8081 so i've changed the
port on which my tomcat server would run
all right so that's one chain second
change when jenkins kind of tries to get
into my tomcat and deploy something for
someone he would need some
authentications so that he'll be alloyed
deployment by tomcat so for that i need
to create a user on tomcat and provide
this user credentials to my jenkins
instance
so i would go to
tomcatusers.xml file here
i've already created
a username called deployer and the
password is deployer and i've added a
role called manager hyphen script
manager hyphen script will allow
programmatic access to the tomcat server
so this is the role that is there so
using this credentials i will enable or
i'll empower jenkins to get into my
tomcat server and deploy my application
all right only these two things that is
required
let me just start my tomcat server first
so i get into my bin folder i open a
command prompt here and there's a
startup.bat
it's pretty fast it just takes a few
seconds yes there you go tomcat server
is up and running now this is running on
port 8081 so let me just check if that
looks good
so localhost
8081.
okay my tomcat server is up and running
that sounds good the user is already
configured on this that's also fine so
what i'll do as a part of my first job
my one is also installed on my system so
i'm good to use maven as a part of my
jenkins so i will put up a simple job
now
i will say job
mbn
[Music]
web app i call this
freestyle job that's good
okay so this will be a git repository
what is the url of my git repository
is this guy
https url
okay
that's this url i will use the
credentials the old credentials that i
set up will work well because it's the
same git user that i'm kind of
connecting into
all right so now the change happens here
where after i get this since i said this
is a simple maven repository i will have
some maven targets to run
so a simple target first is
let me run maven package this creates a
war file
okay so mvn package is the target
package is the target so when whenever i
run this package it kind of creates it
it builds it it tests it and then
creates a package so this is all that is
required maybe let me try to save this
and let me first run this and see
if it connects well if there's any
problem with my war file
or the war file gets created properly
okay
wonderful so it built a war file and if
you see it all shows you
what is the location where this war file
was generated
so this will be the workspace if you see
this this war file was successfully
built now i need to grab this particular
war file and then i would need to deploy
it into tomcat server
again i would need a small plugin to do
this because i need to connect tomcat
with my jenkins server
let me go ahead and
install the plugin for the container
deployment
so i will go to manage plugins
available
type in container
container container
deploy to container okay so let's put
this the plugin that i would need i will
install it without a restart
right seems to be very fast
nope sorry it's still installing
okay
it installed the plugin so if at all you
see this
if you go to my workspace
okay in the target folder
i would say this web application war
file that is already built
so i would need to configure this plugin
to pull up this war file and deploy it
onto the tomcat server for deploying
onto the tomcat server i will use the
credentials of the user that have
created okay so let me go to configure
this particular project again
and um
okay all this is good
so the package is good i'm gonna just
create a package that's all fine
now add a post build step so after the
war file is built as a part of this
package directive let me use this
deployment to container now this will
show up after you install the plugin so
deploy this one to the container
now what is that you're supposed to
specify you're supposed to specify
the what is the location
okay so this is a global uh you know
configuration that is there that will
allow you to
from the root folder it will pick up the
war file that is there so star star
forward slash star dot war that's good
for me
okay what is the context path context
path is nothing but just the name of an
application that you know under which it
will get deployed into the tomcat server
i will just say mvn web app
that's the name of my thing now i need
to specify what kind of a container that
i'm talking about
all right so the deployment would be for
this tomcat 8.5 is what i need
okay because the server that we have is
a tomcat 8.5 server that i have so this
would be the url so the credentials yes
i need to add a credential for this
particular server so if you remember i
had created a credential
for my web application so let me just
find that
my tomcat server yes configuration of
this
okay so deployer and deployer username
is deployer password is deployer
okay so let me use that credential
i would say i would say add a new
credential jenkins credential the
username is deployer and the password is
deployer
so i would use this deployer credentials
for that and what is the url of my
tomcat instance
so this is the url of my tomcat instance
so take the war file that is fine found
in this particular
folder
and then you know context path is mn web
app use the deployer deployment
credentials and get into this localhost
which is there
8081 this is the tomcat server that is
running on my system and then go ahead
and deploy it
okay so that is all that is required so
i would say just save this
and let me run it now
okay it builds successfully built the
war file it is trying to deploy it and
looks like the deployment went ahead
perfectly well
so
the context path was mvn web app so if i
type in this
all right if at all i go ahead into my
tomcat server there would be a web apps
folder
you would see the
you know the date timestamp so this is
the file that get got recently copied
and this is the explorer version of our
application
so the application was built the source
code of this application was pulled from
the github server it was built locally
on the jenkins instance and then it was
pushed into a tomcat server which is
running on a different port which is
808.1 now for this demo i'm running
everything locally on my system but
assuming that you know this particular
tomcat instance was running on some
other server with some other different
ip address all that you got to go and
change is the url of the server
so this would be the server in case you
you already have that you know if you
have a tomcat which is running on some
other machine that's all fine with a
different ipa that's all good enough
the whole bundle or the war file that
was built as a part of this jenkins job
gets transferred onto the other server
and gets deployed that's the beauty of
jenkins and automatic deployments or
other deployments using jenkins and
maven
distributed build or master slave
configuration in jenkins as you would
have seen you know we just have one
instance of jenkins server up and
running all the time and also i told you
that whenever any job that kind of you
know gets started on the jenkins server
it is little heavy on in terms of disk
space and the cpu utilization so which
kind of you know if at all you're in an
organization wherein you're heavily
reliant on the jenkins server you don't
want your jenkins server to go down so
that's where you kind of start
distributing the load that is there on
the jenkins server so you primarily have
a server which is just a placeholder or
like a master who will take in all kind
of jobs and what he will do is based
upon trigger that has happened to the
job or whichever job needs to be built
he if at all he can delegate these jobs
onto some other machines or some other
slaves you know that's a wonderful thing
to have okay use case one use case two
assuming that you know if you have a
jenkins server that is running on a
windows box or on a linux one and if at
all you have a need where you need to
build based upon operating systems you
have multiple build configurations to
support maybe you need to build a
windows you know windows based dotnet
kind of a projects where you would need
a windows machine to build this
particular project you also have a
requirement where you want to build
linux linux based systems you also have
a mac you you support some sort of an
apps or something that is built on mac
os you would need to build you know mac
based system as well so how are you
going to support all these needs so
that's where in a beautiful concept of
master slave or you know primary and
delegations or agent and master comes
into play so typically you would have
one jenkins server who will just you
know configure with all the proper
authorizations users configurations and
everything is set up on this jenkins
server his job is just delegations he
will listen to some sort of triggers or
based upon the job that is coming in he
will if there is a way nice way of
delegating these jobs to somebody else
and you know taking back the results he
can control a lot of other systems and
these systems may not have a complete or
there's no need to put in a complete
jenkins installation all that you got to
do is have a very very simple runner or
a slave that is a simple jar file that
is run as a low priority thread or a
process within these systems so with
that you can have a wonderful
distributed build server that can be set
up and in case one of the servers goes
down your master would know that what
went down and kind of delegate the task
to somebody else so this is the kind of
distributed build or the master slave
configuration so what i'll do in this
exercise or in this demo is i'll set up
a simple slave but since i don't have
too many machines to kind of play around
what i'll do is i will set up a slave in
in one other folder within my hard drive
so i've got the c drive and d drive my
jenkins is on my c drive so what i do is
i would just use my e drive and set up a
very very simple slave out there i'll
just show you how to provision a slave
and how to connect to a slave and how to
delegate a job to that slave let me go
back to my jenkins master and configure
him to
you know talk to an agent
so there are various ways in which this
client and server talk to each other
what i'm going to choose is something
called as jnlp java network launch
protocol so using this i would ensure
that you know the client and server talk
to each other so for that i need to
ensure that i kind of enable this jnlp
port so let me try to find out where is
that let me try this
okay yes
agents and by default this jlp agent's
thing would be disabled so if you see
here there's a small help on this
so i'm going to use this jnlp which is
nothing but java network launch protocol
and you know i'll configure the master
and server to talk to each other using
jlp so for that i need to enable this
guide so i enable this guy instead of
making the by default the configuration
was disabled so i make him random i make
him you know enabled and i say save this
configuration
all right so now configured or i made a
setting for the master
so that the jlp
port is kind of opened up so let me go
ahead and you know create an agent
so i'll go to manage nodes so if you see
here there's only one master here so let
me provision a new node here so this is
the way you know in which you bring up a
new node you have to configure it on the
server jenkins would put in some sort of
security around this particular
agent and let you know how to launch
this particular engine so that he can
connect your jenkins master so i would
say new node i would give a name for my
node i would say windows
node because both of these are windows
only so that's fine i just give an
identifier saying that windows note i
would say this is a permanent agent i'll
say okay
so if you see the name let me just copy
this name here with the description
number of executors since it's a slave
node and both of these are running on my
system i will keep the number of
executors as one
that's fine remote root directory now
this is where let me just clarify this
since i have both my
my master is running on my c drive c
drive program files 86
or not 86
c column program files
it is indeed 86
all right jenkins so this is where my
master is running so i don't want the c
drive what i'll do is i'll use something
called as a drive i have another drive
in my system but please visualize this
like you know you're running this on a
separate system altogether so i create a
folder here called jenkins node and this
is where i'm going to place my or i'm
going to provision my slave
and i'm going to run him from here so
this is the directory in which i'm going
to provision my slave node so i'm going
to copy this here and that is the remote
root directory of your particular agent
or slave so i just copied here the label
you know probably this is fine for me
and usage
how do you want to use this guy
so i would don't want him to run all
kinds of jobs i will only build jobs
with label expressions that match this
particular node and so this is the label
of this node so in order for somebody to
kind of delegate any task to them they
will have to specify this particular
label
so imagine this way if i have a bunch of
windows system i name it as windows star
anything that says from windows i can
give a regular expression and say that
anything that matches windows run this
particular task there if i have some mac
machines i name all these mac agents as
a mac star or something like that and i
can delegate all tasks you know saying
that start with whatever starts with mac
this node run the mac jobs there
so you identify a node using the label
and then delegate the task there
all right so launch method you know we
will use java web start because we're
going to
maybe we're going to use jnlp protocol
okay that sounds good directory i think
nothing else is required availability
yes we'll keep this agent yep online as
much as possible that sounds good all
right let me save this
all right i'm just provisioning this
particular node now
so if i click on this node i get a bunch
of commands along with an agent.jar
so this is the agent.jar that has to be
taken down to the other machine or the
slave node and from there i need to run
this along with a small security
credential so let me copy this whole
[Music]
text here in my notepad
not bad plus plus is good for me
okay i copy this whole
path there i also want to download this
agent.jar
i would say yes
this agent.jar is the one that is
configured by our server so all the
details that is required for launching
this agent.jar is found in this uh sorry
for launching this agent is found as
agent.jar so typically i need to
take this jar file onto the other system
and then kind of run it from there so
i have this alien.jar i copy this or i
cut this i come back to my folder my
jenkins node i paste it here
okay so now with this provisional.jar
and i need to use this whole command
control a control c and then launch this
particular agent so let me
bring up a command prompt right here
and then launched it so i'm saying in
the same folder where there is agent.jar
i'm going to launch this a particular
agent java hyphen jar agent.jar jnlp
this is the url of my server in case the
server and client are in different
locations or different ips let us
specify the ipad as all this anyway
would show up
and then the secret and you know the
root folder of your jenkins or the slave
node
okay
so
something ran and then you know it says
it's connected very well it seems to
have connected very well so let me come
back to my
jenkins instance
and see you know if you told me you see
earlier this was not connected let me
refresh this guy
okay now these two guys are connected
provision a jenkins node and then i
copied all the credentials or the
slave.jar along with the launch code and
then took it to the other system and
kind of
ran it from there since i don't have
another system i've just got a separate
directory in another folder another
drive and i'm launching the agent from
here as long as this particular agent is
up and running or this command prompt is
up and running the agent would be
connected so once i close this the
connection goes down
all right so successfully you've
launched this particular agent now this
would be the home directory of this
jenkins node orthogen can slave so any
task that i'm going to delegate to this
particular slave would all be run here
it will create a workspace right here
all right so good
so let me just
come back and let me kind of put up a
new task here i will say that you know
delegate job is good i say freestyle
project i'm going to create a very very
simple job here
i don't want it to connect to gate or
anything like that let me just create a
very very simple
echo
delegate to the
slave obligated to i don't like the word
slave delegate it to
agent
put this way
all right so delegated to agent sounds
good now how am i going to ensure that
this particular job
runs on the agent or on the slave that i
have configured
right you see this if at all you
remember how we provisioned our
particular slave we give a label
right so now i'm going to put in a job
that will only match this particular
label
so i'm going to say that whatever
matches this you know windows label run
this job on that particular node so we
have only one node that's matching this
in a windows node so this job will be
delegated out there so i save this
and let me build this
this is again a very very simple job
there's nothing in this i just want to
demonstrate how to kind of delegate it
to an agent so if you see this
it runs successfully
and where is the workspace
the workspace is right inside our
jenkins node it created a new workspace
delegated job it put in here so my old
or my primary master
job is in sql
program files under jenkins and this is
the slave job that was successfully run
very very simple but very very powerful
concept of master slave configuration or
distributed build and jenkins
okay approaching the final section where
we've done all this hard work in
bringing up our jenkins server
configuring it putting up some jobs on
it creating users and all this stuff now
we don't want this configuration to kind
of go away we want a very nice way of
ensuring that we backup all this
configuration and in case there is any
failure hardware crash or a machine
crash we would want to kind of restore
from the existing configuration that we
kind of backed up
so one quick way to do that would be or
one dirty way to do that would be just
you know take a complete backup of our
colon program files colon jenkins
directory because that's where our whole
jenkins configuration is present but we
don't want to do that let's use some
plugins for taking up a backup so let me
go to manage in cans
and click on available
and let me search for some back there
are a bunch of backup plugins so i would
recommend one of these plugins that i
specifically use
so this is the backup plugin so let me
go ahead and install this plugin
all right so we went ahead and installed
this plugin
so let me come back to my
manage plugins
so this plugin is there
so
hang on backup manager so you will see
this option once you install this plugin
so first time i can you know do a setup
i would say backup this particular i'll
give a folder uh this folder is
pertaining to the folder where i want
jenkins to backup some data
and i would say the format should be zip
format is good enough let me give a name
or a template or a file name for my
you know backup this is good i want it
in verbose mode i don't want to shut on
my jenkins or should i shut it down no
okay one thing that you got to remember
is that whenever a backup happens if
there are too many jobs that is running
on the server
it can kind of slow down your jenkins
instance because it's it's in the
process of copying a few of those things
and the files are being changed at that
moment it's little bit problematic for
jenkins so typically you back up your
servers only when there is very less
load or typically try to you know bring
it to a shutdown kind of a state and
then take a backup
all right so i'm going to back up all
these things you know i don't want to
exclude anything else i want the history
i want the maven artifacts
possibly i don't want this guy i would
just say save
and then i would say
back him up
so this would run a bunch of you know
steps and all the files that is required
as a part of this is pretty fast but
then if at all you have too many things
up on your server for now we didn't have
too many things up on our server but in
case you had too many things to kind of
backup this may take a while so let me
just pause this
recording and get back to you once the
backup is complete so there you go the
backup was successful
created a backup of all the workspace
the configurations the users and you
know all that so all this is kind of
hidden down in this particular
zip file so at any instance if at all i
kind of crash my system for some
instance or say hard disk failure and i
bring up a new instance of jenkins i can
kind of use the backup plugin for
restoring this particular
configurations
so how do i do that i just come back to
my manager cans
come back to backup manager and i will
say restore her that's an or
jenkins configuration
welcome everyone to another tutorial on
selenium webdriver in which we are going
to talk about what exactly is in
selenium and why exactly we are going to
use the selenium web driver here
now uh in this one there are different
topics which we are going to talk about
let's go through that what first we are
going to talk about what exactly is
selenium all about because that's a
basic topic which we need to cover
then uh we will be talking about what is
the purpose of uh using selenium web
driver in which which situations we can
actually use the selenium whip driver
here
and then we are going to talk about
these the selenium webdriver framework
the framework which is specifically
designed for the selenium web driver the
various drawbacks of the selenium drip
driver and ultimately at the last we
will be talking about a demonstration
over here which is all about the
selenium webdriver like how exactly uh
we can make use of a web driver a
selenium web driver in action which can
help us to go for some uh
real time executions or sometimes some
test scenarios uh opening up some
website or doing some execution so all
that stuff is what we are going to talk
about in this whole tutorial over here
now coming back to the main topic so
let's start with the what exactly is a
selenium here
now software automation uh is something
which is a kind of a
minimum requirement every organization
is having nowadays because they were
doing a lot of stuff manually in the
previous situations and it was consuming
a lot of time but until then we were not
having the frameworks like selenium
which was giving the
users or the cure the automation
engineers a whole total a different
exposure there now
testing is always an important part of a
software development here it's it's
something which
gives a very a
high level of value add-ons to overall
exposure or the overall sdlc cycle here
without the software testing it's not
possible for an organization to release
its source code till production
environment and it makes sense also
because the testing is very important
even nowadays if we have to procure a
new car or a vehicle we basically go for
a test drive now this is something which
we are using because of the fact that
we want to experience the exposure there
like how
in real time we can see the vehicle in
action whether all my requirements is
getting fulfilled or not so you have
your own parameters everyone have its
own parameters so you just want to
address those parameters and want to see
that if this product is something which
can take care of all your requirements
or not so that's something keeping in
mind software testing is very important
and whether it's a manual whether it's
an automated testing in both the cases
it's very important for the software yes
over the period of time the organization
felt that manual testing is actually uh
is not efficient as compared to the
automation testing secondly it takes a
lot of time of the end users to do that
uh different processing and you know any
kind of uh
you know test scenarios if he wants to
execute he wants to go ahead with that
so that's something which takes a lot of
time but in case of the automation test
cases we have lot of frameworks which
can help us to drive like how the
implementation should be done so keeping
in mind selenium is one of the tool
which is available there and the whole
focus of selenium is to provide a
framework or provide an automation which
can generate a quite efficient uh
results for you and results these
results which we are talking about these
results are something which we are
talking about like how exactly we are
getting the high level of efficiency so
when we are talking about selenium so it
gives us a lot of benefits and a lot of
exposure
so um you talking about the websites
when we talk about websites we deal like
okay um you know if i have to validate
my website i have to do the login i have
to access the application so that's how
i will be doing the verification but
with the help of selenium kind of
frameworks we don't have to do these
things manually anymore we have this
automation tool which can help us to
drive the things uh it will
automatically open the browser go to the
specific website put some inputs
clicking on some buttons generating the
responses and taking up the actions so
ultimately it will help you to drive
each and everything from the beginning
to the end
most of the organizations after the
deployment actually have written the
test cases like the sanity testing and
the smoke testing in case of the
selenium like a particular selenium test
cases will be executing it will try to
validate it if the application is
working fine as expected or not just try
to you know have a kind of a brief uh
overview or you can say like
introduction here like this so and so
steps you have to execute this one so uh
procedure you have to execute to follow
a complete procedure or complete
automation here so keeping in mind
selenium is one of the open source tool
which is available there for this
purpose of writing the test cases test
automation there
any kind of web portal can be easily
verified and tested along with the help
of selenium
it's something uh which can be
created like the test scripts can be
easily created across different
programming languages it's not like
since selenium is written in the java
programming language so you can only uh
use this one for the java programming
language it's not like that it's pretty
generic which means like any programming
languages if you feel you want to use
you can use a selenium for that so it's
having the compatibility with the java c
shaft python a variety of applications
uh programming languages can be used
with the help of selenium so it doesn't
mean like you are only stuck with one
language so uh it helps you to gain the
benefits also because once you are
comfortable selenium then pretty much
any programming languages you can
automate and if you see like most of the
automation engineers are actually having
the understanding of selenium only
because this gives them the comfort that
with this one single programming
language they will be able to handle
like all the different programming
languages uh related work whether it's a
c sha whether it's a.net it's a java a
node.js or any kind of programming
language is there so selenium is having
the comfort or is having the
compatibility with that also uh in case
of selenium it's not only about one test
cases we can pretty much create test
suits like heavy test suits uh you can
create the regulation test suits you can
create the uat test source you can
create the sanity testing or the smoke
testing kind of test source so there are
different kind of uh test suits which
you can create here now these test suits
actually have a bunch of test cases
integrated like it's not only about one
test case or it's not only about two
test cases it's kind of a bunch of test
cases which we are trying to create with
the help of selenium so selenium is
something in which we basically create a
multiple uh test cases it's a
combination of multiple test cases all
together into a single one so that's
what we call it as a kind of selenium
test suit here right now the selenium
test suit is comprising of four
different tools here the very first one
is the selenium remote control
second one is the selenium grid then we
got selenium ide and ultimately at last
we have the selenium whip driver so
these are the four different tools which
we got over here with the moment we talk
about this selenium suit here
now let's talk about this selenium web
driver because that's the whole focus of
this uh
content over here to see like what
exactly is the selenium web driver and
how we can go ahead with that
so coming back to the selenium web
driver so here uh selenium webdriver is
one of the most important component of
the selenium test suite
when we talk about the selenium uh tools
suit over here like we talk about okay i
want to create a whole together
regression test suit so selenium web
driver is very important component for
that
and when we talk about the selenium web
driver it allows the cross browser
compatibility which means like you want
to test your applications you can have a
test suit there one for the chrome
browser one for the firefox one for the
internet explorer you can then say like
okay i want to test and validate my
application across all these three
browsers and in future if safari browser
comes in all you have to do is like you
have to just run the same script
with the web driver of the safari so
this web driver is not only static for
one browser it's actually
approachable for across multiple
browsers there so that enhances the
compatibility there that yes this set
test suit even if you're writing the
test suits in case of selenium it's not
limited to one browser so it's kind of a
cross browser here
so these are small small benefits
although we're talking about the
selenium web driver here but if you
closely see these all points are
actually defining why exactly the
selenium is best uh when we talk about
the web
automations or the web testing
automation here
right and then it's actually supporting
various programming languages like uh
programming languages yes it's there
it's even supporting with different
browsers and then of course it's
supporting different operating systems
also
because you can pretty much run these
test cases uh onto linux macs or windows
whatever the platform you feel like you
want to use you can pretty much use it
so you don't have to worry about like
where exactly this web driver is getting
deployed and from where you are trying
to refer it so that kind of
compatibility is also something which is
available here so you don't have to
think about the uh specific different uh
versions or the different operating
systems as such over here and then let's
talk about
further on this one so it also provides
the compatibility across different
programming languages so you can see
like what are the different benefits you
got you got benefits like uh you know
it's it's supporting different
programming languages it's supporting
different browsers and ultimately at
last it's supporting the different uh
particular uh operating systems or the
platforms here so these are small small
things like different uh benefits which
we get with the help of selenium here
and uh it's it's having the support
across different programming languages
so
it doesn't matter that if you're working
with java or if you're working with net
this is going to work for across a
different different platforms like
different uh
environments you can actually deploy so
these benefits are something which can
definitely help you to see like how the
overall uh benefits can be achieved over
here
and uh definitely the chrome browsers
are the safari the firefox the oprah
different uh platforms you will be able
to see like how the execution needs to
be done and how the setup used to be
performed here so that's where the
complete uh implementations uh needs to
be performed here right and uh these web
driver provides a faster execution of
the test scripts uh because that's uh
the kind of uh automation which we are
looking forward that we are not trying
to see like how the systems can be
implemented so when we are trying to
talk about the automation here so these
web drivers basically help us to go for
the faster execution also so it's not
only about uh that we are trying to see
the setup like we are trying to go for
the configurations here it's also like
the performance and the efficiency which
we're getting with this one is quite
beneficial so you can get an easy and a
faster execution of the test cases
so it's it's having a lot of benefits if
we talk about in these features only
itself you can see like there are a lot
of benefits which we got over here so
it's fast it's efficient and on top of
that it's
not depending on any kind of environment
it's quite generic like you know it's
something which you can use for windows
you can use it for linux you want to use
it for dotnet you want to use it for
java it's kind of uh
chandrick for a lot of technologies
platforms and programming languages
right now why exactly we require the uh
selenium web driver like what is the
purpose of using this one so let's
explore on that part here so selenium
fib driver provides a user friendly
interface that could uh you know it can
be easily understood by a particular
person like when we uh when you're using
this uh selenium web driver so this is
something which you can easily
understood like it's pretty easy for you
to understand that and it's not that
much complex for you to understand that
okay you are going to take a lot of time
to
consume you're going to take a lot of
time to
uh you know understand that so that's
not a kind of interface which we are
getting when we talk of the uh selenium
web driver here right and uh the web
driver is something which is having uh
much more uh features as compared to the
uh selenium rc and selenium ide there so
when we talk about the uh selenium web
driver so this is something which is
having uh much more features as compared
to the other components like you know
these the other components is also about
the selenium only but yes the when we
talk about selenium uh web drivers so
it's having
much more features as compared to the
selenium rc and the selenium id here
so you don't have to worry about the
features like altogether selenium uh
driver is something which is quite
efficient and better as compared to the
other components so that's another
benefit which we get with the selenium
here
so selenium uh
we have got some other components like a
selenium remote control here so uh rc is
something which enables uh the creation
of uh you know automated web
applications like uh in in case of
programming languages such as java
c-sharp uh node.js different different
programming languages are there so we
can pretty much uh use the remote
control uh selenium remote control over
here which will enable the uh the
creation of the automated web
applications there so that's the purpose
of using the selenium remote control
here it's uh it's not something which is
being used nowadays because most of the
functionalities have nowadays moved on
to the uh
selenium driver here so that's a
migration which has happened over there
and that's the reason why we are not
going to use
much of the
selenium remote control over here so
that's not being used as such as
compared to the other components but yes
the selenium web driver is something
which is quite popular and because of
its features and the efficiency we are
going to use of the particular uh
browse the uh web driver as compared to
the any other component as such here
right now selenium ide um needs not
additional any kind of setup is required
like uh you know apart from installation
of the browser because uh in that case
everything will be integrated in that
like because we are using we are
integrating the complete uh selenium ide
over here so all you need to do is like
you need to do the installation of
chrome browser that's also because you
want to
go for the specific
chrome driver which you require for the
execution of the test cases so for that
only you are basically trying to install
the chrome browser but other than that
there is no other component which you
actually require when we talk about the
selenium ide here
so
the ide makes the life easy because it
helps us to go ahead with the debugging
mode here like a kind of a debugging
environment you will be able to do that
so even if there is any kind of issue
any any kind of problem which comes up
so it will be very easy for you to debug
those things and go ahead with that part
so uh tracking the exceptions managing
the exception so all those things can be
easily handled with the help of the
selenium ide here so selenium ide is
something which is kind of a bigger
package which is uh further comprising
of different different components like
it's something which is giving us a
variety of things here
right now how exactly the uh selenium
whip driver is at all different from the
selenium rc and ide because those are
also the solution which is available
there from this lane now unlike the
selenium ide selenium webdriver can
actually work with different browsers so
that's something which we have already
focused on that it's having the
compatibility across multiple
uh browsers there that's the first
benefit which we get over here in this
one now also the web drivers is
something which does not require any
user to start the server or anything
like that there so just in case of a
selenium rc you have to start some
server because you're ultimately
connecting to that server and that's how
the communication is happening but that
kind of stuff is not there in the uh
selenium uh web driver here
also this selenium web driver is an api
and it's not a gui based plugin so uh
it's it's something which can easily
handle like uh it's having the um quite
efficient uh connectivity or you can say
like the uh integration is also good
there because we most of the
applications nowadays are working on the
api format which is pretty generic so
with there is no gui based interface
which we have to explore or which we
need to integrate here so it's all like
the api is called which we need to do in
order to use uh make use of the selenium
web driver here
now in selenium webdriver the apis are
entirely object oriented in nature as
compared to the selenium rc and selenium
id so which is not a kind of object
oriented in nature but selenium
webdriver is something which is quite
object oriented here also
web driver the selenium web driver is
actually supports multiple
listeners right so uh which is available
there as compared to selenium rc and
selenium id here so these are some
couple of features which is available
there also it also supports the testing
of the ios and android which is not
being supported in the
rc and ide there because most of the
applications uh nowadays also have the
counterpart android or the ios
applications so if you don't have the
interface or integration with those
platforms then it's a incomplete way of
testing here so not only the web
applications but even the mobile
applications also now getting integrated
with the help of the selenium web driver
here so these kind of features which is
not exactly available in the rc or the
id over here but definitely it's it's
going to be available there in case of
selenium web driver so what exactly is
the overall need of the web driver like
this lyrium web driver here so
let's talk about that that how exactly
we can use it for the software
automation here so there are a couple of
benefits which is available there so
let's focus on that one by one the very
first one is the open source now it's
something which is available or which is
uh available as an open source over here
which means like uh it's something which
you can use uh without any license
without any cost uh just like that you
can go to the selenium.dev website and
you can start downloading the
selenium related uh
deals or selenium related components
second is multilingual support it's
having the support for different kind of
programming languages not only for the
java based applications it's actually
supporting like different different
programming languages so you just have
to learn one single tool and then can
some eyes or that can support multiple
programming languages here several
operating system support yes it's not
only related to the windows or linux
platform here so it's actually supported
across
windows linux macos different operating
systems are actually supported here so
different suppor operating systems is
supported by this particular selenium
here uh multiple frameworks are there so
that's a multiple framework support
which is available in this one uh user
friendly it's quite user friendly there
and the developers were more comfortable
with the java programming languages so
they get uh quite uh comfortable and
integrated with the
selenium because it's also using the
same java syntax over here in this one
um it's cross device testing uh
definitely both mobile desktops are
different platforms different operating
systems mac os uh ios android different
uh platforms are actually supported by
this uh particular selenium here so
selenium web driver is something which
is having like cross device testing here
community support is there it's kind of
open source yes but it's having a very
good community like a lot of people are
actually there
who can contribute to this selenium you
can get the information from there and
it's kind of a huge efforts like a kind
of a huge community efforts which you
can
see over here in this case
also a compatibility testing so it's
having a very good compatibility here so
uh when you're working with this uh
selenium so it's compatible with pretty
much any programming languages any
platform any operating system so that
kind of
benefits you get with the help of this
selenium web driver here
and uh
unlike uh selenium rc you don't have to
start any kind of server component here
uh which you need to connect so it's
like uh on demand like when you're
running the scripts a kind of a local
chrome browser will be initialized
and your test cases will be executed and
performed and that that's how the whole
executions will be performed there so
there is no inward like you have to go
somewhere start some server start
somewhere remote server there and then
the communication or the execution of
the test cases will be initialized so
it's not like that kind of communication
here
right so let's talk about the uh web
driver
architecture here now in this one there
are some different components which is
available there in this architecture
components the very first one is the
selenium language bindings here now
these are actually available in
different different programming
languages like java ruby python c sharp
javascript these are the different
programming languages bindings which is
available there then with the help of
json wire protocol these are going to be
connected to the different drivers now
browser drivers is the one where exactly
the request will be sent out so the
selenium web driver is actually going to
connect or send the request to this
drivers
so um depending on the platform also and
depending on the different uh
systems you can actually go for the
browser drivers here so you want to go
for chrome driver you want to go for
firefox you want to go for opera you
want to go for safari these are the
different browsers which is available
there earlier the
internet explorer was also there but now
in the latest version see it uh each
browser or h driver is something which
is available there
and uh these are going to be connected
to the actual uh particular browsers
like the chrome firefox and all so it
will be sending the request over the
http uh http uh that request will be
sent out to the real drivers so the
browser drivers and then the real
drivers will be there so the web driver
is going to connect to the chrome driver
and then in fact from there the chrome
driver is going to initialize the chrome
browser and then the whole request will
be processed the
websites will be open the clicking the
access everything will be done after
that on that case
so these are the different uh
steps which is involved when we are
basically going for uh from one step to
another like where the communications or
will be performed over here in this case
right so uh again uh it's not dependent
on any programming languages it's not
dependent on any kind of
browser or any kind of components here
so
right from the uh language bindings it
will go to the json wire protocol from
there it will be sent out to the browser
drivers various browser drivers whatever
the browser drivers you want to use you
can use that and then those drivers are
actually going to connect with the real
drivers or with the real
browsers over here so that the
communications or the
exact end result you should be able to
see
so
for instance if you run a particular
chrome browser uh chrome driver there so
you will be able to see like a chrome
browser getting initialized and the
website is getting accessible so all
that activity will be happened or will
be performed over there so these are the
parts of the sequence these are kind of
architecture components like one to
another these will be processed or these
will be executed here right so uh these
programming language these selenium
programming languages again it's
actually a kind of a generic one so
these are the client libraries which is
available there depending on this one
for example for java i can download some
binaries i can download some jar files
so that will be referenced or utilized
into my source code for ruby it's maybe
like different uh third party libraries
or shared libraries which will be
available there for python it will be
available in the form of modules uh c
sharp javascript so each and every
programming languages is actually having
its own uh
libraries now these libraries are
actually required so that we can get the
whole interface of the selenium it's
okay like i am writing some test cases
i'm writing the complete test sort and
i'm using it but unless and until i
import my selenium libraries it will not
work for me i will not be able to work
on that part because i will not be able
to get those features as such in order
to get those features i need to download
these bindings or these kind of
language bindings there corresponding to
my programming language and these are
easily available on the selenium website
so if you go to the selenium website
whatever the programming languages you
want to follow you can download these
findings these windings will be nothing
but the archives where you will be
having some kind of executables
depending on that programming language
right now from there uh we will be using
our libraries like these bindings in
order to interact in order to initialize
the selenium so then we will be going to
the json wire protocol so it's kind of a
connector between the libraries and the
web drivers
now uh programically uh using these with
the help of these uh client libraries
we're going to send the request to the
web drivers it also helps to enable the
transfer of data between a server and
client
because of course you have to
uh get your end result process right so
that's where you need to go for the
execution so what you're going to do is
like you're going to see like okay i'm
going to run or i'm going to execute
this uh json wire protocol over here and
it's going to connect between my client
libraries and the web drivers here so
that's the communications and the
connectivity which we want to establish
or we want to provide here now these are
selenium browser drivers are actually
specific browsers now because
the json wire is going to connect to the
specific
browsers the drivers here so that the
communication can be happen
now uh these drivers are actually used
uh as in drivers in order to interact
with the exact browser because these are
not the exact browser now if you
want to interact with the chrome then
you definitely have to use the chrome
driver if you want to use for the
fireworks then you have to use the
firefox driver so depending on the
programming language you have to define
like which driver you really need to
process or you need to really go ahead
with that part so that's where the
selenium browser drivers really comes
into the picture
and then uh the
exact browsers will be there now once
the
executions will be done at last you will
be able to see like all these browsers
getting open if you're going to use the
chrome browser then chrome browser will
be initialized if you're using the
firefox then the firefox browser will be
initialized so whatever the browser or
driver specific driver you will utilize
so according to that you will see a
particular browser being invoked over
here
so that's how the communication happens
and it's kind of a sequence here like
step by step here
so each and every stage is very
important because that's how the uh
communication will happen over here
and you will get the end result or the
desired output if you uh have any kind
of uh failing component over here so
that's where the whole connectivity will
be breakdown and you will not be able to
get any kind of values x expected so
this is something which we really need
to consider or we need to go ahead with
that part here
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
so what are the different drawbacks
which we got with the help of the
selenium web driver here so when we talk
about the selenium web drivers so what
are the different drawbacks which we are
getting over here so that we can
understand like how exactly we can talk
about that part here
now the drawbacks of uh selenium
webdriver is something which we uh you
know use because
this is kind of uh uh main component you
can say like you know using which you
can actually do the complete validation
but the problem is that it's not
something which you can use for the
desktop application so for the desktop
application this does not works so this
web driver is something which is
supported for the web applications only
it's not something which we can use for
the desktop applications as such so
that's a kind of a limitation which we
get with the help of the selenium
webdriver here so it's only there for
the websites for the web portals
secondly uh the uh it requires the
expertise of the teams uh you know in
order to manage these scripts because
these are the programming languages of
course there although it's a test suit
but uh it requires a programming
language efforts as such in order to go
ahead with that in order to manage these
things
so it requires a kind of expert team uh
who can actually handle these scripts or
who can work on these requirements
so uh that's a kind of a overhead
because if it's not like very easy to
manage these like uh pretty much a
person who is an expert in these things
can only handle these kind of
requirements so
it's kind of a limitation where we will
be only depending on an expert to manage
these scripts as such right
now um it's not having any kind of uh
reporting builder reporting capability
over here so it's not available in this
one so test reports which is getting
generated here is uh with the help of
the junit and test ng so there is no
default reporting mechanism which is
available over here in this one so we
only have the mechanism of the junit
like we can extend our
test scripts in selenium by integrating
with jh unit and the test ng here
so that we will be able to get a proper
reporting so for the uh reporting
purposes we actually use the components
like this junit and the test ng over
here to go ahead with that
so these are the ways in which we can
actually go for the integration where we
can integrate the selenium and the other
frameworks like junit and the uh test ng
kind of components here
and that's the whole basis because
alone the selenium webdriver is
something which can execute the scripts
process the request but it's not going
to handle any kind of uh reporting
mechanism so reporting mechanism is
something which you can only get with
the help of the junit or the test uh ng
here because these are the additional
packages which you need to integrate so
it's it's a kind of a custom solution
which we need to design uh you know
where we don't have only the web driver
will available over here like the core
components but also we have like other
components available over there which
will be of course having the other
components like distance g and the j
unit here so that's also something which
you can integrate all together with this
one right also uh it's very difficult to
manage there is a lot of management or
the maintenance activity which we get
over here
also it's very difficult to scale this
up also depending on the load or
depending on the requirement it's very
difficult to scale it up also if you are
using for some infrastructure some kind
of a load there so having it increased
to a different level is kind of a
difficult task here
also maintenance activity is quite huge
so if you want to have a proper
maintenance or management you have to
get a couple of uh
you know experts in that case so that
they can easily manage those things so
these are the different uh requirements
which is available there where we can
see like how exactly the uh we can you
know manage all these things
now it also uh you know allows the
across
browser compatibility testing here so
it's something which can easily handle
like different requests across the
browsers
so um image testing is not available so
uh you don't have to uh you know use the
selenium alone like selenium alone is
not compatible for testing the images
here so if you really want to test the
images so you have to
equally uh in with your selenium so that
you can have a complete package so again
uh selenium in some cases it's not
sufficient for like most or a variety of
things there so in some cases you have
to actually
go for another tool integrations so that
you can have the complete details you
can have the complete component here
so that's where the uh real mechanism
comes in like yes uh you don't have the
exact single tool available for taking
care of all these things but yes you can
have all these things integrated with
the other tools other components there
and from there you will be able to get a
complete uh values and the complete uh
implementation here
right so these are the um you know
different uh drawbacks which we get once
we start using the a web driver here so
let's go ahead uh with the uh particular
demo over here to understand like how
exactly the uh selenium web driver can
be utilized can be used so that we will
be able to run some test scripts here so
we are going to run or prepare a test
suit here so that we can get it executed
with the help of selenium so that's what
we are trying to do here so for this one
we require some couple of components to
be there like the jdk eclipse and all so
let's talk about that component so let's
go ahead with the implementation
so let's begin with the uh
configurations of this webdriver here
now the very first thing which we
require is that we require to the
installation of the
java here now let's uh go ahead with
this url so now this one is something
where we have to see like how uh we can
go for the installation of the jdk here
now here we need to go for the jdk
installation that's the version which we
want to install now it a variety of
versions are available there like which
version you want to install you can go
with that um jdk 11 8 it is the most
stable version so you can go ahead with
the jdk eight here so you can download
here
different platforms it's available like
windows platform uh whatever the
platform is there all you need to do is
like you need to just download this exe
file now once the exe file is downloaded
so what happens like you will be able to
do the installation now i have done the
installation of this jdk here so if i
have to open my uh command prompt here i
would be easily able to see that i'm
using a jdk version
of
1.8.0 over here in this one so that's a
version which i'm using but again of
course if you're using some different
version of cdk that will also work here
the only thing is that you need to see
that you need to go for a compatible
browser
a compatible uh
java and the compatible eclipse tool
here so that's what you require now what
i'm going to do is like i'm going to
install or download the eclipse browser
also now let's download the eclipse here
now we got an official website of
eclipse here from where we can download
the exact clips
different platform you can do it like
this is the one which is available there
now you can click on download this one
so that will help you to download the
eclipse here
so uh here the uh download will work
just like that you can do the download
here even if you want to go for a
different offerings like you want to go
for different platform uh
you feel like you want to decide that
which package actually you need to do
because uh in the eclipse also you got
like different things
um id eclipse ide for the java
developers for uh the c plus c plus plus
so different uh different uh operating
system and different uh packages are
also available there so it's basically
up to you like which exactly environment
you want to follow
so i want to download this uh 64 bit
over here in this one so let's download
this here
now uh let's again download this this is
kind of a exe file which is available
here so let's download it again
now um
it will be working on like uh it's kind
of a download which is getting started
over here it's close to 102 mb which is
available there this is the executable
which is going to help us to do the
installation of eclipse now this is the
uh latest version our 2020 version is
what it is getting installed over here
and uh it's completely there i have
already got the jdk installed because of
the fact that using this jdk the eclipse
will be open if you don't have the jdk
installed the java runtime then the
eclipse will not be installed for you so
uh in order to get the eclipse uh
installed and executable perfectly fine
you need uh the jdk installed to be done
here so we got like one more minute here
to complete the download and this is
just 102 mb package or installer which
is available there and once this is
installed we will be able to get ahead
with this installation of the eclipse
here so once the eclipse is installed
all you can do is like you can go ahead
with the uh particular configurations
you can create some couple of cro uh
projects in case of eclipse um then
we'll also see like how we can download
the
programming languages binding so that
also we are going to download so these
are the different components which
you're going to explore while working on
this one so uh let's wait for this uh
download of this executable to be
performed here so that we will be able
to proceed further with this one so
let's wait for that so it's hardly
taking one minute more to complete it
so selenium and eclipse both are the
open source one you're getting a donate
to a class community page there because
that's the donation which they want but
again you can use it like 100 open
source and free of cost here so you
don't have to pay any cost as such over
here in this case so there is no cost
associated with this one
so just 10 seconds more and uh then we
can pursue with the installation of the
eclipse here and here we go so the
installer is almost done here so i can
pretty much go ahead and
open the file so this will help me to do
the installation of the eclipse here so
the eclipse installer is what it's
getting started initialized over here in
this one
uh now the java runtime is already
available with me we require the uh
specific
uh jdk installed the java command line
is working we can download the eclipse
here
and
then we can go for the uh specific
executions like we can go and uh
download the uh browser drivers here now
the thing is that if you really want to
go for the chrome browser or firefox or
any kind of those things in case of your
particular system in case of your
windows machine over here
you don't have to necessarily go for any
kind of uh a kind of a driver as such
here because of the fact we got a links
over here like uh this mozilla for the
firefox uh this one is there for the uh
particular selenium this one is there
for the chrome now chrome is something
which we have already got here like we
have already got the chrome browser
installed
but let's see like uh we can download
this driver also like uh depending on
that we can go ahead with that part and
then we can also download the java
client uh libraries over there from the
bindings over there from the
specific selenium.dev website over there
and we can download and we can integrate
it so let's do it one by one so first of
all let's see like you know once the
installation of the eclipse is done and
then we'll be able to go ahead with the
third component or the third request
which is the a web driver or a
particular chrome browser a driver over
here so this installer is going to give
us the same thing here so i'm going for
the
uh specific java developer here so let's
go for the installation here now this is
going to uh install uh the uh java 8
right uh this runtime over here so uh if
you feel like you want to use the jdk 11
because that's something which is
available there now if you're using an
existing ones like uh you're already
using uh an existing once over here the
jdk and all so uh that's where the
installation is going on like uh it's
it's going in with that part here but
we already got some system related uh
jdks which is installed but uh you feel
like you want to go ahead with this one
um like you're not doing the separate
installation of the jdk or jre so there
you can actually use this once here
so let's select this one like i pretty
much want to use like any one of these
jvms over here like which i feel like i
can configure or i can utilize so that's
pretty much we can do here so it's like
uh we can use these variables like we
can go for these jvms or if you feel
like you can go for an external jvm also
there so it all depends on you like how
the uh installation you want to perform
here
right and this is the location let's uh
go for the desktop location there
and or you can go for the default
location also over here in this one
so let's go for the installation now
just accept it and uh the installation
will be proceeded over here so
uh even if you have not done a separate
jtech installation so this will
basically have a jdk installed i have
selected the java 11 over here uh but
you can go for the 15 also in this case
in this scenario so the whole
installation of the eclipse is what it's
happening over here
so once the eclipse is installed so then
we can pretty much go ahead with the
next component there which is like uh
dealing with the uh specific selenium
related components and chrome browser
again it's already something which is
installed there but we'll see like how
we can download the chrome driver how we
can configure and we can utilize that so
that's what we're going to follow here
so it's going for the installation and
uh it's something which we are trying to
do like uh it's
this installer is pretty much
downloading some couple of components as
such uh like this j uh
jre is something which is getting
installed or downloaded from the uh
eclipse website and uh that's where the
uh you know all the components is
getting installed so one by one all the
components will be downloaded
from the eclipse website here and it's a
complete package which means like you
don't have to necessarily go for a
separate installation there is another
installer which is available for eclipse
where you just have to unzip up for a
zip file and you can pretty much use it
but in this case
this is something which is having all
these things integrated all together
inside that so that's an another
component which is being available here
so the installation is still going on
there
so uh it depends because all these
things are getting cached up from the
internet so it also depends on like how
much size of file is getting downloaded
here
so let's uh you know let's uh wait for
the installations to be complete and
then we'll proceed further
so now the installation is done so we
can launch our eclipse here so that's
what we are trying to launch here now
apart from eclipse what happens like we
require some other components also like
uh we require this lyrium web driver
also there so for that we have to
download the uh java related client
bindings so for that uh chrome browser
first of all it's already installed so
we don't have to do any kind of
installation there uh yes i can go ahead
with the exe file like of the chrome
browser driver that i'm going to use it
so i'm going to open the uh specific
downloads here now in this segment what
happens like selenium.dev is the website
which is available there now here we can
go for the downloads now related to your
programming language whatever the
programming language you are trying to
use so you can download the language
binding for that now language binding is
something which is utilized so using
which you will be able to see like how
uh you can establish the connectivity
it's just a kind of a libraries where
you can do the connectivity and you can
see that execution
so what i'm going to do is like i'm
going to download this bindings here so
let's download this one now it's again
available as in zip file which is
available there so uh
depending on the version you can go for
the beta download version also and i'm
going for the stable version which we
want to utilize we want to refer it so
it's going to download zip file so this
zip file will have all the jar files and
all the required libraries there
and when i'm going to create a project
into my eclipse at that moment of time i
would be requiring all these components
like all these various uh libraries
should be added up into my uh project as
such in case of the eclipse so that's
what i need to do here so let's go to
the eclipse here
so here we're going to expand this like
a package
explorer and here we're going to go to
file
new and java project so i'm going to
create a java project over here so um
in which we will be getting some couple
of class files in which we will be
having the
selenium related test cases like how we
want to process or how we want to
execute that part so i'm going to
proceed with that part so uh let's put
the uh project name here so i'm going to
say like selenium
just a project name i want to put uh
then the jdk now uh if you want to go
for a specific jdk like another version
so you can go with that but right now
i'm using like jdk 1.8 which is pretty
much configured so i can use that
uh you feel like you want to use uh the
specific jre of uh
uh gre which is available as part of jdk
1.8 that also you can use or if you want
to use like a jdk so that also something
which you can utilize over here in this
one so there are different things like
you can configure the gres also so if
you have some custom path which uh where
you have the java available or the jdk
or jre is available there so that also
you can easily refer it so you can
simply say that yes this so and so
location i want to refer i want to see
my source code so that's where you can
do the you can go for the execution now
once you're providing these values like
the install gres which you want to
provide which you want to process here
next thing what you need to perform is
like you need to go ahead with that
execution so i'm completely okay with
the jdk whatever the environment i want
to process i can easily do that and i'm
completely okay with that
right so uh let's go with that part and
then click on next
and uh this is the source directory
which is available there right and if
you want to add any additional libraries
so uh here exactly you can add your a
selenium related libraries using which
you will be able to see your source code
working fine but i'm not going to do
that activity here so i'm going to do
that later on so that we can get our
complete things in a sequence
and then here we go like finish so you
will be able to get
the jr related libraries and the source
folder here so right now it's completely
empty project there is nothing available
as such here and what i'm going to do is
like i'm going to create a class file
over here to see to be the specific
source code of the selenium to how the
web driver is getting loaded up and
processed so that's stuff we are going
to talk about here so let's see like
what content we need to really put up
over here in this one now if we
downloaded this selenium
programming language bindings here so
let me extract it
uh you can pretty much keep it into the
eclipse folders also or if you wish you
can keep it aside in some specific
folder because it's just going to be
referenced with every project so it's
just kind of a shared release which is
available there so whatever project you
want to onboard you want to use so this
kind of a
package or this kind of share library
you can easily utilize and you can
implement it so we are just trying to
extract it now once extraction is done
so you will be able to see like some
couple of files and folders
uh now this is having a particular two
executable files like client embed
combined this is kind of connecting
acting like a selenium client and which
is using to connect and
process all the requirements
and we also have a sources file which is
available there for this one but again
uh it's something which depends on the
requirement so you don't have to put
these sources uh jar file also over here
because that's not required so you can
pretty much uh use this executable jar
file because in this one you will not
have any kind of source then of course
your selenium-related jar file is
further on depending on some
dependencies like this so these jar
files are also uh something which you
should be putting up into your uh
specific
uh
shared library so that your selenium
related jar files should not started
failing so uh we'll we'll try that
scenario also so that we can get the
complete output and complete insurance
here so let's see now uh we'll go to
this uh we'll import this particular
file over there and for that we have to
write a class file so let's see like how
we can do that so we have already got
the selenium web driver so
uh the eclipse is what we have followed
so we have created a new uh java project
now we want to create a new class file
the build path configurations we will be
taking care of that later on but right
now we are going to see like how we can
proceed further with that
so i i'm going with this uh specific
component here right so uh whatever the
browser or whatever the
driver you want to follow you can do
that so firefox if you want to use you
want to use our chrome browser it all
depends on you like it all depends on
the way that how you want to configure
it so uh let's see let's uh import this
uh particular component here now if the
uh specific uh
firefox browser is installed that's
great if it's not installed so you can
just go back here so here you will be
able to see like this browsers like
these specific components which is
available here
so this is the driver which is available
so for
the windows 64-bit you can again
download this one here
so whatever the platform you want uh
like if you want to use for the chrome
browser you can go for that if you want
to go for the firefox edge whatever the
driver you feel like you want to go you
can do go with that part here
so let's uh open this one here and
extract this one also so that we should
be able to refer it over here into our
specific source code so this is the
driver this is the exe file which is
available there now all we need to do is
like we need to just open our eclipse
there so in our eclipse
we should be using or we should be
referring to this one here so this is a
kind of a path which is available
similarly we will also be giving a path
over there so that uh we can refer to
that specific uh driver that driver over
here so let me open that and uh let's
see
so i'm going to create a class file here
you can create a package
uh called
calm
and uh in that package you can further
on create a class file
like
selenium
test
uh
it's also uh depends like this is just a
custom name so
uh you feel like you want to give some
different name you can uh
go for uh you know any kind of class
name over here but this is something
which is uh something we are going to
see like how the execution needs to be
performed and needs to be done here
so there are different uh you know names
like uh you want to follow some
different name you can do that also
now if you see closely here let me save
the file here now in this one you're
getting some errors uh related to this
one like you're getting the uh error
codes related to the imports here like
how the uh specific execution should be
done here right now the thing is that uh
this is something which is uh really
causing the problems uh like how the
import or the execution should be done
right
also uh the thing is that uh
we require these imports to be available
there right so uh that's definitely we
are requiring over here and uh that's
that's something which we uh
require uh we want to process as such
also so right now let's uh have an uh
particular declaration of the uh package
also there because it's something which
is there in the comp package so let's
have the package com also here so it's
there in the com package
uh but again those errors are not
related to that so these are like
related to the configurations which we
are trying to put
and uh during the copy paste there might
be a conversion of the code so that i
have taken care great
so uh let's see now what i have to
really do is like we have to see like
how we can proceed further on the uh for
the most executions and we need to get
this driver like we need to get this one
so i'll right click on my project here
and go to the build path and click on
configure build path so first i'm going
to uh add my binding jar file there the
java binding the jar file which i
downloaded just now this client combined
one here so only this jar file we are
trying to add up over here
and with that
most of the uh related errors related to
that uh imports will be resolved now i'm
not sure that how it's going to work how
it's going to uh you know function
whether it's going to success or failure
that's a different story but yes all you
have done is like i right clicked on my
project went to the build path went to
the configure build path here and went
for the add external charge so these are
the external jars which you have to do
we have to put up over here
so only the combined client combined jar
file is what i have put up over here in
this one in the reference libraries you
will immediately be able to know that
part of the jar file here
now this is a directory where you will
be having the exe file available for
that driver for the firefox so let's get
the path for our component also so we
got the path so let me paste it over
here
and here we go so we got the path here
this is the folder where we got our
driver available here and let's try to
resolve it let's try to run it over here
great
so now i'm going to right click here
just say run as and java application
now in this one i got an error saying
that some com google common collect
imitable map some class file is not
available there this is of the fact that
i did not imported those uh dependent
jar files also which we got downloaded
from the uh java binding file here so
that zip file was also having some of
the jar files there in the library
folders so in this one also you will be
able to see like some executions of the
jar files is required over here as an
imports as a standard imports
so let's import this one and this is the
reason why we got the error at the first
place because we are not importing those
ones those jar files which is being
required by our client combined jar file
also so these are the dependent jar
files which we are trying to import here
so ultimately at last you will be able
to have your referenced libraries
available here with all these jar files
component available here
right now since our driver is configured
everything is configured now the next
thing which we require is the browser
now i have the chrome browser but
unfortunately i don't have the firefox
browser so let's go ahead and download
the firefox browser so for that
let's open the browser so i'm going to
download a
firefox browser over here into my system
so uh the official website is something
which is quite good so we can go for the
download firefox here now uh why because
i require now i'm using the firefox here
if i am using the chrome browser i will
not be having or facing any kind of
issues as such but since i'm using the
firefox
driver so i require firefox browser so
uh the uh dependency of the uh browser
is there when we want to go ahead
because uh pretty much my uh core base
is going to connect or this
one is going to connect to the driver
here but driver ultimately internally or
require a browser show that it can
perform these occasions it can do that
execution so these drivers are going to
just uh communicate between the your
source code and the uh actual browser
here
so uh after the driver you also require
the browser to be installed like the
chrome browser to be available here so
that you can pretty much use it and you
can perform the configuration so let's
see uh we are getting the browser over
here in this one and uh we got the
browser installed perfectly fine over
here so we should be able to see the
browser uh because in this one we are
basically trying to open the browser and
getting our website called www.go
here
and then we are having a particularly
one and then ultimately the driver is
getting cured here
so let's see so once the browser is
downloaded and installed so right click
on run as java application
so you will be able to see the browsing
here so okay it's connecting the uh
browser the firefox exe file is getting
executed a browser is getting executed
and it will be maximized automatically
you can see here like it's you know
getting maximized automatically here and
we just have to wait for a couple of
seconds more
and uh here we go we got the
browser closed automatically also
because there was a slip of a couple of
seconds over here and you got the
failure like you got the complete uh
component or it got the driver close
there driver close means that definitely
the browser will also be closed here and
you can see here that the specific
output which is being performed or which
is getting executed over here it's
actually showing us like how the
executions and the uh setup needs to be
performed
or needs to be done here
so this is the way that how
the bro the implementations really
performed or really gets executed over
here in this case you got the browser
execution and everything will be work
perfectly fine
so again i'm right clicking over here
just click on run as java application
the same browser will be open again uh
it will be automatically refreshed you
will see that progress like this and
after a couple of seconds uh the thread
will be on sleep but yes after that it
will be closed automatically over here
so like that you can program how to open
your website how to proceed further from
there you want to click on some buttons
you want to do some processing that's
all up to you like how you program how
you code it over here so this completely
helps you to see like how exactly you
can go ahead with the complete program
and this program will help you to uh
execute a good amount of testing
validations and running or executing
some couple of test cases so this is
what we have in this demo where we saw
like how we can configure the different
drivers the web driver the browser
driver and ultimately the browser and
the selenium web driver here so you're
using this linear web driver over here
which is going to invoke the browser
driver and this browser driver is going
to invoke the browser as such over here
in this case
so that's it for this demo let's move on
to main content
so that was the demo in which we
executed a very simple program in order
to execute the selenium web driver which
is going to further invoke the uh
browser driver the firefox driver and
then it was invoking the uh specific
implementations there right so this is
what we did and if we summarize this
demo so in this one we downloaded uh the
selenium web driver we installed it we
configured it
we integrated the eclipse with the
selenium web driver
and we also executed a specific test
script in order to see like how a
particular browser will be booked and
the previous cases yes the browser was
invoking a
www.google.com website there and we were
getting the response accordingly and
that was the executions mechanism like
that's the whole basis that how the
selenium test cases used to work and
used to be integrated over there so this
is the complete way that how exactly we
did this demo here
meet tim
tim builds a robot in his lab
a climate-controlled and pollution-free
environment
once he's done he drops the robot off at
his project partner mia's house mia
takes it out to her backyard to ensure
that the robot meets the requirements
but here is where the problem arises the
change in the environment causes the
robot to malfunction
mia is now really annoyed and she has a
lot to correct and it seems to her as
though tim didn't really do much
this wall between them leaves a poor
robot to bite the dust
well what if we broke this wall tim and
miana work together in a common space
tim develops each block of functionality
of the robot which is then immediately
checked by mia both are now working
simultaneously instead of waiting on the
other to finish their task as and when a
feature is ready for use they are put
together to build the final product they
develop a common mindset and share ideas
to further speed up the process they use
several tools which can automate every
stage this means that the robot is now
ready sooner with less iterations and
manual work from an organization
perspective tim would be the developer
while mia the operations their union is
the core of the devops approach
devops has several stages and set of
tools to automate each of these stages
let's have a look at these tim first
puts down a plan
in terms of software this could mean
deciding on the modules and the
algorithms to use
once he has the plan he now codes the
plan with tools such as git tim has a
repository for storing all the codes and
their different versions this is called
version control
next this code is fetched and made
executable this is the build stage tools
such as gradle and maven will sort this
out now before deployment the product is
tested to catch any bugs the most
popular tool automating testing is
selenium once the products are tested
mia must deploy it the deployed product
is then continuously configured to the
desired state
ansible puppet and docker are some of
the most common tools used that automate
these stages
now every product is continuously
monitored in its working environment
nagios is one such tool that automates
this space and the feedback is fed back
to the planning stage
and finally we have the core of the
devops life cycle the integration stage
tools such as jenkins is responsible for
sending the code for build and test if
the code passes the tests it's further
sent for deployment this is called
continuous integration
let's now have a look at an organization
that has adopted the devops approach
which of the below sequence of steps
would they follow to develop a software
leave your answers in the comment
section
keep an eye out for the right answer on
the comment section or our youtube
community
giants such as amazon netflix target xc
and walmart have all adopted devops and
seen a considerable increase in delivery
and quality
in 2014 an hour of downtime for netflix
would cost it two hundred thousand
dollars
it became absolutely crucial that
netflix prepared themselves for any sort
of failure and so they took to the
devops approach and implemented it in
the most unique way they developed a
tool called simeon army this tool
created failures and automatically
deployed them in an environment that did
not affect the users
the team would troubleshoot these
failures and this gave them enough
experience to deal with any degree of
collapse with everything being automated
and happening simultaneously
organizations can now deliver at a much
faster pace so considering the benefits
of devops and its divergence from the
traditional methods would devops be the
future
let us know what you think in the
comment section below and with that we
come to an end of our video hello this
is matthew from simply learn and today
we're going to cover what is docker and
why it should be of value to you as
somebody who works in devops
so let's take a little scenario of a
developer and a tester before you had
the world of docker a developer would
actually build their code and then they
send it to the tester but then the code
wouldn't work on their system the code
doesn't work on the other system due to
the differences in computer environments
so what could be the solution to this
well you could go ahead and create a
virtual machine to be the same of the
solution in both areas we think docker
is an even better solution so let's kind
of break out what the main big
differences are between docker and
virtual machines as you can see between
the left and the right hand side both
look to be very similar what you'll see
however is that on the docker side what
you'll see as a big difference is that
the guest os for each container has been
eliminated docker is inherently more
lightweight but provides the same
functionality as a virtual machine so
let's step through some of the pros and
cons of a virtual machine versus docker
so first of all a virtual machine
occupies a lot more memory space on the
host machine in contrast docker occupies
significantly less memory space the boot
up time between both is very different
docker just boots up faster the
performance of the docker environment is
actually better and more consistent than
the virtual machine docker is also very
easy to set up and very easy to scale
the efficiencies therefore are much
higher with a docker environment versus
a virtual machine environment and you'll
find it is easier to port docker across
multiple platforms than a virtual
machine finally the space allocation
between docker and a virtual machine is
significant when you don't have to
include the guest os you're eliminating
a significant amount of space and the
docker environment is just inherently
smaller so after docker as a developer
you can build out your solution and send
it to a tester as long as we're all
running in the docker environment
everything will work just great so let's
step through what we're going to cover
in this presentation we're going to look
at the devops tools and where docker
fits within that space we'll examine
what docker actually is and how docker
works and then finally we'll step
through the different components of the
docker environment so what is devops
devops is a collaboration between the
development team the operation team
allowing you to continuously deliver
solutions and applications and services
that both delight and improve the
efficiency of your customers if you look
at the venn diagram that we have here on
the left hand side we have development
on the right hand side we have operation
and then there's a crossover in the
middle and that's where the devops team
sits if we look at the areas of
integration between both groups
developers are really interested in
planning code building and testing and
operations want to be able to
efficiently deploy operate a monitor
when you can have both groups
interacting with each other on these
seven key end elements then you can have
the efficiencies of an excellent devops
team so planning in codebase we use
tools like jit and geara for building we
use gradle and maven testing we use
selenium the integration between dev and
ops is through tools such as jenkins and
then the deployment operation is done
with tools such as docker and chef
finally nagios is used to monitor the
entire environment so let's step deeper
into what docker actually is so docker
is a tool which is used to automate the
deployment of applications in a
lightweight container so the application
can work efficiently in different
environments
now it's important to note the container
is actually a software package that
consists of all the dependencies
required to run the application so
multiple containers can run on the same
hardware the containers are maintained
in isolated environments they're highly
productive and they're quick and easy to
configure so let's take an example of
what docker is by using a house that may
be rented for someone using airbnb
so in the house there are three rooms
and only one cupboard and kitchen and
the problem we have is that none of the
guests are really ready to share the
cupboard and kitchen because every
individual has a different preference
when it comes to how the cupboard should
be stocked and how the kitchen should be
used this is very similar to how we run
software applications today each of the
applications could end up using
different frameworks so you may have a
framework such as rails
perfect and flask and you may want to
have them running for different
applications for different situations
this is where docker will help you run
the applications with the suitable
frameworks so let's go back to our
airbnb example so we have three rooms
and a kitchen and cupboard how do we
resolve this issue well we put a kitchen
and cupboard in each room we can do the
same thing for computers docker provides
the suitable frameworks for each
different application and since every
application has a framework with a
suitable version this space can also
then be utilized for putting in software
and applications that along and since
every application has its own framework
and suitable version the area that we
had previously stored for a framework
can be used for something else now we
can create a new application in this
instance a fourth application that uses
its own resources you know what with
these kinds of abilities to be able to
free up space on the computer it's no
wonder docker is the right choice so
let's take a closer look to how docker
actually works so when we look at docker
and we call something docker we're
actually referring to the base engine
which actually is installed on the host
machine that has all the different
components that run your docker
environment and if we look at the image
on the left hand side of the screen
you'll see that docker has a client
server relationship there is a client
installed on the hardware there is a
client that contains the docker product
and then there is a server which
controls how that docker client is
created the communication that goes back
and forth to be able to share the
knowledge on that docker client
relationship is done through a rest api
and this is fantastic news because that
means that you can actually interface
and program that api so we look here in
the animation we see that the docker
client is constantly communicating back
to the server information about the
infrastructure and it's using this rest
api as that communication channel the
docker server then would check out the
requests and the interaction necessary
for it to be the docker daemon which
runs on the server itself will then
check out the interaction and the
necessary operating system pieces needed
to be able to run the container okay so
that's just an overview of the docker
engine which is probably where you're
going to spend most of your time but
there are some other components that
form the infrastructure for docker let's
dig into those a little bit deeper as
well so what we're going to do now is
break out the four main components that
comprise of the docker environment the
four components are as follows the
docker client and server which we've
already done a deeper dive on docker
images docker containers and the docker
registry so if we look at the structure
that we have here on the left hand side
you see the relationship between the
docker client and the docker server and
then we have the rest api in between now
if we start digging into that rest api
particularly the relationship with the
docker daemon on the server we actually
have our other elements that form the
different components of the docker
ecosystem so the docker client is
accessed from your terminal window so if
you are using windows this can be
powershell on mac it's going to be your
terminal window and it allows you to run
the docker daemon and the registry
service when you have your terminal
window open so you can actually use your
terminal window to create instructions
on how to build and run your docker
images and containers if we look at the
images part of our registry here we
actually see that the image is really
just a template with the instructions
used for creating the containers which
you use within docker the docker image
is built using a file called the docker
file and then once you've created that
docker file you'll store that image in
the docker hub or registry and that
allows other people to be able to access
the same structure of a docker
environment that you've created the
syntax of creating the image is fairly
simple it's something that you'll be
able to get your arms around very
quickly and essentially what you're
doing is you're creating the option of a
new container you're identifying what
the image will look like what are the
commands that are needed and the
arguments for within those commands and
once you've done that you have a
definition for what your image will look
like so if we look here at what the
container itself looks like is that the
container is a standalone executable
package which includes applications and
their dependencies it's the instructions
for what your environment will look like
so you can be consistent in how that
environment is shared between multiple
developers testing units and other
people within your devops team now the
thing that's great about working with
docker is that it's so lightweight that
you can actually run multiple docker
containers in the same infrastructure
and share the same operating system this
is its strength it allows you to be able
to create those multiple environments
that you need for multiple projects that
you're working on interestingly though
within each container that container
creates an isolated area for the
applications to run so while you can run
multiple containers in an infrastructure
each of those containers are completely
isolated they're protected so that you
can actually control how your solutions
work there now as a team you may start
off with one or two developers on your
team but when a project starts becoming
more important and you start adding in
more people to your team you may have 15
people that are offshore you may have 10
people that are local you may have 15
consultants that are working on your
project you have a need for each of
those developers or each person on your
team to have access to that docker image
and to get access to that image we use
the docker registry which is an open
source server-side service for hosting
and distributing the images that you
have defined you can also use docker
itself as its own default registry and
docker hub now something it has to be
very mind though is that for publicly
shared images you may want to have your
own private images in which case you
would do that through your own registry
so once again public repositories can be
used to host the docker images which can
be accessed by anyone and i really
encourage you to go out to docker and
see the other docket images that have
been created because there may be tools
there that you can use to speed up your
own development environments now you
will also get to a point where you start
creating environments that are very
specific to the solutions that you are
building and when you get to that point
you'll likely want to create a private
repository so you're not sharing that
knowledge with the world in general now
the way in which you connect with the
docker registry is through simple pull
and push commands that you run through
terminal window to be able to get the
latest information so if you want to be
able to build your own container what
you'll start doing is using the pull
commands to actually pull the image from
the docker repository and the command
line for that is fairly simple in
terminal window you would write docker
pull and then you put in the image name
and any tags associated with that image
and use the command pulls so in your
terminal window you would actually use a
simple line of command once you've
actually connected to your docker
environment and that command will be
docker pull with the image name and any
associated tags around that image what
that will then do is pull the image from
the docker repository whether that's a
public repository or a private one now
in reverse if you want to be able to
update the docker image with a new
information you do a push command where
you would take the script that you've
written about the docker container that
you defined and push it to the
repository and as you can imagine the
commands for that are also fairly simple
in terminal window you would write
docker push the image name any
associated tags and then that would then
push that image to the docker repository
again either a public or a private
repository so if we recap the docker
file creates a docker image that's using
the build commands a docker image then
contains all the information necessary
for you to be able to execute the
project using the docket image any user
can run the code in order to create a
docker container and once a docker image
is built it's uploaded to a registry or
to a docker hub where it can be shared
across your entire team and from the
docker hub users can get access to the
docker image and build their own new
containers
welcome to all our viewers i'm anjali
from simply learn and today i'll be
taking you through the installation
process for docker so before we begin
let me give you an intro to docker so
what is docker docker is a tool which is
used to automate the deployment of
applications in lightweight containers
so when i say containers i mean a
software package that consists of all
the dependencies required to run the
particular application and when you
deploy containers you're basically
providing the capability for the
application to run in any kind of
environment so dockers have multiple
features some of which are that multiple
containers can run on the same hardware
it has very high productivity when
compared to virtual machines it
maintains isolated applications and has
a very quick and easy configuration
process so now let's begin with the demo
we'll be installing docker on an ubuntu
system so this is my system i'll just
open the terminal so the first thing you
can start with is removing any docker
installation that you probably already
have present in your system if you want
to start from scratch so this is the
command to do so sudo apt get remove
docker
docker engine docker dot io enter your
password
and docker is removed so now we'll start
from scratch and we'll install docker
once again
before that i'll just clear my screen
okay so before i install docker let me
just ensure that all these softwares on
my system currently is in its latest
state
so sudo apt get update
great so that's done next thing we'll
actually install our docker
so type in sudo apt
get
install
docker
now as you can see here there's an error
that's occurred so sometimes it's
possible that due to the environment of
the machine that you're working in this
particular command does not work
in which case there's always another
command that you can start with
just type docker install
and that by itself will give you the
command you can use to install docker so
as it says here sudo apt install docker
dot io is a command that we will
need to execute to install docker
and after that we will execute the sudo
snap install docker so sudo apt install
docker dot io first
and this will install your docker
after that's done we will have
sudo snap install docker so snap install
docker installs a newly created snap
package
there are basically some other
dependencies for docker that you'll have
to install
of course since this is the installation
process for the entire docker i o
it will take some time
great so our docker is installed the
next thing we do as i mentioned earlier
is that we need to install all the
dependency packages so the command for
that is
sudo snap install docker
enter your password
so with that we have completed the
installation process for docker but
we'll perform a few more stages where we
will test if the installation has been
done right
so before we move on with the testing
for docker let's once again just check
the version that we have installed
so for that the command is docker
version
and as you can see docker version
17.12.1
ce has been installed
next thing we do is we pull
an image from the docker hub
so docker run
hello
world
now hello world is a docker image which
is present on the docker hub docker hub
is basically a repository that you can
find online so with this command the
docker image hello world has been pulled
onto your system
so let's see if it's actually present on
your system now the command to check
this
is sudo docker images
and as you can see here hello world
repository
this is present on our system currently
so the image has been successfully
pulled onto the system
and this means that our docker is
working
now we'll try out another command
sudo docker ps minus a
this displays all the containers that
you have pulled so far
so as you can see here there are three
hello world images displayed and all of
them are in exited state so i did this
demo previously too which is why the two
hello worlds which is created two
minutes ago is also displayed here and
the first hello world which has been
created a minute ago is the one we just
did for this demo now as you have
probably noticed that all the hello
world images over here all these
containers are in the exited state so
when you give the option for docker ps
minus a where minus a stands for all it
displays all the containers whether they
are in exited or running state if you
want to see only those containers which
are in their running state you can
simply execute sudo docker ps
suro
docker
yes
and as you can see no container is
visible here because none of them are in
running state and with that we come to
an end of our docker installation this
is matthew from simply learn and today
we're going to dig through what docker
is and how you could be using it within
your own devops environment so let's get
started in this presentation we're going
to go through a number of key things
we're going to compare docker versus
traditional virtual machines and what
are the differences and why you want to
choose docker over a virtual environment
we'll go through the advantages of
working with docker and the structure
and how you would build out a docker
environment and during that structure
we'll dig through the components and the
advanced components within docker at the
end of the presentation we'll go through
some basic commands and then show you
how those basic commands can be used in
a live demo so with all that said let's
get started so let's first of all
compare docker with a traditional
virtual machine so here we have the
architecture on the left and right of a
traditional virtual machine versus a
darker environment and there are some
things that you'll probably see
immediately that are big differences one
is that the virtual environment has
hypervisor layer whereas the docker
environment has a docker engine layer
and then in addition to that there are
additional layers within the virtual
machine each of these really start
compounding and creating very
significant differences between a docker
environment and a virtual machine
environment so with a virtual machine
the actual memory usage is very high
whereas with the docker environment the
memory usage is very low if we look at
performance virtual machines when you
start building out particularly more
than one virtual machine on a server the
performance starts degrading and starts
getting poorer whereas with docker the
performance always stays really good
this is largely due to the lightweight
architecture used to construct the
docker containers themselves if we look
at portability virtual machines just are
terrible for portability they're still
dependent on the host operating system
and there's just a lot of problems that
happen when you are using virtual
machines for portability in contrast
docker was designed for portability so
you can actually build solutions in a
docker container environment and have
the guarantee that the solution will
work as you have built it no matter
where it's hosted finally boot up time
now the bit up time for a virtual
machine is fairly slow in comparison to
the boot up time for a docker
environment which is almost
instantaneous so we look at these in a
little bit more detail one of the other
challenges that you have with a virtual
machine is that if you have unused
memory within the environment you cannot
reallocate that memory so if you set up
an environment that has nine gigs of
memory that's being used we have six
gigs that are free you can't do anything
with it though that whole nine gig has
been allocated to that virtual machine
in contrast with docker if you have nine
gigs and six gigs becomes free that free
memory can then be reallocated and
reused across other containers used
within that docker environment another
challenge is running multiple virtual
machines in a single environment that
can lead to instability and performance
issues whereas docker is designed to run
multiple containers
in the same environment and actually
gets better the more containers you run
in that hosted single docker engine
portability issues with a virtual
machine is the software can work on one
machine but then when you move that vm
to another machine suddenly some of the
software won't work because there are
some dependencies that haven't been
inherited correctly whereas docker
itself is designed specifically to be
able to run across multiple environments
and to be deployed very easily across
the systems and again the actual boot up
time for a vm it just takes a long time
you took about minutes in contrast to
the milliseconds that it takes for a
docker environment to boot up so let's
dig into what docker actually is and
what allows for these great performance
improvements over a traditional vm
environment so docker itself is an os
virtualized software platform and it
allows it organizations to really easily
create deploy and run applications as
what are called docker containers that
have all the dependencies within that
container very easily
and the container itself is really just
a very lightweight package that has all
the instructions and dependencies such
as frameworks libraries bins etc all
within that container and that container
itself can then be moved from
environment to environment very easily
if we to look in our dev ops life cycle
the place where docker really shines is
in deployment because when you're
actually at the point of deploying your
solution you want to be able to
guarantee that the code that has been
tested will actually work in the
production environment but in addition
to that what we often find is that when
you're actually building the code and
you're actually testing the code having
a container running the solution at
those stages is also a really good plus
because what happens is that the people
building the code and testing the code
are able to validate their work in the
same environment that would be used for
the production environment so really
you can use docker in multiple stages
within your devops cycle but it becomes
really valuable in the deployment stage
so let's look at some of the key
advantages that you have with docker
some things that we've already covered
is that you can do rapid deployment and
you can do it really fast the
environment itself is highly portable
and was designed for that in mind the
efficiencies that you'll see will allow
you to run multiple docker containers in
a single environment as compared to more
traditional vm environments the
configuration itself can be scripted
through a language called yaml which
allows you to be able to write out and
describe the docker environment that you
want to create
this in turn allows you to be able to
scale your environment very very quickly
but with all of these advantages
probably the one that is most critical
to the type of work that we're doing
today is security you have to ensure
that the environment you are running is
a highly secure but highly scalable
environment and i'm very pleased to say
that docker takes security very
seriously so you'll see it as one of the
key talents for the actual architecture
of the system that you're implementing
so let's look at how docker actually
works within your environment so docker
works there is a what's called a docker
engine the docker engine is really
comprised of two key elements so you
have a server and a client and the
communication via the two is via a rest
api the server as you can imagine has
the instructions that are communicated
out to the client and instructs the
client on what to do the connection
between the client and the server the
communication is via a rest api
on older systems you can take advantage
of the docker toolbox which allows you
to go ahead and control the docker
engine the docker machine docker compose
and kitematic so let's now go into what
the actual root components though of
docker are so let's have a look at those
key components there are four components
that we're going to go through we have
the docker clients and server we have
docker images we have the docker
registry and the docker container we're
going to step through each of these one
by one so let's look at the docker
clients and server first so the docker
client and server is a command line
instructed solution where you would use
terminal on your mac or command line on
your pc or linux system to be able to
issue commands from the docker daemon
the communication between the docker
client and the docker host and is via a
rest api
so you can do some communication such as
a docker pull command which would send
an instruction to the daemon which would
then form the interaction of pulling in
the correct components
such as an image or container or
registry to the docker client the docker
daemon itself is actually a service
which actually performs all sorts of
operating and performance services and
as you'd imagine the docker daemon is
constantly listening across the rest api
to see if it needs to perform any
specific requests if you want to trigger
and start the whole process you what you
want to do is use the command dockered
within your docker daemon and that will
start all of your performances and then
you have a docker host which actually
runs the docker daemon and registry
itself so now let's look into the actual
structure of a docker image so a docker
image itself is a template which
contains instructions for the docker
container and that template is written
with a language called yaml and yaml
stands for yet another markup language
it's very easy to learn the docker image
itself is built within that yaml file
and then hosted as a file in the docket
registry the image is really comprised
of several key layers and you start with
your base layer which will typically
have your base image and this instance
is your base operating system such as
ubuntu and then you would then have
layer of dependencies above that
this would then comprise the
instructions in a read-only file that
would become your docker file so let's
let you go through and look at what one
of those in sets of instructions would
look like so here we have four layers of
instructions we have a from pull run and
then command so what does that actually
look like in our layers so to break this
down the from creates a layer which is
based on ubuntu and then what we're
doing is we're adding in files from the
docker repository onto that base command
that base layer and then what we want to
be able to do is then say okay what are
the wrong commands so we can actually
then build the container within the
environment and then we want to be able
to then have a command line that
actually executes something within that
container and in this instance the
command is to run python so one of
things that we will see is that as we
set up multiple containers each new
container is a new layer with new images
within the docker environment each
container is completely separate from
the other containers within your docker
environment so you're able to create
your own separate read write
instructions within each layer what's
interesting is that if you delete a
layer then the layer above it will also
get deleted so what happens when you
pull in a layer but something has
changed in the the core image what's
interesting then is that the actual main
image of itself cannot be modified once
you've copied the image you can then
modify it locally but you can never
modify the actual base image itself so
here are some callouts for the
components within a docket image so the
base layer are in read-only format the
layers can be combined in a union file
system to create a single image the
union file system saves memory space by
avoiding duplication of files and this
allows a file system to appear as a
writable but without modifying the file
which is known as a copy on write the
actual base layers themselves are read
only so to be able to get around this
structure within a docker container the
docker environment itself uses what's
known as a copy and write strategy
within the images and the containers
themselves and so what this allows you
to do is you can actually copy the files
for better efficiency across your entire
container environment the copy and write
strategy does make docker super
efficient and what you're able to do all
the time is keep reducing the amount of
disk space you're using and the amount
of performance that you're taking from
the server and that's really again a key
element for docker is just this constant
ability to be able to keep improving the
efficiency within the actual system
itself all right so let's go on to item
number three which is the docker
registry so the docker registry itself
is the place where you would host and
distribute the different types of images
that you have created or you want to be
used within your environment the actual
repository itself is just a collection
of docker images and those docker images
are built on instructions that you would
write with yaml and are very easily
stored and shared and what you can
actually do is you can actually
associate specific name tags to the
actual docker images themselves so it's
easy for people to be able to find and
share that image within the docker
registry itself one of the things you
actually see is we go through the demos
you actually see us actually using the
the tag name and you'll see how it is an
alphanumeric identifier and how we
actually use it to actually create the
actual container itself one of the
things you can do to as start off how
you would manage registry is you can
actually use the publicly accessible
docker hub registry which is available
to anybody but you can also create your
own registry for your own use internally
the actual registry that you create
internally can have both public and
private images that you create and this
may be for various reasons of how you
structure your environment the actual
commands you would use to actually
connect to the registry are both push
and pull push is to actually push a new
container environment you've created
from your local manager node to the
remote registry and a pool allows you to
pull a new client that has been created
and is being shared so again full
command and it pulls and retrieves a
docket image from the docker registry
and makes it very easy for people to
share different images consistently
across teams and a push command allows
you to take a new command that you've
created a new container that you created
and push it to the registry whether it's
docker hub or whether it's your own
private registry and allow it to be
shared across your teams some uh key did
you know in docker registry deleting a
repository is not a reversible action so
if you delete a repository it's gone so
let's go into the final stage here which
is the actual docker container itself so
the docker container itself um is an
executable package of applications and
its dependencies bundled together so it
gives all the instructions that you
would have for the solution that you're
looking to run it's actually really
lightweight and again this is because of
the redundancy that's built into how you
structure the container and the
container itself is then inherently also
extremely portable
what's really good about running a
container though is that it does run
completely in isolation so you're able
to share it very easily from grouped
group and you are guaranteed that even
if you are running a container it's not
going to be impacted by any host os
peculiarities or unique setups as you
would have in a vm or a
non-containerized environment the actual
memory that you have on a docker
environment they can be shared across
multiple containers which is really
useful typically when you have a vm you
would have a defined amount of memory
for each vm environment the challenge
you start running into though is that
you can't share that memory whereas with
docker you can easily share the memory
um for a single environment across
multiple containers
the actual container is built using
docket images and the commands to
actually run those images is a run
command so let's actually go through a
basic structure of how you would run a
docker image so you go into terminal
window and you would write a docker run
redis
and then it would run a container called
redis so we're going to go in and if you
don't have the redis image locally
installed it will then pull it from the
registry then the new docker container
redis will be then available within your
environment so you can actually start
using it so let's look at why containers
are so lightweight they're so
lightweight because they really have
been able to get away from some of the
additional layers that you have in
virtualization within vms and the
biggest one is the hypervisor and the
need to run on a host operating system
those are two big big elements so if you
can get rid of those then you're doing
great so let's look at some of the more
advanced concepts within the docker
environment and we're going to look at
two advanced components one is docker
compose and the second is docker swamp
so let's look at docker compose docker
compose is really designed for
running multiple containers as a single
service and it does this by running each
container in isolation but allowing the
containers to interact with each other
as was stated earlier on you would
actually write the compose environment
using yaml as the language in the files
that you would create so where would you
use something like docker compose so an
example would be if you are running an
apache server with my sql database and
you need to create additional containers
to run additional services without the
need to start each one separately and
this is where you would write a set of
files using docker compose to be able to
help balance out
that demand so let's now look at docker
swarm so docker swarm is a service that
allows you to be able to control
multiple docker environments within a
single platform
so what you actually are looking at
doing is within your docker swamp is
we're treating each node as a docker
daemon and we're actually having an api
that's interacting with each of those
nodes
there are two types of node that you're
going to be getting comfortable working
with one is the manager node and the
second is the worker node and as you'd
expect the manager node is the one
sending out the instructions to all of
the worker nodes but there is a two-way
communication that is happening the
communication allows for the imagine
node to be able to manage the
instructions and then listen to receive
updates from the working node so if
anything happens within this environment
the imagine node can react and adjust
the architecture of the worker node so
it's always in sync it was really great
for
large scaled environments so finally
let's go through what are some of the
basic commands you would use within
docker and once we've gone through all
these basic commands we'll actually show
you a demo of how you'd actually use
them as well so if we're going to go in
probably the first command is to install
docker and so if you have yam installed
you just do yum install docker and
you'll install docker onto your computer
to start the docker daemon as you want
to do system ctl start docker the
command to remove a docker image is
docker rmi and then the image id itself
and that's not the image name that's the
actual alphanumeric id number that you
want to uh grab the command line to
download a new image is docker pull and
then the name of the image you'd want to
pull and by default you're going to be
pulling from the docker default registry
that will then connect to your docker
daemon and download the images from that
registry client the command line to run
an image is docker run and then the
image id
and then we have the if we wanted to
pull specifically from docker hub then
we would have a docker pull and then the
image name and colon its tag to pull
build an image from a docker file you
would do docker build dash t and then
the image name and colon tag to shut
down the container you do docker stop
container id the access for running a
container is docker exec it container id
bash
so we've gone through all the different
commands but let's actually see how they
would actually look and we're going to
go ahead and do a demo so welcome to
this demo where we're going to go ahead
and put together all of the different
commands that we have outlined in the
presentation for docker uh first is just
to list all of the docker images that we
have so we do
sudo docker images and we enter in our
password and this will now list out the
images that we've created already and we
have three images there
so let's go ahead and pull a docker
image so to do that we'll we'll go ahead
and type sudo
docker
and actually we don't want to do image
we want to select pull
and then the name of the image that we
want to pull which is going to be my
sequel
and by default this is actually going to
go ahead and use the latest my sequel
command mysql image that we have so it's
now go ahead and pull this image it's
going to take a few minutes depending on
your internet connection speed it's kind
of a large file that has to be
downloaded so we'll just wait for that
to download
you can see the others have completed
just waiting for this last file to
download almost there
once that's done we're going to go ahead
and do is we'll actually
run the docking container and create a
new container using the image that we
just downloaded but we have to wait for
this to download first
all right so the image has been pulled
from docker hub
and let's go ahead and create the new
docker container so we're gonna do sudo
docker
run
dash d
dash
p
0.0.0.0
colon
80
colon 80.
and then put in my sql call on
latest so we have the latest version
and we have our new token
and that shows our new docker container
has been created
now let's go ahead and see if the
container is running
and we'll do
sudo docker
ps
to list all the running containers and
what we see is that the container is not
listed there which means it's probably
not running so let's go ahead and list
out all of the images that we have
within docker so we can see whether it's
actually listed there so we'll do ps
dash a
and yes there we are we can see that we
do have our new container we want to see
sql latest
and it was created 36 seconds ago
but it's in the exit mode so what we
have to do is we have to change that
status so it's actually running
so let's change that to running state
we'll do sudo
docker
run
dash
i t
dash dash
name
and we can name it
sl
sql
mysql
and that's now going to be in the route
and we'll exit out of that and now if we
list out the docking containers we
should see it is now
an active container
sudo docker
start
and then we'll start the
scene
and then
and we should now see it
there we are it's now in the running
state excellent
and we can see that it was updated six
seconds ago
we're gonna go ahead and we're gonna
clear the screen
okay now what we want to do is remove
the docker container
so we're going to do is check list of
images that we have
and to sudo docker images
here are the images that we have and we
have my sql is listed
and what we want to do is delete my sql
and to do that we're going to type in
sudo docker rm-f
[Music]
image
mysql
run that command and what we'll find is
the image there's no such image oh okay
so what we actually have to do is we
have to go and see that the image is
now gone it's been removed excellent
it's exactly what we wanted to see
and we can also delete an image by its
image id as well
however if an image is running
and active we have to kill that image
first so we'll go ahead and we're going
to select the image id we'll copy that
and it's going to
replace that it won't be able to
actually run correctly because the image
is active so what we have to do now is
stop the image and then we can kill it
so it's in the running state
so we have to do
so we do sudo darker kill
and kill sl and then we'll kill the
container
and now we'll see that the container has
gone
and now we can delete the image
and that's going to be the image gone
with image id but boom
easy peasy
okay let's go ahead on to the next
exercise which is two
so here we are we've listed all of the
uh
containers and they're all gone so let's
go into the next exercise final exercise
which is to actually
create a batch image
and we do a batch http image so let's go
ahead and write that out so it's going
to be docker
run
dash did
dash dash
name
white is that's going to be the name of
this http service dash p
8080 colon 80 dash v
open quotes
dollar sign pwd
close quotes
colon
slash usr
slash local
slash
apache2
slash htdocs
slash
httpd
semicolon 2.4
we'll run that
put in our password again
uh so what we see is the port is already
being used so let's go ahead and see
which ports let's go see if we can
change the port or see what ports are
running so let's do
sudo images and see which ports are
being used because it's either the the
port or the name
hasn't been put in correctly so sudo
docker images
ps
pseudo docker
ps dash a
and
yep
let's port 80 there
so we'll clear the screen
so we're going to change the container
name because i think we actually have
the wrong container name here so let's
go and change that and we'll paste that
in and voila there we go
now working and we'll just double check
and make sure everything's working
correctly so to do that we'll go into
our web browser
and we'll type in
as soon as firefox opens up
type in localhost
colon 8080
which was the the port that we created
and there we are it's a list of all the
files which shows that the server is up
and running today we're going to cover
what is a docker container why you would
want to consider using it in your devops
environment
so let's have a look at what we have in
our current environment so today when
you actually have your standard machine
you have the infrastructure you have the
host operating system and you have your
applications and then when you create a
virtual environment what you're actually
doing is you're actually creating
virtual machines but those virtual
machines actually are now sitting within
a hypervisor solution that sits still on
top of your host operating system and
infrastructure and with a docker engine
what we're able to do is we're able to
actually reduce significantly
the different elements that you would
normally have within a virtualized
environment so we're able to get rid of
the the bins and the so we're able to
get rid of the guest os and we're able
to eliminate the hypervisor environment
and this is really important as we
actually start working and creating
environments that are consistent because
we want to be able to make it so it's
really easy and stable for the
environment that you have within your
dev and ops environment now critical is
getting rid of that hypervisor element
it's just a lot of overhead so let's
have a look at a container as an example
so here we actually have a couple of
examples on the right hand side we have
different containers we have one
containers running apache tomcat and
with java and second containers running
sql server and microsoft.net environment
the third container is running python
with mysql these are all running just
fine within the docker engine and
sitting on top of a host os which could
be linux it really could be any host os
within a consistent infrastructure and
you're able to have a solution that can
be shared easily amongst your teams so
let's have a look at an example that
you'd have today if a company is doing a
traditional java application so you have
your developers working in jboss on his
system and he's coding away and he has
to get that code over to a tester now
what will happen is that tester will
then typically in your traditional
environment then have to install jboss
on their machine and get everything
running and cool and hopefully set up
identically to the developer chances are
they probably won't have it exactly the
same but they're trying to get as close
as possible and then at some point you
want to be able to test this within your
production environment so you send it
over to a system administrator who would
then also have to install jboss on their
environment as well yeah this just seems
to be a whole lot of duplication so why
go through the problem of installing
jboss three times and this is where
things get really interesting because
the challenge you have today is that
it's very difficult to almost impossible
to have identical environment if you're
just installing software locally on
devices the developers probably got a
whole bunch of development software that
could be conflicting with the jboss
environment the tester has similar
testing software but probably doesn't
have all the development software and
certainly the system administrator won't
have all the tools that the developer
and tester have their own tools and so
what you want to be able to do is kind
of get away from the challenge you have
of having to do local installations on
three different computers and in
addition what you see is that this uses
up a lot of effort because when you're
having to install software over and over
again you just keep repeating doing
really basic foundational challenges so
this is where docker comes in and docker
is the tool that allows you to be able
to share environments from one group to
another group without having to install
software locally on a device you install
all of the code into your docker
container and simply share the container
so in this presentation we're going to
go through a few things we're going to
cover what docker actually is and then
we're going to dig into the actual
architecture of docker and kind of go
through what docker container is and how
to create a docker container and then
we'll go at through the benefits of
using docker containers and then the
commands and finalize everything out
with a brief demo so what is docker so
docker is as you'd expect because all
the software that we cover in this
series is an open source solution and it
is a container solution that allows you
to be able to containerize all of the
necessary files and applications needed
to run the solution you're building so
you can share it from different people
in your team whether it's a developer a
tester or system administrator and this
allows you to have a consistent
environment from one group to the next
so let's kind of dig into that
architecture so you understand why
docker runs effectively so the docker
architecture itself is built up of two
key elements there is the docker client
and then there is a rest api connection
to a docker daemon which actually hosts
the entire environment within the docker
host and the docker daemon you have your
different containers and each one has a
link to a docker registry the docker
client itself is a rest service so as
you'd expect a rest api and that sends
command line to the docker daemon
through a terminal window or command
line interface window and we'll go
through some of these demos later on so
you can actually see how you can
actually interact with darker the docker
demo then checks the request against and
the docker components and then performs
the service that you're requesting now
the docker image itself all it really is
a collection of instructions used to
create a container and again this is
consistent with all the devops tools
that we have the devops tools that we're
looking to use throughout this series of
videos are all environments that can be
scripted and this is really important
because it allows you to be able to
duplicate and scale the environments
that you want to be able to build very
quickly and effectively the actual
container itself has all of the
applications and the dependencies of
those applications in one package you
can kind of think of it as a really
effective and efficient zip file it's a
little bit more than that but it's one
file that actually has everything you
need to be able to run all of your
solutions the actual docker registry
itself is an environment for being able
to host and distribute different docker
images among your team so say for
instance you had a team of developers
that were working on multiple different
solutions so say you have a team of
developers and you have 50 developers
and they're working on five different
applications you can actually have the
applications themselves the containers
shared in the docker registry so each of
those teams at any time check out and
have the latest container of that latest
image of the code that you're working on
so let's dig into what actually is in
the container so the important part of a
docking container is that it has
everything you need to be able to run
the application it's like a virtualized
environment it has all your frameworks
and your libraries and it allows the
teams to be able to build out and run
exactly the right environment that the
developer intended what's interesting
though is the actual applications then
will run in isolation so they're not
impacting other applications that's
using dependencies on other libraries or
files outside of the container because
of the architecture it really uses a lot
less space and because it's using less
space it's a much more lightweight
architecture so the files in the actual
folder itself is much smaller it's very
secure highly portable and the boot up
time is incredibly fast so let's
actually get into how you would actually
create a docker container so the docker
container itself is actually built
through command line and it's built of a
file and docker image so the actual
docker file is a text file that contains
all the instructions that you would need
to be able to create that docker image
and then we'll actually then create all
of the project code with inside of that
image then the image becomes the item
that you would share through the docker
registry you would then use the command
line and we'll do this later on select
docker run and then the name of the
image to be able to easily and
effectively run that image locally and
again once you've created the docker
image you can store that in the docker
registry making it available to anybody
within your network so something to bear
in mind is that docker itself has its
own registry called docker hub and that
is a public registry so you can actually
go out and see other doc images that
have been created and access those
images as your own company you may want
to have your own private repository so
you want to be able to go ahead and
either do that locally through your own
repository or you can actually get a
licensed version of docker hub where you
can actually then share those files
now something that's also very
interesting to know is that you can have
multiple versions of a docker image so
if you have a different version control
different release versions and you want
to be able to test and write code for
those different release versions because
you may have different setups you can
certainly do that within your docker
registry environment okay so let's go
ahead and we're going to create a docker
image using some of our basic docker
commands and so there are essentially
really you know kind of just two
commands that you're going to be looking
for one is the build command another one
is to actually put it into your registry
which is a push command so if you want
to get a image from a docker registry
then you want to use the pull command
and a pull command simply pulls the
image from the registry and in this
example using
nginx as our registry and we can
actually then pull the image down to our
test environment on our local machine so
we're actually running the container
within our docker application on a local
machine we're able to then have the
image run exactly as it would in
production and then you can actually use
the run command to actually use the
docker image on your local machine so
just a you know a few uh interesting
tidbits about the docking container once
the container is created a new layer is
formed on top of the docker image layers
called the container layer each
container has a separate read write
container layer and any changes made in
that docking container is then reflected
upon the particular container layer and
if you want to delete the container
layer the container layer also gets
deleted as well so you know why would
using docker and containers be of
benefit to you well you know some of the
things that are useful is that
containers have no external dependencies
for the applications they run once you
actually have the container running
locally it has everything it needs to be
able to run the application so there's
no having to install additional pieces
of software such as the example we gave
with jboss at the beginning of the
presentation now the containers are
really lightweight so it makes it very
easy to share the containers amongst
your teams whether it's a developer
whether it's a tester whether it's
somebody on your operations environment
it's really easy to share those
containers amongst your entire team
different data volumes can be easily
reused and shared among
multiple containers and again this is
another big benefit and this is a
reflection of the lightweight nature of
your containers the container itself
also runs in isolation
which means that it is not impacted by
any dependencies you may have on your
own local environment so it's a
completely sandboxed environment so some
of the questions you might ask is you
know can you run multiple containers
together without the need to start each
one individually and you know what yes
you can with docker compose docking
compose allows you to run multiple
containers in a single service and again
this is a reflection on the lightweight
nature of containers within the docker
environment so we'll end our
presentation by looking at some of the
basic commands that you'd have within
docker so we have here on the left hand
side we have a docker container and then
the command for each item we're actually
going to go ahead and use some of these
commands in the demo that we're going to
do after this presentation you'll see
that in a moment but just you know some
of the basic commands we have are
committing the docket image into the
container kill is a you know standard
kill command to you know terminate one
or more of the running containers so
they stop working then restart those
containers but suddenly you can look at
all the image all of the commands here
and try them out for yourself so we're
going to go ahead and start a demo of
how to use the basic commands to run
docker so to do this we're going to open
up terminal window or command line
deploying whether you're running linux
pc or mac
and we're going to go ahead and the
first thing we want to do is see what
our docker image lists are so we can go
sudo docker images and this will give us
well first we'll enter in our password
so let's go enter that in and this one
now gives a list of our docker images
and here are the doc images that have
already been created in the system and
we can actually go ahead and actually
see the processes that are actually
running so i'm going to go ahead and
open up this window a little bit more
but this will show you the actual
processors and the containers that we
actually have and so on the far left
hand side you see under names we have
learn simply learn the underscore cool
these are all just different ones that
we've been working on so let's go ahead
and create a docker image so we do sudo
docker
run
dash d
dash p
0.0.0.0
go on 80 colon 80.
ubuntu and this will allow us to go
ahead and run
an ubuntu
image and this will run the latest image
and what we have here is a hash number
and this hash number is a unique name
that defines the
container that we've just created and we
can go ahead and we can check to make
sure that the container actually is
present so we're going to do
sudo docker.ps and this actually shows
some there so it's not in a running
state right now but that doesn't mean
that we don't have it so let's list out
all the containers that are both running
and in the exit state so let's do sucker
ps dash a and
this lists all the containers that i
have running on my machine
and this shows all the ones that have
been in the running state and in the
exit stage and here we see one that we
just created about a minute ago and it's
called learn
and these are all running ubuntu and
this is the one that we had created just
a few seconds ago
let's open it up and
there we go
so let's change that to that new doc
container to a running state so scroll
down
and we're gonna type sudo
docker
run
dash i t dash dash
name
my
um
so this is going to be the new container
name it's going to be my docker so this
is how we name our docker environment
and we'll put in the image name which is
ubuntu
and dashbin dash bash
and it's now in our route and we'll exit
out of that
so now we're going to go ahead and start
the new my docker container so sudo
docker
start
my
and we'll get the container image which
will be my docker
my docker
return and that started that docker
image
and let's go ahead and check against the
other running docker images to make sure
it's running correctly so sudo docker
ps
and there we are underneath name on the
right hand side you have to see my
docker along with the other docker
images that we created that's been
running for 13 seconds
quite fast so we want to rename the
container let's use the command sudo
docker
rename
we can take another docker image this
grab this one and we'll put it in rename
and we'll rename
and put in the old container name which
is image and then we'll put in the new
container name and let's call it
purple
so now the container image that had
proved something called image is now
called purple
so we do sudo docker
ps
to list all of our docker images
and if we scroll up and there there we
go purple
how easy is that to rename an image
and we can go ahead and use this command
if we want to stop containers so we're
going to write sudo
docker
stop
and then we have to put in the container
name
and we'll put in my docker the container
that we originally created
and that image has now stopped
and let's go ahead and prove that we're
going to list out all the docker images
and what you see is that it's not listed
in the active images it's uh not on the
list on the far right hand side
but if we go ahead and we can list out
all of the docker images so you actually
see it's still
there as an image is just
not in an active stage it's what's known
as in an exit state
so here we go
and there's my ducker it's in an exit
state so that happened 27 seconds ago
so if we want to to remove a container
we can use the following command
so sudo docker
rm
will remove
my docker
and that will remove it from the exit
state
and we're going to go ahead and we're
going to double check that
and yep
yep
it's not not listed there under exit
state anymore
it's gone
and there we go
there that's where it used to be
all right let's go back
so if we want to exit a container in the
running state so we do sudo kill and
then the name of the container
i think one of them is called yellow
let's just check and see if that's gonna
kill it
oops no i guess we don't have one called
yellow so let's find out name of
container that we actually have
so sudo
docker
kill
oh we're going to list out the ones that
are running oh okay there we go now
yellow isn't in that list so let's take
i know let's take simply learn and so we
can actually go ahead and let's write
sudo docker
kill
simply learn
and that will actually kill an active
docker container
boom there we go
and we list out all the active
containers you can actually see now that
they simply learn container is not
active anymore
and these are all the basic commands for
docker container
today we're going to dig into docker
swarm so what we're going to do in this
session is we're going to go through
what a docker and docker container is
and why you'd want to use it we'll then
break out what are the characteristics
and structure of a docker swarm
environment and then finally we'll go
through and do a demo using actual code
in the command line interface to
actually run and build out the main
functions and
commands that you would use for a docker
swarm environment so with that said
let's get started so docker is a tool
that we actually use to help automate
applications in our environment so that
we have a consistent way that we're
actually building and testing and
validating codes that's been created
think of it as a virtualization but much
more sophisticated and efficient way of
doing virtualization
the thing that you have that's a huge
advantage when you're working with
docker is that it's a very lightweight
software package it allows you to have
all of the tools needed for actually
running the code without having to have
the significant overhead that you would
normally have with virtualization so one
of the characteristics you have with
docker is that you can actually run
multiple docker environments in the same
host environment and for you to be able
to do this we had to figure out how this
would actually run and so to actually do
this we actually do what's called a
docker swarm and a docker swarm is an
environment where you can actually have
multiple docker images running on the
same host operating system so you can
have running in each of those docker
containers different solutions so let's
dig into what a docker swarm is so a
docker swarm is essentially a tool that
allows you to very easily create and
schedule multiple docker nodes so really
two or more docker nodes and you can
have quite a large number of docker
nodes in a single swarm uh each node
itself is actually a docker daemon and
that demon is able to interact with the
docker api and have all the benefits of
being a full docker environment one of
the other advantages you have is that
the
each docker container within the swarm
can then be deployed and managed but as
a node in that entire clustered
environment so what we have here is a
breakdown of the five key elements
within a docker environment you have the
docker container you have the daemon the
docker images and the docker client and
docker registry so the docker game
itself is what does all the work
interacting with the actual host
operating system to be able to manage
the docker containers so if we look here
here we have set up an environment where
we have three docket containers being
run with docker and what we want to be
able to do is be able to interact with
the environment because what would
happen if we actually have something
changed in our environment so we have
the environment set up as a docker swarm
and one of our containers fails what
we're able to do is use the swarm to be
able to correct that failure so the
docker swarm manager is able to come in
and reschedule containers and as you
would imagine the actual swarm note has
full backups and full redundancy for any
kind of failures that would happen and
we would do all of this work through
command line interface so let's go
through some of the features that you
have within the actual docker swarm
itself so
a key feature for docker swarm is that
it is fully decentralized which means
that it makes it very easy for teams to
be able to access and manage the
environment as you would expect as well
is that the communication that happens
between the manager and client nodes
within the swarm is highly secure and of
course this is really just a fundamental
that you should have for any kind of
solution but it is good to know that
docker swarm has that built in there is
also auto load balancing within your
environment you can actually script that
into how you write out and structure
your swarm environment and that load
balancing then also allows you to then
convert that swarm environment into a
highly scalable infrastructure
and then rollback task allows you to be
able to roll back environments to
previous safe environments so say
something that does get pushed out and
something breaks you're able to
immediately roll back into a safe
environment so each of the containers
are pushed out and and are controlled
using services and they actually have to
be breast services which make it very
easy for you to be able to integrate
within your environment
and each of the different services
contains a group of containers of the
same image now by having this structure
it allows you to be able to scale your
application appropriate to the demands
on your server so if you have a service
that needs to have a significantly
larger number of services for it to run
you can actually scale that
appropriately and they can be either geo
or demand based one of the requirements
for setting up a docker swarm is you
must have at least one node deployed so
the way that the architecture is set up
is that you have a manager node and a
client node and there must be one of
each for the entire environment to be
able to work effectively so you know
here we are just jumping ahead of sales
a little bit we have two types of nodes
in the docker swan we have the manager
node and we have the worker node which
is the client that does the actual
execution of the tasks the manager node
very similar to other systems that we've
talked about on simply learn allows you
to actually control and manage the
actual tasks that are being executed by
the worker nodes and the worker nodes as
you can imagine and then actually
execute the instructions that the
manager are sending out to it so here we
have a situation where we can illustrate
what would happen with a manager node
sending out commands to different worker
nodes the manager is fully aware of the
status of the entire swarm environment
at all times this is because of the
two-way secure communication that's
going from the manager to the worker
environment the workers as you'd expect
are accepting tasks that are being sent
from the manager so the manager sends
out a task saying that you need to be
running as a my sequel environment then
the worker node will then convert to my
sequel environment and all of these
environments are scripted and controlled
by you as the manager the actual worker
nodes themselves actually have a client
agent and that client will then
communicate all different states of the
infrastructure back to the manager so
that any time the manager node is in
full control of the entire swarm the
manager is the controller of this
environment and so you always want to be
able to ensure that the manager has full
access to all the work that's happening
within the swarm and this allows you as
the manager to be able to control your
swarm and very quickly be able to react
to any changes without having to rely on
manual installations of software and
hardware and as we covered earlier on
there is a rest api that uses the
communication over http from the manager
to the worker node it's interesting to
note that it is a rest api because if
you wanted to you could actually
integrate that api into custom
applications and even then create
automated docker images to be created on
demand from third-party solutions that
you may want to create so one of the
things that's a really a big advantage
with having a swarm is that once you've
actually created the swarm any of the
services um that you create can be
accessed by any node of the same cluster
one of the things you do have to do
though is you have to specify
what container image that you're going
to use when you're creating a new
service and you can do that either
through a centralized docker hub
environment or through your own private
docker hub environment one of the things
that's interesting is that you can set
up commands and services to be either
global or replicated a global service
will allow you to run a service
consistently on every node within the
swarm whereas a replicated service will
only push out functionality and tasks to
specific worker nodes within a swarm so
you may be asking yourself hey isn't a
service and task the same thing no
they're they're kind of not in the
docker world and the difference is is a
service is a description of a task for
the state whereas the actual task is the
work that needs to get done and that's
the differentiator here so what you can
do as a docker user is you actually
create services and then you can then
define when you want them to start as
tasks now what's interesting is that
when you do assign a task to a node that
same task cannot be assigned to another
node also what's interesting is that you
can actually have multiple managers
within a docker swarm environment if you
do however go down this path you have to
elect one manager to be the primary
manager and the other managers to be
secondary managers in many ways those
secondary managers are really similar in
concept to worker nodes in which they
have the capability of a manager but
they are dependent on that single
primary manager to be able to provide
the right instructions and for services
and tasks to the entire swarm
environment so if we kind of recap some
of these we have a command line
interface which allows us to create and
connect via apis and that those apis
that we connect to in our small
environment
allows us to do orchestration via tasks
and services the task allocation allows
us to allocate work to tasks via their
ip address which allows them to execute
them on the work and then the worker
nodes themselves have to connect to the
manager node to be able to check for
when to ask someone so that they are
keeping a consistent communication back
and forth across the entire swarm and
then the final stage is to actually
execute the tasks that have been
assigned from the manager note to the
work note so that you have a successful
execution of the solution you're looking
to build all right so with that said
let's go ahead and we're going to do a
demo
so we're going to go ahead and do a demo
and showing how you can run docker swarm
for this you'll need to have both a
virtual environment running your manager
and your working environment so here we
have our worker and uh here we have our
manager so we're just going to open up
terminal window and we're going to go
into the manager for terminal window so
the following command here is used to
initialize docker swan which is going to
type this in so sudo docker swarm init
and we put the ip address for the
network we're connecting to
and we'll put in our password
and here we have now connected
and this is our manager node and what we
want to be able to highlight is the
specific token which identifies the
docker swarm environment and this is our
token right here so we're going to copy
that
because we'll need to use that for our
worker environment so here we are in the
work environment and we'll use the token
that we just copied um as a way to be
able to connect to the manager and
connect to the docker swarm environment
and so sudo
i'll paste in the docker swamp and we'll
join that
and now here we shows that we have
joined the swarm environment as a worker
and now
we're in the manager we can actually
show that we actually have
that worker in the environment so
there's docker node ls to list out all
of the
items in that environment
sorry we actually did that in the wrong
area so we're on the right sudo docker
node ls to list out
all the nodes in the swarm
and there you are you see we've actually
connected the
worker to the manager node and both
are active and the manager is the leader
and the work of virtualbox is in the
swarm
okay we're going to go ahead and create
a new service so docker swan create and
we're going to just change the name to
hello world for the new service and we
use the alpine image from docker.com
it takes just a moment for it to run
there we go
and there we go services converged
so what we have now is a new service
that has been created
let's go ahead and we'll list out the
services
and here we have our new hello world
service
and we go ahead and check the document
containers and we're going to do
docker ps and
here's our alpine it's running the
latest image
and that's the docker container id
and we can see that it was just updated
and so we're going to do is use the same
command in the worker node
and make sure everything is working over
there
so go over to our worker
paste that in
so what we see here is there is no image
or container created because it's not in
the worker node it would be in the
manager node
so we can go ahead and create the new
service
and we're gonna make the mode global and
that way the service is available across
all of the swarm
so we're just gonna execute that work
takes a moment
and
[Music]
there we are
done work has been completed and we have
the two different ids which shows that
two different services running and if we
go back to the worker mode and we run
sudo docker ps again and there we are
now we see that we have the hello world
new virtual environment has been added
with the image of alpine and we also
have the new token id for that
if we want to kill a node from the swamp
we can use the following command which
is pseudo
docker swamp leave dash dash force
and that will force the node to leave
the swarm today we're going to cover
dhaka compose so in this session what
we're going to do is we're going to go
through what docker is and then by
extension what docker compose is and how
it improves the performance of docker
what the benefits of working with
dockercompose is we are going to cover
as well what the difference between
docker compose and docker swarm is
because the two products are similar but
they have two different types of job and
at the end of this presentation we'll
take you through some basic commands
that allow you to get up and running
working with docker and docker compose
finally after this presentation we'll do
a brief demo that allows you to get up
and running using some of these commands
to do your own docker compose
environment so let's get started with
docker compose so first of all we have
to kind of cover what docker is so
docker has come as an evolution of
technologies that started with virtual
machines vm machines and a vm machine
allows you to run a complete operating
system and complete operating system and
its environment on your own computer in
your own operating system without it
interfering the problem was is that it's
very heavy and complex and in contrast
docker is a much more lightweight and
more flexible environment that you can
automate with scripts so we have to
remember that the container itself is
just software and it has dependencies
that run within that application that
are managed by docker so we have a look
at the way docker is broke now first of
all we have the docker image and we have
the docker image created by a docker
file and the docker file is a text based
script and that text file within
dockerfile actually has all the commands
that allow you to run the appropriate
technologies within the docker image so
the docker image allows you to be able
to have a wide group of people and
consistently run the same environment
and if you want to be able to share that
docker image effectively you would do so
by uploading to docker hub and docker
hub can be available either publicly uh
through the the public docker hub
website or you can actually set up your
own private enterprise docker hub to
share your own images across your own
network and then from docker hub people
can then pull their own docker image and
build new containers that are consistent
on the original docker container that
you created so it's a great way of being
able to have your entire team scale up
easily and effectively so one of the
questions that will come up though is
what if you want to use two containers
in a single service and an example this
might be like a web server that is using
a database but the database may be in
one container and the web server may be
in another container which is very
typical for your own web and database
infrastructure so very similar um
scenario but how would you do this with
doc app so by using just docker itself
it's actually very difficult to do this
you can do it but it's just very time
consuming and just not a very good use
of your productivity but with docker
compose you can actually do the whole
process quite quickly and easily and
hence the reason why we have docker
compose to allow you to have two or more
docker containers running in the same
environment being able to communicate as
if they were running in a production
environment so let's dig into what
docker compose is so let's consider a
scenario that you'd have today so
mintra is a
fashion website similar to amazon and
you go to mentor with your web browser
and on that website you would go through
a number of activities such as logging
into your account browsing a catalog uh
you'd have your checkout application
server and you go through the typical
process of building out an application
behind each of these services are
different products such as you know to
have an account database you'd have a
product database different checkout
processes and these would all be run
behind the scenes and each of these can
be considered a micro service so the
more microservices you build into your
environment the more complexity you're
adding and the more of value it would be
to have each of these services in their
own container but as a developer you
want to be able to jump from one
container to another container so your
login account can then be passed on to
your product catalog and then be able to
move through the whole process so the
environment that you would see today
would be small like what we're showing
right now where you'd have your server
and your database and you may have a
server running on apache tomcat or a sql
server you'd have different databases
and you'd want to be able to have each
of those in their own containerized
environment so the way that duck compose
runs is that it works as a single
service so you have the docker compose
running multiple containers but the
perception is of a single service run
the thing that's great though is that
each of those containers will run in
their in isolation and but they can
interact with each other so unlike a
normal docker environment where you have
multiple docker images running
completely in isolation of each other
these are images that will run in
isolation but can interact with each
other the docker compose files are very
easy to write they're all written with a
scripting language called yaml and yaml
is an xml based language it actually
stands for yet another markup language
but it's an xml based language and it's
very easy to use the great thing about
learning yaml is that a lot of open
source tools in the devops environment
use yaml as the scripting lang and then
finally in docker compose as a user you
can actually go and and trigger all your
services within the containers to start
with a single command as you can imagine
this dramatically reduces the amount of
work that you as a developer have to do
so let's take an example of if you're
running a container one with a ninjx um
server and one with a redis database uh
you can create a yaml docker compose
file that actually has the instructions
on the containers needed to build out
both environments and then you can run
each of those environments separately
but have them connected as a single
service so the benefits of dock and
compose is that you have a single host
deployment environment you can run this
all on one piece of hardware you can
have a quick and easy configuration
using yaml scripts the productivity that
you get as a developer significantly
increases because you're not having to
have time wasted trying to configure
just traditional docker containers by
themselves you now have a way of being
able to interact with those containers
and then finally security is at the
center of all of these containers so
each of those containers are completely
isolated from each other and they are
controlled with the same level of
security that you'd have with a
traditional docker image but there is a
question here around docket compose
isn't it similar in concept to docker
swarm because at a high level it kind of
seems like both do the same thing and
the answer is well actually no they're
different there are similarities but
there are also differences and
particularly for a developer these
differences will really start coming out
in scale as you start working on your
solutions so let's look at docker
compose so docker compose will allow you
to create multiple containers on a
single host and that's the important
part having a single host which is maybe
your development pc with docker swarm it
also allows you to create multiple
containers however you have to manage
those multiple containers on multiple
hosts which makes a lot of sense if you
are running an operations environment
but not so much if you're doing a
development environment and docker
compose is scripted with yaml which is
very easy for you to be able to control
your scripts docker swarm doesn't have a
scripting technology like yaml so it's a
little bit harder to work with so what
we have here is just some basic commands
that allow you to get up and started
working with docker compose in our next
demo we're actually going to take you
through how to use all of those commands
so we're going to go ahead and do a demo
on how to use docker compose um the
first thing you want to do is check that
you have docker installed so what we're
going to do is we're going to open up
the command window and we're going to
type in docker you'll be able to see now
that we have docker installed uh if you
don't have docker installed go ahead and
install docker you can go to
google search to install docker and
they'll give you the instructions for
that we also have videos that we've
already done if once you have docked
installed then you want to do a google
search on docker compose or go to the
docker.com website and select for the
compose section and look for the install
docker compose instructions so we
already have another tab which has
the instructions already installed
you'll see on the left hand side there
are a number of docker tools you want to
expand the docker compose section select
install compose and then on the right
hand side you'll have different install
options for mac windows and linux uh if
you're installing on those platforms
make sure you copy the correct command
line so there's a couple command lines
you want to
copy copy the first one over and we
paste that in and it's going to go ahead
and download all of the files for
compose it takes a while but uh we have
to get another file so while it's
downloading we'll go get the other
command line just go back and grab it
real quick there's a little faster but
we'll copy that over there was a second
command instruction and post that
command yep there's the command right
there and that will apply the
appropriate binary and once you've done
that you can actually go ahead and
validate that you have the correct
version of docker compose installed and
for that you want to write the command
docker dash compose space dash dash
version and that will then give you a
version build once you know that you
have a version built that means that you
have everything installed correctly on
your machine so you can see here that we
have a version number which means we
have everything installed you might see
a different version number depending on
how old the video is when you're
watching it but we're using variable uh
content at the moment let's just go
ahead and clear the screen and now what
we're going to do
is create a folder where we're actually
going to install the ammo file that will
have the instructions for our docker
component environment so we're moving
the cursor to the desktop and on the
desktop we're going to create a new
folder and
using the mkdirf command and we'll call
this one docker compose f for file and
then we'll move the cursor into that new
folder by using cd command and now we
are in the folder called docker compose
f and you can go look at your desktop
and you'll see it's there and now you
want to select impound touch docker dash
compose dot yml and they'll actually
create the new uh yaml file for you and
you can use the ls list command ls
docker dash compose.yaml and they'll
allow you actually now to step in and
edit that file so let's go ahead and hit
return and that will allow us to go in
and edit the file so now i'm in the
editor and i'm going to write some
instructions um so i'm i'm going to put
a couple of mistakes in these
instructions so we can see how dr pose
catches those mistakes um so but most of
this is going to be fairly correct so
you can just type this out so we're
going to start with surfaces colon then
we'll do web colon and then we'll create
image colon and we'll do nitrix and then
we'll do a database colon and we call
the image redis and so what you can see
because we have two reference images
we're actually calling two different
images two different containers that
will be created by docker hub uh so what
we're gonna do is uh where we can
actually show you um how that's pulling
in you can go to docker hub and you can
actually see the references to the
images that we've just created so go to
docohub which is wholeheart.docker.com
and you'll see that uh nidjic's redis
those are the default names for the
images so you could do
other images like http for apache web
server if you wanted to there are a lot
of images in docker hub so suddenly have
a lot of fun building uh tools from that
environment so we're going to save those
files
in the docker image we're just going to
do colon wq to exit this screen i save
the text and this is going to run our
yaml file and you'll see the two
different error messages that will come
up so we do cat docker dash compose dot
yml and here we have a display of the
text that we just wrote and now let's go
check the validity of the file that we
just created so we'll do docker dash
compose config and we should get an
error message and there we are error
message and the reason why we have an
error message is because the spacing is
not correct in the yaml file itself so
let's go to the actual yaml file we
created let's go through and we're going
to use
just the file finder and you'll actually
open up the yaml file in your text
editor your favorite text editor and
here we have um the code that created it
and let's use the correct spacing so
that everything is spaced out
appropriately in the image and so this
is the spacing that you'd expect to see
a space a line between surfaces and the
first image and the first image is a tab
in and then it referenced what the image
is and let's go ahead and clear the
screen and we'll see whether or not
we've got that all correct it click um
let's clear the screen and we're going
to check that everything is running
correctly and we're seeing we're still
getting an error message and the reason
why we're getting another error is that
there's still a config error in this the
actual yammer file so one of the things
you have to do when you're creating a
yaml file for docker composers you
actually have to have the appropriate
version
number in there so what we have to do is
we have to go and find which is the
appropriate version and there are three
major versions one two and three
depending on the age of docker that you
have installed on your computer so if
you have the very latest version of
docker 18 and newer you would put 3.7 as
the version number and what we're going
to do is we're going to just check on
the version that we have installed and
so just clear the screen and then we'll
just do docker version and what we have
is our version of docker's
17.12 now this is the version of docker
not docker compose uh it's your main
docker environment and so if we go back
to our web browser we'll actually see
that version 17 should align with
version number 3.5 yep there we are
version 3.5 so what we want to do is go
back into our yaml file the very first
line that we want to put in above the
services is the version number and that
version number we're going to put in is
3.5 so we type in version version and we
put colon and then version number is in
brighton quotes you save that and now
what we can actually do is we can
actually go ahead and use the
single line instruction to run both of
these uh
two images that we've created because
everything is configured correctly but
with just one note you'll see that the
version number is actually at the bottom
of the list and that's just the way that
docker compose works it pulls out the
services and the images that you'd
create and then put the image the
version number at the bottom of the list
so in the presentation we talked about
how you can use one line to trigger two
or more images and so to do that we're
going to do sudo docker dash compose
dash d and it's going to create the two
environments we have the web environment
and the database environment and let's
use sudo docker ps to actually list out
that all the processes that are running
right now and there we are we actually
see all of the images are running we
have the names the commands the images
and everything's up and running and if
we want to close both of those images we
can actually use a single line of
command as well and that command will be
sudo docker dash compose down and that
closes both of the images and we can see
that all the databases and the web
services images have been closed and
pseudo docker ps where she lists that
there is nothing running and that's how
to use docker compose and with that we
come to the end of this full course
video i hope it gave you a brief
understanding of what exactly full stack
development is and i hope you enjoyed
learning these different tools
so thank you so much for being here and
watch out for more videos from us until
then keep learning and stay tuned to
simply learn